EVERYONE.
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING.
FEW NOTES BEFORE WE BEGIN.
FIRST ARMED PUBLIC COMMENT
COMMENT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
IN TWO PARTS PART ONE WILL BE
AFTER ISSUE NUMBER ONE SO THAT
WE CAN HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ALL ISSUES INCLUDING ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS.
RELATED TO CONTINUE WITH CARE
REFORM.
PART TWO WILL BE AFTER WE HEAR
THE PANELS ON SHOES TO THROUGH
NINE OR THE BALANCE OF THE
DISCUSSION PORTION OF THE AGENDA.
WILL ALSO ASK FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE NON DISCUSSION ISSUES
THAT ARE INCLUDED AT THE END OF
THE AGENDA.
ALL PANELISTS ARE ASKED TO
MAINTAIN REMARKS TWO UNDER THREE
MINUTES PLEASE.
PUBLIC COMMENT TO WILL BE
RESTRICTED TO ONE MINUTE EACH
AND OUR STAFF WILL HOLD UP A
GENTLE REMINDER WHEN.
IT'S YOUR TIME TO CLOSE.
WITH THAT LET'S BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE WELCOME COLLEAGUES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
FUNDING UPDATE RELATED TO THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM EFFORTS.
ALSO CALLED THE C. C. R..
PLEASE ALSO COVER THE B. C. P.
USE THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH C.
C. R. [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF FEATURE
BINGO WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR THERE -- I WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND THANK YOUR STAFF THEY
DID A VERY THOROUGH MULTI PAGE
JOB DESCRIBING THE C. C. R. I'M
GONNA RUN THROUGH IT VERY
QUICKLY FOR REFERENCE WITH SOME
HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS BUT I DON'T
WANT TO TAKE.
THE TIME TO READ IT BACK TO YOU
EITHER.
WONDERFUL -- THE C. C. R. THANK
YOU FOR DEFINING THE ACRONYM --
RESULTED FROM LEGISLATION A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO THAT LED TO
A MULTI YEAR ENGAGEMENT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM.
THAT EFFORT CULMINATED IN A
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTEEN REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ACCOMPANIED WITH
A JANUARY -- BUDGET PROPOSAL --
FROM FROM THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION HAD A MULTI YOUR
VIEW ON A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE TO IMPROVE THE
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILY --
IN CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
AROUND CHILD WELFARE OF COURSE --
THE THERE WERE A VARIETY OF OF
GOALS OF THE OF THAT WITHIN THAT
BUT PRIMARILY AROUND THE
REDUCING THE USE OF CONGREGATE
CARE -- WE WE FOUND THAT WHILE
OF COURSE THERE ARE GOOD
CONGREGATE CARE PROVIDERS TO
PRODUCE GOOD OUTCOMES BY AND
LARGE THE ASSOCIATIONS THAT A
DEMOGRAPHIC LEVEL -- ARE BETTER
FOR USE WHEN THEY ARE IN HOME
BASED FAMILY CARE SITUATIONS
WITH IT WITH A A MORE LIMITED --
GROUP GROUP AROUND THEM -- THAT
THEY CAN BE CARED FOR YOU
OBVIOUSLY CAN'T JUST TAKE KIDS
OUT OF A GROUP HOME YOU HAVE TO
HAVE SOME PLACE TO PUT THEM.
SO THAT WAS THE REFLECTION IN
THE INITIAL INVESTMENTS MADE IN
THE C. C. R. IN TERMS OF FAMILY --
RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
SUPPORT.
IN -- RE RE CASTING THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE VARIOUS
FACILITY TYPES THAT WE HAVE.
A MAKING SETTING THE EXPECTATION
THAT GROUP HOMES WOULD BE PHASED
OUT IN THE CHILD WELFARE ARENA
IN FAVOR OF SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS --
I DON'T WANT TO USE THE WORD
CRISIS STABILIZATION BUT THEY
WERE ENVISIONED AS SIX MONTHS
MAXIMUM PLACEMENTS AND LAST
THOSE STRENGTHS AND NEEDS OF THE
CHILD AND YOUTH INDICATED A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME WAS NEEDED.
AND THAT REALLY THE FOCUS OF OUR
EFFORT WAS TO GET HOME BASE
FAMILY KERR -- WE HAVE GONE TO
SINCE JANUARY TWENTY FIFTEEN
THROUGH SEVERAL YEARS OF POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND GUIDANCE A LOT
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- WITH
COUNTIES WITH PROVIDERS IN THE
SYSTEM AND WE'VE BEEN MOVE NOW
BEYOND THE JUST THE POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND INTO THE
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE AND MORE
NOW A COUPLE YEARS INTO THAT.
AND YOU'LL SEE THAT REFLECTED IN
THE IN THE FUNDING -- THAT THAT --
IS IS PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET AND
HAS BEEN PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET --
IN ADDITION TO EFFORTS TO A
RETAIN AND RECRUIT FAMILIES AND
TO CHANGE THE THE MIX OF
PROVIDER TYPES AND OUR SERVICE
EXPECTATIONS OF THOSE PROVIDERS.
A CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING
CONCEPTS WERE A MAJOR FEATURE OF
THIS IT'S IMPORTANT.
I THINK IT'S NO SECRET TO
ANYBODY THAT WHEN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
THEM AND THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'VE
HAD A VOICE AND BEEN ABLE TO BE
HEARD THEY HAVE MORE BY INTO
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THEM.
AND SO CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING
AROUND DECISIONS ABOUT PLACEMENT
ABOUT SERVICE NEEDS -- ABOUT
DURATION OF CARING OVERALL CASE
MANAGEMENT AND WHAT'S IN A COURT
REPORT THOSE ARE ALL FEATURES OF
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING.
EXCUSE ME SACRAMENTO ALLERGIES --
THE OTHER MAJOR FEATURE -- WELL
IT WAS A DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW
RATE SYSTEM FOR ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS PRIOR TO THIS -- WE'VE HAD
AN AGE BASED SYSTEM WHERE AS A
CHILD GOT OLDER RATE RATES
CHANGED -- WE'VE DOW IMPLEMENTED
A RATE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S BASED ON THE SS STRENGTHS
AND NEEDS OF THE CHILD.
AND INTENDED TO BETTER SUPPORT
FAMILIES -- ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
AND TEN HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLAR A
MONTH INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT
GIVEN TO FAMILIES.
A CHANGE IN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE PROVIDE FOR SERVICES AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT TO FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES -- AND OTHER
CHANGES -- TO FOR EXAMPLE THEY
THE PHASE OUT OF THE GROUP HOME
RATES AND REPLACEMENT WITH A
SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM I'M GONNA TRY NOT TO
CALL THEM S. T. R. T. P. S. --
AS DESCRIBED IN YOUR AGENDA THEY
HAVE NEW RATES AS WELL -- THOSE
THOSE ARE REALLY THE HIGHLIGHTS
I WANTED TO HIT FOR YOU THERE
WAS MAYBE ONE OTHER ON PAGE
THIRTEEN THERE'S A MENTION OF
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND THAT'S BEEN A HUGE FOCUS FOR
MANY YEARS IN CALIFORNIA EVEN
DATING BEFORE THE C. C. R..
WE KNEW IT AS KATIE A LITIGATION
KATIE.
A WAS THE THE NAME OF THE YOUTH --
IN THAT LITIGATION -- AND WE'VE
DONE AND MADE GREAT STRIDES IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASING THE
ABILITY OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN
CARE TO ACCESS NECESSARY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AS I MENTIONED WHEN WE RE CAST
THE EXPECTATIONS OF OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FEATURES PROMINENTLY AND NOT.
AND THE SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH CONTRACTS AS A AS
A PRIMARY FOCUS OF THEIR SERVICE
PREVENTION.
IN TERMS OF FINDING YOUR CHART
ON PAGE.
SIXTEEN OF AT THE TOP THERE ARE
LATE LAYS OUT THAT THE THE
RECENT HISTORY AND A PROPOSAL --
FOR FOR C. C. R. YOU WILL NOTICE
THE TOP FOUR LINES ALIGNED WITH
THE MAJOR THEMES THAT I TALKED
ABOUT THE THE THE RATE CARE --
PAYMENTS THE CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMS THE THE SUPPORT FOR FOSTER
PARENT CARE GIVERS AND RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL WHAT WE USED TO
CALL A FOSTER FAMILY HOME IS NOW
KNOWN AS A RESOURCE -- FAMILY --
SO THAT'S A TERMINOLOGY CHANGE
BUT THE CONCEPT IS THE SAME
THOSE ARE THAT THE HOME BASED
FAMILY KERR -- PROVIDERS CARE
GIVERS THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE DISCUSSED
IN YOUR AGENDA -- THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CHANGE MANAGEMENT THAT'S
BEEN DIFFICULT UNDERSTANDING
ROLES AND EXPECTATIONS THE THE
TRANSFER OF OF FAMILIES FROM A
FOSTER FAMILY DESIGNATION TO A
RESOURCE FAMILY DESIGNATION.
HAS BEEN SLOWER N
EVERYBODY ANTICIPATED -- THERE'S
BEEN SOME INVESTMENTS AND BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND AND THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET TO GET -- THROUGH A
BACKLOG TO APPROVE THOSE MORE
TIMELY -- BUT THERE WAS A
FUNDING AUGMENTATION MADE A
COUPLE YEARS NOW -- THAT WE USED
TO PAY -- FAMILY CARE GIVER WHEN
THE CHILD I AM SORRY WHEN THEY
HOME WAS APPROVED AS A PLACEMENT.
BUT VERY OFTEN WE FIND PLACEMENT
PRIOR TO APPROVAL AND SO THERE
WAS A PERIOD OF TIME WHERE
FAMILIES DIDN'T HAVE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THAT MAYBE WOULD HAVE
HELPED THEM.
EITHER BE A BETTER CARE GIVER OR
BE WILLING TO ACCEPT A CHILD IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO THAT'S A
MAJOR INVESTMENT THE LEVEL OF
CARE PROTOCOL TOOL HELPS US TO
SIGN THE NEEDS BASE RATE TO A
CHILD.
CANS THE CHILD ASSESSMENT OF
NEEDS AND STRENGTHS IS THE
FUNCTIONAL ASSESSMENT WE'RE
USING TO IDENTIFY THE NEEDSAND
STRENGTHS OF THE YOUTH.
AND THEN THERE ARE THE OTHER
BUCKET WHICH I WON'T DESCRIBE
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY MANY
THINGS LUMPED INTO THAT -- ON
PAGE SEVENTEEN THERE'S A MENTION
OF A COUPLE BCP'S.
A BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS -- AT
THE BOTTOM OF SEVENTEEN AND ON
TO EIGHTEEN OTHER WAS RECENT
LEGISLATION PASSED LAST YEAR --
AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY -- THAT
TALKED ABOUT INTEGRATED SYSTEMS
OF CARE -- AND AND HOW WE GET
EVERYBODY WHO NEEDS TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE CARE OF A KID
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY CROSSOVER A
FOSTER YOUTH ISN'T JUST A FOSTER
YOUTH THEY'RE ATTENDING SCHOOL
THEY MAY HAVE.
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE DISABILITY
SYSTEM MENTAL HEALTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH -- WE HAVE YOU THROUGH OR
DO ONLY INVOLVED WITH PROBATION
SO MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S EXPECTED OF
THEM AND MEETING THE NEEDS OF
THE USE.
IT WE'RE ASKING FOR STATE
POSITIONS TO TO WORK ON THAT.
AND THE SECOND ITEM ON THE TOP
OF PAGE -- EIGHTEEN IS -- C. C.
R. WAS CUT TITLE COMPLIANCE
WORKLOAD BUT THESE THIRTY FOUR
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THE CORE OF OUR
CC OUR IMPLEMENTATION TEAM AT
THE DEPARTMENT WE'RE ASKING
THEIR RENT -- IT RENEW ALL AN
EXTENSION -- HERE THROUGH TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO RECOGNIZING THE
PACE OF CCR HASN'T BEEN WHAT IT
IS THESE ARE OUR RESIDENT
EXPERTS PROVIDING ASSISTANCE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE WORK
ACTUALLY GETS DONE.
I WON'T DISCUSS THE ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS BECAUSE WERE ARE
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO GO THROUGH
THEM IN THE NEXT COUPLE AGENDA
ITEMS -- AND THERE'S A FEW PAGES
STARTING ON PAGE TWENTY WHERE
THE LA -- GOES THROUGH A NUMBER
OF COMMENTS WE FOUND WHAT THE LA --
HAD TO SAY ABOUT CC ARE AT THIS
POINT WAS VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
FOCUSED ON WHAT IT TAKES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL -- WE LARGELY AGREE
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE LA --
AND WILL HAVE SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT LEVEL OF CARE IN RESPONSE
TO QUESTIONS THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO US IN THE AGENDA AHEAD OF
TIME.
A WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS OR I CAN -- TURN IT TO
MY COLLEAGUE -- GREG ROSE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION TO GO
THROUGH THE QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA.
THANKS MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
GREG ROSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
AND COUPLE OF THINGS I WANTED TO
MENTION BEFORE ANSWER THE THE
FIRST QUESTION.
YEP YOU DIRECTOR TRIPPING CAN
MENTION SOME OF THE THE THE THE
SUCCESSES AND THE CHALLENGES OF
OF C. C. R. I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE A COUPLE OF
THINGS AS WELL. ONE AND WE'RE
SEEING A DECLINE OF OVER A
THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE IN
CONGREGATE CARE OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS -- THAT THEY'RE THE
NUMBER OF CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMS
IS INCREASING SIGNIFICANTLY BOTH
ON CHILD WELFARE AND ON
PROBATION MANAGE CASES WE'RE
SEEING SOME SOMBER SOLID
PARTNERSHIPS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT I THINK WILL BE --
THAT WILL BE FOUNDATIONAL TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE THE THE SYSTEM
FORWARD.
AND AND THERE'S A LOT OF UPSTATE
COLLABORATION WITH LOOK WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ON THIS CASE
SPECIFIC SITUATIONS -- SO THAT
WE CAN BETTER CERTAIN THE WEEK
WE CAN LEARN AND WE CAN ALSO
BETTER SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE -- AND
HELP THEM GET THE NEEDS THE THE
THE THINGS THEY NEED.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE A A
COUPLE OF AREAS THAT WE I THINK
ARE IMPORTANT WE FOCUS ON IN
THIS -- THIS COMING YEAR AS WE
DO IMPLEMENTATION ONE OF THOSE
IS THERE'S THERE'S A AROUND
EIGHT HUNDRED YOUNG PEOPLE IN --
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES THAT --
ON MAY NOT OR ARE SOME MAY NOT
AND SOME HAVE TOLD US THEY WILL
NOT BE TRANSITIONING -- THE THE
DAY THE COUNTIES ASSESSMENT OF
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE IN CARE IS
ABOUT SEVENTY SOME ODD PERCENT
72% OF THEM WE DON'T MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR FOR A SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAM AND SO IT TO THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE I THINK THAT WE WE WE AS
A AS A AS A GROUP OF COLLEAGUES
NEED TO FOCUS ON CLEARLY WE NEED.
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THE
BACKLOG OF THE RFA APPLICATIONS
AND THEIR AND AND I THINK THE
THE THE KEY AS I THINK IS
MENTIONED ACTUALLY IN THE AGENDA
ONE OF THE CORNERSTONES OF THE
AT OF THE OF THE INITIATIVE.
IS HIGH QUALITY CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR
AND PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT THEM
HAVE BOYS AND CHOICE AND WE ARE
SEAT WE'RE SEEING THE THE AS I
MENTIONED WE'RE SEEING THE
INCREASE OF THOSE -- WE ALSO ARE
WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE WITH HIGH HIGH QUALITY
AND WITH HIGH FIDELITY WITH THAT
SAID I'M HAPPY -- TO TRANSITION
INTO ACT ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE POSED INTO THE AGENDA.
THE THE FIRST TWO QUESTIONS ARE
ARE ARE SIMILAR IN NATURE AND
AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR JAMAICA
MENTIONED THAT -- THERE HAD BEEN
SOME INVESTMENTS IN THESE AREAS
OF THE THE SPECIFICALLY IS A
QUESTION ABOUT -- ABOUT THE
ELIMINATION AND I WOULD SAY THAT
THE A COUPLE OF POINTS ONE THE
THE COUNTIES HAVE HAD TO HAVE A
PRIOR TO TO REALIGNMENT AND AND
HAVE HAD SOME RESPONSIBILITY. TO
DO -- APPROVALS AND THEY'VE HAD
SOME RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION.
THE ADMINISTRATION CLEARLY KNEW
GET GIVEN THE THE THAT HEAVY
LEFT IN FRONT OF US.
AND THE INTENT AND THE AND THE
LEVEL OF INTENSITY NEEDED -- FOR
TO TO DO RECRUITMENT RETENTION
AND SUPPORT -- CREATED TO IN
ESSENCE A THREE YEAR -- THAT A
THREE THREE YEAR FUNDING TO
PROVIDE -- THAT UP FRONT
INVESTMENT IN IN THESE
ACTIVITIES SO THE THE REDUCTION
HAS BEEN THE REDUCTION IN THESE
FUNDS IT HAS BEEN AT WHAT'S
PLANNED -- WHEN WE HAVE FROM THE
FIRST YEAR -- OF THAT ADDITIONAL --
ROLLOUT OF THE IMPLEMENTATION --
AND SO BOTH WITH THAT BOTH WITH
THE THE SO CALLED SHIPPERS FUNDS
THAT FOSTER PARENT RECRUITMENT
RETENTION PONDS AND AND THE OUR
FATE DOLLARS WERE INTENDED TO
PROVIDE -- A SURGE OF ACTIVITY
TO TO ALSO IDEA I I IDENTIFY
AREAS THE OF IN FOR INNOVATION
AT AND FUTURE -- REINVESTMENT
BYE BYE COUNTIES -- WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO GO THROUGH ALL THE
QUESTIONS OR YOU WANT US WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO STOP AFTER EACH.
ONE DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT
ISRAEL OKAY.
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT BEFORE WE
CONTINUE -- YOU -- INDICATED
THAT THERE IS A BACKLOG IN OUR
FAVOR APPROVAL CAN YOU TELL ME
WHAT THE BACKLOG IS OR HOW LONG
IT'S TAKING I KNOW THERE WAS A
DISCUSSION LAST YEAR AND WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO
ADD. TO THE BACKLOG IS DECLINE
IS DECLINING -- THE SPECIFIC
NUMBERS I A CAN HAVE FOR YOU
BEFORE THE END OF THE HEARING I
DON'T HAVE THEM IT IN IN FRONT
OF ME AT THE MO THEY'VE BEEN
DEBT THERE'D.
THEY'VE DECLINED BY -- AS I
RECALL THE TWENTY SOME ODD
PERCENT THE TIME TO APPROVAL IS
STILL OPEN BUT IT'S STILL OVER
NINETY DAYS SIGNIFICANTLY OVER
NINETY DAYS.
THE THE THE THE TREND IS THAT
THE THE BACKLOG IS TRENDING DOWN
AND THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
IS TRENDING UP.
SO -- DEAD.
SO AT THAT THE US THAT TIME FOR
APPROVAL IS IS DECLINING BUT
IT'S STILL IT'S STILL IN
EXISTENCE I KNOW AND I IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY LAST YEAR WE
HAD THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT --
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
APPLICATIONS WERE APPROVED IT
WITHIN THE NINETY DAYS AND WE
HAD ASSURANCES LAST YEAR THAT --
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN AND SO
THAT'S WHY I WANT TO KNOW
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE THE YOU
KNOW HOW LONG IT'S TAKING AND
WHY.
SINCE LAST YEAR WE HAD THE
DISCUSSION WHY HAS ANY CHANGE
RIGHT AFTER THE PROMISES SO THAT
SOME AT THE THERE ARE. FOUR ON
THE PLACEMENTS PRIOR TO APPROVAL
SO THESE WERE THE YOUNG PEOPLE
IN RELATIVE CARE -- THE THE
THEIR OF THE THE BACKLOG THE
LAST I CHECKED WITH ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND SET AND AND SIXTY
SEVEN CASES.
THE THEY ARE AND AND 61% OF
THOSE CASES THAT ARE AT THAT ARE
THAT ARE GOING ON BEYOND THE
NINETY DAYS ARE -- ARE -- HAVE
BEEN GRANTED GOOD COSTS OF THEIR
THINGS THAT THE THE BOTH THE
COUNTY AND THE CHECK AND THAT
AND FAMILY ARE OF WITHOUT
WITHOUT THEIR CONTROL SOME OF
THEM HAPPENED TO DO WITH.
THE LENGTH OF TIME RIGHT WHAT IT
COST ME GOOD CAUSE MEANS THAT
THAT THERE IS A THERE IS A A
REASONABLE THERE'S ARE A
REASONABLE REASON. FOR THAT FOR
THAT FOR THAT THE THE TIME TO GO
BEYOND NINETY DAYS SO FOR
EXAMPLE SOME OF THOSE THINGS
HAPPEN TO BE THE TIME IT TAKES
TO GET A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECK COMPLETED.
SOME OF THEM HAVE TO HAVE TO DO
WITH SOME OF THAT WHICH IS THE
THAT THAT ONE OF THE LARGER ONES
AND SOME OF THEM HAVE TO DO WITH
SOME -- PHYSICAL PLANT THINGS IN
THE HOME.
EXAMPLES ARE SOMETIMES IT HAS TO
DO WITH -- SOMETIMES IT HAS TO
DO WITH OF UP APPROPRIATE
FENCING OR SOMETIMES IT HAS TO
DO WITH -- WITH -- SMOKE
DETECTORS AND OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS BUT BUT IT'S IT'S IT'S
IT'S IT'S THOSE KINDS OF
PHYSICAL PLANT THINGS BY BUT AND
YOU KNOW Y. ALLEY I THINK WE
WERE HERE LAST YEAR WHEN WE HAD
THESE CONVERSATIONS -- SMOKE
DETECTORS ARE.
TRIVIAL IN MY OPINION SEARCH LE
IT'S LARGER THAT THAT THE THE
THE THE WHOLE I DON'T HAVE MY
LIST TO AND FROM THE I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
THE THE THE THEY TEND TO IT THAT
THAT HOME.
THINGS HAPPEN TO BE THEY THEY'RE
OFTEN.
SO THEY'RE THEY'RE FLAUNTING
WHAT THEY'RE ALSO THEY'RE ALSO
SITUATIONS WHERE A FAMILY MOVED.
TO SEND SOMEBODY TO GET THOSE
LISTS FOR YOU SURE IN THE
MEANTIME WHILE WE'RE HAVING THIS
COME I EAT I WILL HI I HAVE SOME
OF THE INFORMATION -- IN MY
BACKPACK I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THERE ARE THERE ARE SITUATIONS
IN WHICH FAMILIES WILL MOVE --
LIKE AT AT B. TIP TO HAVE TO
FIND ANOTHER TO AS THEY'VE TAKEN
ON THE YOUNG PERSON.
AT MICH THROUGH THE APPROVAL AND
THAT REQUIRES ANOTHER HOME AND
GROUNDS INSPECTION SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF THERE'S A FEW THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT THAT -- ARE AT
THAT -- HAVE THAT THE CURRENT
THERE'S A NUMBER SIX AS I SAID
61% OF THESE -- OF THE BACK OF
THAT.
TIME TO APPROVAL PAST NINETY
DAYS EVENTS ALL ITS ON THE
MEANTIME I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT
AT CHURCH TRYING TO HAVE A
DIALOGUE HAD A FEW -- IN THE
MEANTIME WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE
KIDS THOSE KIDS ARE IN
PLACEMENTS WITH THEIR RELATIVE.
AT AT THAT POINT THERE THE
RELATIVES ARE BEING REIMBURSED
FOR THAT FOR THAT THERE OKAY SO
WITH THAT WAS THAT THAT BIGELOW
A DISCUSSION I ONE RELATED
DISCUSSION INSTEAD OF AN
ARGUMENT LAST YEAR.
ABOUT HOW LONG IT WAS TAKING FOR
THE OUR PAY. FOR THE FOR THE
FAMILIES TO RECEIVE PAYMENT NOW
SO THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS IS
THERE A BACKLOG IN PAIN THOSE
FAMILIES.
NOT THAT WE'RE AWARE OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE OKAY.
ARE INEVITABLY I'M SURE THAT
SOMEBODY COULD FIND A
SITUATIONAL SOMEBODY I'M.
SOMEBODY IS ONE THING BUT THE
LIGHT IN GENERAL AS HE IS CLEAR
THAT WE CAN PAY UP TO A YEAR OF
PLACEMENT PRIOR TO APPROVAL OKAY
SOLD MIKE IN SEOUL JUST TO BE
CLEAR.
SO FAMILIES ARE BEING PAID
CREATES ARE IN THE HOMES IN THE
MEAN AROUND IT'S JUST THE
OFFICIAL APPROVAL HASN'T BEEN
GRANTED CORRECT PLACEMENT
PENDING APPROVAL.
THE IMPROVE AS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN OUR OPINION BUT IT'S NOT
DELAYING THE WELL BEING AND CARE
OF THE CASE IS THAT ONCE AGAIN
WHICH IS OUR FOR MISTER THAT
WORKERS HERE THAT THAT WAS BOB
BIG.
DISCUSSION LAST YEAR OKAY AND
THEN -- YOU SAID THERE'S SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN CASES.
OF A CAN YOU ELABORATE ON THAT.
THAT'S THE THE BACKLOG OF THE OF
THE ROUTE THAT THE OF THE BEYOND
THE NINETY DAYS SO THE MORE THE
RELATIVE AND SIXTY SEVEN CASES.
GIVE OR TAKE A FEW BRIGHT AND
THE MAKE THE THE BAR. 99% OF
THESE ARE OUR CHILDREN THAT ARE
PLACED.
CORRECT THE OF THAT THAT NUMBER
I PROVIDE THEY'RE ALL PLACE
THERE THAT THEY'RE ALL THEY ALL
OUR RELATIVES WITH THAT ARE AT
THAT HAVE CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE
WHO ARE BEING COMPENSATED WHO
GET THE STIPEND THE FOSTER CARE
STIPEND FOR WHILE THAT WHILE THE
WORK IS GOING THAT'S GREAT.
NEWS BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A
BIG A TOPIC OF DISCUSSION AFTER
A LOT OF THE FOLKS WERE HERE AND
INDICATING THAT THERE WAS NO --
PAYMENT FOR THEM FOR IT RIGHT
YOU TO FOUR MONTHS AND YOU KNOW
SO THAT HAS BEEN COMPLETELY THAT
ALL THAT PART HAS BEEN SOLVED
BASED AS THE THE THE THE ACTUAL
APPROVAL TIME.
IS TAKING THE SOMETIME AT THE
BASE AND THE FINAL CORRECT.
OKAY CORRECTS OF FOLKS GET YOUR
THAT WORKS ARE BEING SUPPORTED
OKAY -- BUT STILL FOR THAT OKAY
WERE YOU HAVING UP ARE VERY.
THIS IS MY LEASE -- BUT NO I'M
I'M REALLY THANKFUL THEN BECAUSE
IT FEELS NOW THAT YOU ARE
LISTENING -- WE HAD A BIG HUGE
DISCUSSION LAST YEAR AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
BECAUSE AGAIN I THESE ARE KIDS
THAT THAT NEED OUR SUPPORT AND
FAMILIES IN NEED OUR SUPPORT SO
IF YOU'RE GUARANTEEING ME THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT IF YOU
CAN JUST YOU KNOW GIVE ME THE A
DVD OF THE DATA TO SUPPORT THAT
I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE IT
ABSOLUTELY WE CAN DO THAT --
WERE REPORTING ON C. C. R.
IMPLEMENTATION PURSUANT TO SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WAS JUST
LAST MONTH WE GOT TOGETHER WITH
YOUR STAFF AND WE PROVIDE A
TWENTY SOME ODD PAGE REPORT THAT
INCLUDES A CHART WITH THAT
INFORMATION.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
IF YOU WOULD LIKE IT AS HE
EXPLAINED -- THERE'S BEEN A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE VOLUME
OF PEOPLE WANTING TO BE CARE
GIVERS AND NEEDING TO MOVE
THROUGH THE PIPELINE AT THE SAME
TIME THAT'S HAPPENED.
WE'VE MANAGED TO BRING THE
BACKLOG DOWN AND I WHEN I SAY WE
I MEAN US WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS -- TO BRING THAT THAT
BACKLOG DOWN IT IS MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION IN TIME TO
APPROVAL IS MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT ALL OF THAT SAID
AGAIN.
CHILDREN ARE GETTING THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE AVERAGE
IT'S PROBABLY IN THE WRITTEN
WORD IS HUNDRED NINETY DAYS SITE.
IT'S ABOUT SAY NOT BY.
WILL DO NOW IS THAT WE'LL WHEN
WE HEAR FROM.
MEDINA -- FRANK JUSTIN RYAN --
AND THEN.
PERHAPS HAVE SOME OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS YOUR ANSWERS ARE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE DEAN OF COCOA.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES GOOD AFTERNOON --
SPECIFICALLY I AM I'M.
GOING TO BE ADDRESSING QUESTIONS
FOUR AND FIVE AROUND SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
QUESTION NUMBER FOUR HOW DO THE
DEPARTMENTS TRACK WHETHER MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
ARE BEING PROVIDED TO CHILDREN
WHO NEED THOSE SERVICES WHETHER
OR NOT IN AN S. T. R. T. PEER
GROUP HOME -- AND THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS -- DO PRODUCE
QUARTERLY REPORTS THAT TRACK --
FOSTER CARE CHILDREN CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE WHO MAY NEED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY ARE GETTING THOSE
SERVICES.
THE CHILD WELFARE IS REQUIRED --
TO SCREEN AND ALL CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND THEN MAKE A
REFERRAL -- TO COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH -- IF THE CHILD SCREENS
POSITIVE AND THEN THAT IS
DOCUMENTED IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
TAKES THAT DATA -- FROM THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND MATCHES
IT TO OUR DATA TO DETERMINE WHAT
SERVICES THE CHILDREN ARE
GETTING -- IF IN FACT THEY'RE
GETTING THE SERVICES.
SO -- WE WE DO THAT MATCH WE DO
IT QUARTERLY TO ENSURE THAT THE
CHILDREN ARE GETTING THE SERVICE
WE CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND TRACK
THAT DATA.
AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES --
TO EXAMINE AND REFINED THAT DATA
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
FOUR AND BEFORE WE GET THE FIVE
WHAT IS TODAY TO TELL ME ABOUT
THE DELIVERY -- IT TELLS US THAT
THE CHILDREN THAT ARE ACTUALLY
MAKING IT INTO -- THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM MOST OF
THOSE CHILDREN ARE RECIEVING
SPECIAL TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
WHEN YOU SEE THOSE WHO MAKE IT
YEAH?
IT DOESN'T HELP OF MY MY MY
MICROPHONE IS OFF FOR THOSE WHO
WHO.
YOU SAY FOR THOSE WHO MAKE AT
THE END.
WHAT DETERMINES OUR WHAT IS WHAT
IS THE HOLD BACK FOR THOSE SO --
THERE IS SOME DATA COLLECTION
AND I THINK SOME DATA
IMPROVEMENT ISSUES -- THAT NEED
TO HAPPEN WE ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH SIDE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES -- CAN ONLY
TRACK ONCE THE CHILD HAS MADE IT
INTO THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM AND SEE IF THEY HAVE
SERVICES SO PERHAPS I WILL.
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO SPEAK TO ON YOUR
QUESTION.
OKAY SURE REGRETS AGAIN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THE THE EIGHTY
LIMITED THAT. EIGHTY POINT 3% OF
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO SCREEN
POSITIVE GET REFERRED -- TO GET
REFERRED OVER TO THE OVER TO TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH ACT HIM SORRY.
8083% OF THOSE WHO HAVE HAVE
HAVE SCREENED -- GET IT GET A
REFER SCREEN POSITIVE GET A
REFERRAL INTO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THERE AND THERE'S A
MEDICAL NECESSITY REQUIRE EVAN
OUT OF MEDICAL NECESSITY
ASSESSMENT THAT'S DONE.
ON THE MENTAL HEALTH SIDE SO --
THE THE THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT SCREEN
POSITIVE -- OUT SO THERE'S A
SCREENING AND THEN THERE'S AN
ASSESSMENT TO THE CHILD WELFARE
WORKER DOES A IN ESSENCE A ROUGH
SAFETY IF YOU WILL THAT THE
CHILD MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA --
HAD CERTAIN EXPERIENCES THEN
THEY WILL -- THEY WILL BE
REFERRED OVER TO THAT SPENT TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH -- SPECIAL NOW
PROGRAM SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM AT THAT POINT DOES A
MORE CLINICAL ASSESSMENT TO SEE
IF THE CHILD MEETS THE CRITERIA
FOR MEDICAL NECESSITY.
AND IT'S A THEN WENT THEN --
FOLKS WILL THEN THE SERVICES
BEGAN BEYOND THAT SHOULD NOTE
THAT THERE ARE YOU KNOW -- SOME
SOME SOME FOLKS THAT HAVE
SCREENED POSITIVE WILL NOT MEET
THE MEDICAL NECESSITY
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT STE THE THE
ONLY SERVICE THEY WILL GET WILL
BE AN ASSESSMENT.
BECAUSE THEY THEY DON'T MEET THE
CRITERIA FOR FURTHER -- FOR
FURTHER SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH.
WHEN WE HAVE FRANK MEGA I HAD A
GERMAN JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT ON
THIS PARTICULAR POINT IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH -- THAT WHAT
WE DO KNOW FROM DATA AT THE H.
C. S. IS THAT A ROUGHLY THREE IN
TEN KIDS IN OUT OF HOME CARE.
MEET THE ENGAGEMENT RATE WHICH
IS A STATE THE TERM RATE -- THAT
IS THE SORT OF THE METRIC OF
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT IN THE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
AND THAT MEANS FIVE CONTACTS IN
A YEAR -- AND SO SEVEN IN TEN
ARE NOT AND THAT'S IN PART
BECAUSE AS MR ROSE SAID THAT.
THE MEDICAL NECESSITY DEFINITION.
AS IT'S APPLIED SCREENS SOME
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF KIDS IN
OUT OF HOME CARE OUT OF THE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND TO SOME EXTENT IT'S GOOD FOR
KIDS NOT GETTING SICK AND TO THE
SCREENING IN THE FIRST PLACE BUT
NOT TO HAVE THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONVERSATION HERE BECAUSE THE
BANK COMMITTEES.
YOUR COMMITTEES HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AT SOME LENGTH ALL YEAR BUT THIS
QUESTION OF WHAT IS MEDICAL
NECESSITY.
AND HOW IS IT HELPING ARE NOT
HELPING KIDS TO EXPERIENCE THE
TRAUMA OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT AND
A REMOVAL -- I THINK IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT ONE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE IT SEEMS
COUNTERINTUITIVE AN INCONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT KIDS IN
FOSTER CARE OF EXPERIENCED.
THAT THINK THAT SEVEN OUT OF TEN
OF THEM WOULD NOT.
NEED ANY SUPPORT FROM OUR
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
MEANINGFUL SUPPORT FROM OUR
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND THE ISSUE THERE IS THE
DEFINITION OF MEDICAL NECESSITY.
IS THAT SOMETHING THEM I HOPE WE
CAN WORK ON ON THAT.
YES WONDERFUL AND CLEAN UP --
MISS COOK OFFS -- COULD YOU
ADDRESS QUESTION NUMBER FIVE
BEFORE WE MOVE ON SURE HAPPY TO
SO QUESTION NUMBER -- FIVE
REGARDING THE PROVISION OF
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND HOW IT IS PROGRESSING -- AND
AREAS PERHAPS NEEDING ATTENTION --
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS OR OR
YEAR AND A THE PROVISION
ESPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WE ARE SEEING IS
PROGRESSING -- IT MAY VERY BY S.
T. R. A. T. P. -- BUT BUT IT IS
PROGRESSING -- AREAS OF WHERE --
I THINK THERE MIGHT BE SOME
ATTENTION NEEDED IS PERHAPS ON
THE LOWER LEVEL GROUP HOMES --
WHO ARE TRANSITIONING TO S. T.
R. T. PEAS -- IN THAT THEY MAY
HAVE NOT OR HAVE NOT DEALT WITH
ON CHILDREN AND YOUTH -- WITH
THESE INTENSIVE -- NEEDS AND
ALSO -- MAY NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH
THE SPECIAL TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND REQUIREMENTS AND
THE WAY THAT -- SERVICES ARE
EXPECTED TO BE PROVIDED -- AND
SO IT'S A STEEP LEARNING CURVE
ON FOR THEMSO I WOULD SAY THAT --
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENTS
CONTINUE -- TO BRAINSTORM ON HOW
WE CAN ASSIST SUPPORT -- THAT
LEARNING CURVE WHAT IS IT YOU
NEED. TO BE ABLE TO SHOW -- THE
S. TRT PEAS.
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO?
IS SIX A STEEP LEARNING CURVE
WHAT WHAT IS IT THEY NEED.
I FOUND WHAT IS IT WE'RE GOING
TO DO TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE IT.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE SO THAT.
WE DON'T LEAVE ANYBODY BEHIND --
I APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION --
THERE HAS BEEN A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS STARTING FROM --
TRAINING -- A REGIONAL TRAININGS
THAT HAPPENED SOME AT A HIGHER
LEVEL BUT TO TRY TO INFORM IT'S
BEEN GOING ON REGIONAL COOKIES
BROUGHT THE LAST TWO YEARS TO
EDUCATE -- S. T. R. T. PEAS OR
GROUP -- GROUP HOMES LOOKING TO
CONVERT THERE IS --
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS THAT
HAPPENED BETWEEN THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS WHERE WILL ACTUALLY
NEED -- WORK WITH -- GROUP HOMES
THAT HAVE QUESTIONS -- I THERE
IT IS COLLABORATIVE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH
THE PLACE IN AGENCIES AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN SO I THINK
THERE'S A NUMBER OF SUPPORTS.
THE AT VARIOUS LEVELS THAT CAN
HELP WITH THAT LEARNING CURVE.
CLEARLY IT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
IN THE NEXT MONTH OR MONTHS AS%
OPPOSED TO IN THE NEXT YEAR OR
YEARS -- IS THERE A PLAN IS
THEIR SPECIFIC PLAN TO TO DEAL
WITH THIS [inaudible]
TRANSITION PERIOD.
I KNOW THAT YOU SAY THAT FOR TWO
YEARS THERE'S BEEN SOME
BRAINSTORMING BUT VERY
SPECIFICALLY AND YOU FOR TRYING
TO GET FROM POINT A TO POINT B..
IS THERE A PLAN SO THAT WE GET
THERE.
THE THE THE THE WAY THE THE LEAD
THAT.
THERE IS A PLAN THE PLAN THE IS
BASED PARTLY BASED ON THE THE
THE THE LEGISLATION WHICH COURT
REQUIRES THIS KIND OF LINEAR
PROCESS FIRST.
FIRST YOU GET LICENSE TO IT WITH
THE NEW UNDER THE NEW CRITERIA
AND ADMITTEDLY ARE -- SCRUTON T.
OF THE LICENSING PROCESS IN THE
LICENSING DOCUMENT IS IS IS VERY
HIGH FOR TWO REASONS ONE IS WE
ARE LOOKING AT MAKING SURE THAT
RATHER THAN -- IN OUR OLD WAY OF
THE AUDITING WHERE WE KIND OF
COUNTED ACCOUNTED THINGS AND
ONLY LOOK AT MONEY WE WERE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO ASSESS
QUALITY AND SO PART OF WHAT WE
ARE DOING IS.
BEING CLEAR THAT.
WE WOULD HOLD THE THE WE WOULD
ASSESS THE THAT PROVIDERS OF
QUALITY BASED ON WHAT THEY SAID
THEY WERE.
WHAT THE PROGRAM WAS GOING TO DO
WHAT IS YOUR PROGRAM GOING TO BE
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO FOCUS ON
ON THAT THE HEALING THE TRAUMA
HOW ARE THEY CONNECTED HOW ARE
THEY HOW WILL THE IN?
HOW WILL THE IMPLEMENTED PROVIDE
THAT THE INTEGRATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SO OUR OWN
PROCESS TAKE IT IT TAKES A WHILE
IT IT'S AN INTERNET PROCESS?
ONLY THEN ONCE THEY'RE LICENSED
CAN THEY GO OVER AND GET THE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM APPROVAL
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES IS DOING -- AND
SOME COUNTIES ARE DOING AS WELL
AND THEN ONCE THEY HAVE HAVE
GONE AND GOTTEN THAT PROGRAM
APPROVAL THEN THEY'RE ABLE TO
ENGAGE WITH LOCAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS. TO ACTUALLY GET
A CON GET CERTIFIED TO GET A
CONTRACT SO IT'S A LINEAR
PROCESS THAT IT TAKES A WHILE
OUR PLAN TO GET PEOPLE -- FROM
ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER HE HAS BEEN
A NUMBER OF REGIONAL CONVENING
AND INCLUDING JUST RECENTLY A
NUMBER OF OF OF WEBINARS AND
OTHER ENGAGEMENT WHERE.
SOME OF THAT THAT THE THE
PROVIDERS THAT HAVE ALREADY GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND AND AND
WE'RE AND TURNED THE CORNER MORE
QUICKLY ARE ARE PROVIDING.
HERE KIND OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BE IN ADDITION TO
WHAT THE TWO DEPARTMENTS AND
LOCAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS DOING
SOME COUNTIES ARE ALSO --
PARTNERING LOCALLY TOOK TO HELP
SUPPORT -- THAT THAT THE
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE YET WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY HAD A MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE AND HOW DO
YOU PREPARE.
SO THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY --
ACHIEVE THE PROGRAM APPROVAL SO
THERE'S A NUMBER OF OF OF OF OF
EFFORTS GOING -- BUT THE PROCESS
IS IN FACT A LINEAR AND THEN AT
THE END OF IT THE EVEN THE THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS THAT LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HAVE SELECTIVE
CONTRACTING AND THEY THEY THEY
CAN CHOOSE TO CONTRACT OR NOT TO
CONTRACT WITH ANY GIVEN PROVIDER.
IF IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE PITCHER FRANK AGAIN.
I I WOULD JUST ADD ON TO THIS IS
AN AREA WHERE I WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE DON'T UNDER STATE THE
AMOUNT OF EFFORT GOING INTO THE
WORK HERE -- THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF FACILITIES
TRYING TO TRANSITION THE MALL IT
IS A REALLY DIFFICULT
UNDERTAKING -- WE ARE FOCUSED
WITH OUR COUNTIES -- OUR STAFF
AND AND SOME OF THE THIRTY FOUR
IN THE B. C. P. THAT I
REFERENCED EARLIER OR ENGAGE
pCOLLEAGUES IN OUR COUNTY
COLLEAGUES WE DO FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY INDIVIDUAL CALLS WITH
THOSE COUNTIES.
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH THE ISSUES
THAT THEY'RE SEEING SPECIFICALLY
COUNTY BY COUNTY ON THE GROUND
WE'RE ALSO PRIORITIZING OUR
EFFORT -- TO TO IDENTIFY WHERE
WE NEED CAPACITY TO I'M KEY FOR
YOU HOW MANY -- YOU SAID YOU YOU
MAKE CALLS ARE YOU HAVE --
CALDERON COUNTIES HOW OFTEN --
SOME OF THOSE ARE WEEKLY
DEPENDING ON THE COUNTY THAT
OFTEN YEAH.
A LARGE AMOUNT IS ARE OBVIOUSLY
MORE OFTEN BECAUSE THEY HAVE
MORE CASES TO WORK THROUGH MORE
SITUATIONS TO WORK THROUGH THANK
YOU YEAH ABSOLUTELY.
SO I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH THE IMPRESSION THERE SOME
VAGUE PLANNERS ACTIVE WORK
THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT WORK
THAT'S GOING ON ON A VERY
INDIVIDUAL BASIS HERE AND MISTER
MAC OF PERHAPS OR OTHERS MIGHT
WANT TO WEIGH IN.
WITH COMMENTS THERE THAT SAID
THERE IS MORE THAT COULD BE DONE.
YEAH.
I JUST TOOK MY REMARKS OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK MAKE
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION -- A
COLLEAGUE OF MINE AT SEATED BDA
WHO'S HERE COLE WROTE THE REPORT.
THAT GAVE RISE TO THE C. C. R.
LEGISLATION WITH WITH MISTER
ROSEN SO -- WE'RE FULLY
COMMITTED TO ITS IMPLEMENTATION
AND CONTINUE TO BELIEVE IT'S THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES.
I POINT OUT THAT THAT CCR ISN'T
ONE REFORM CC ARE IS NO FEWER
THAN FIVE MAJOR REFORMS THAT ARE
ALL BEING UNDERTAKEN AT THE SAME
TIME.
WE'RE CHANGING THE WAY WE DO
SOCIAL WORK WERE CHANGING THE
NATURE OF RESIDENTIAL.
CARE INTO INTO SHORT TERM
TREATMENT WE'RE CHANGING THE WAY
WE APPROVED FAMILIES WERE
CHANGING THE LIGHT THE THE RATE
SYSTEM FOR FAMILIES WERE
CHANGING THE WAY AND THE NATURE --
BUT TWO OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
AND CHILD WELFARE AND ALL OF
THIS IS HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME.
AND SO I WOULD JUST UNDERSCORE
WHAT MR JOVANKA SAID THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK HAPPENING.
ALL THAT BEING SAID I DO THINK
IT MAKES SENSE TO TAKE SOME
STOCK AND HOW IT'S GOING WE MADE
SOME BIG ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT.
WITH C. C. R. WOULD BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE AND BY WHEN AND I DO
THINK THAT IT'S FAIR TO SAY.
SERVE HOW THE GOING AND AS AS
YOU MIGHT IMAGINE AND AS WE
SHOULD PROBABLY EXPECT THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT ARE GOING WELL.
AND THERE ARE SOME AREAS THAT
ARE STILL VERY MUCH A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND PROBABLY GIVE RISE
TO SOME REASON FOR SOME MID
COURSE THINKING -- AND SO WE
SORT OF A LINE WITH MR ROSE A
SENSE OF OF WHAT'S WHAT'S
WORKING THE REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF KIDS IN CONGREGATE
CARE BOTH PROBATION AND CHILD
WELFARE KIDS.
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING IS A
MUCH BETTER WAY OF DOING SOCIAL
WORK FOR EVERYBODY INVOLVED AND
THAT'S WELL UNDER WAY THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS.
AS ARGUE WITH HIM LABOR
INTENSIVE AS IT IS AND AT GET IT
SO MUCH MORE WORK THAN WE
ANTICIPATED TO GET THE EXISTING
CASES SORT OF THROUGH THE
PIPELINE.
IT IS A MUCH BETTER WAY. TO
APPROVE AND SUPPORT FAMILIES
BECAUSE YOU DO A ROBUST HOME
ASSESSMENT.
AND SO CARE GIVERS.
ARE BETTER ABLE TO CARE FOR
CHILDREN WHERE BET BETTER ABLE
TO DETERMINE IF IT'S A RIGHT
MATCH SO I DON'T WANNA GET LOST
IN THE DISCUSSION ABOUT OUR A
FAIT.
THE VALUE OF OF IT -- AS A
DIFFERENT AND BETTER WAY OF
APPROVING RELATIVES -- AND MANY
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES ARE NOW
STARTING TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER
CARE FAMILIES.
THIS IS ONE OF TWO MAJOR
CATEGORIES OF FAMILY BASED
PLACEMENTS THAT CC ARE ASSUMED
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR KIDS WHO
WERE IN LOWER LEVEL GROUP COMES
BUT SHOULDN'T BE LIVING THERE.
THEY DON'T THEY DON'T NEED
TREATMENT BUT THEY SHOULD BE
WITH FAMILIES AND WE MADE SOME
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT.
BUILDING OUT INTENSIVE SERVICES
FOSTER CARE AND TREATMENT FOSTER
CARE WHAT WAS WHICH WAS ACTUALLY
A REQUIREMENT OF THE KD ES
SETTLEMENT.
AN INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER
CARE WE'RE STARTING TO SEE SORT
OF TAKE OFF.
THE AREAS THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
STILL VERY MUCH A WORK AND AND
AND PROCESS AND THERE ARE SOME
AREAS OF CONCERN.
ARE ONES THAT YOU'VE HIGHLIGHTED
ALREADY ONE IS.
THE RELATIVELY SLOW RATE OF
CONVERSION OF GROUP HOMES --
INTO -- S. T. R. TEEPEES.
ABOUT HALF OF THE KIDS WHO ARE
IN CONGREGATE CARE ARE IN FILL
IN FACILITIES RIGHT NOW THAT
HAVE AN S. T. R. T. P. LICENSE.
YOU PROVIDED THE AUTHORITY FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW THOSE
FACILITIES TO CARE FOR THOSE
CHILDREN.
UNTIL THE END OF THIS YEAR
BECAUSE OF THAT.
SORT OF THAT THAT SLOWER RATE OF
CONVERSION -- AND WE DO THINK
THAT FOR MANY OF THOSE
FACILITIES THEY'RE SMALLER
FACILITIES THERE COMMUNITY BASED
FACILITIES.
MAY.
THEY ARE QUALITY AND THEY COULD
BE VERY THERAPEUTIC PLACES FOR
YOU FOR YOU.
BUT THE STEPS TO BE CALM
APPROVED ARE NOT INSIGNIFICANT
MISTER ROSE.
OUTLINED SORT OF THE THREE THE
THREE STEPS AND SO THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF WORK TO TRY TO HELP
THOSE FACILITIES.
ALONG THE PROCESS OF LICENSING
AND APPROVAL AND THEN
CONTRACTING.
BUT I DO THINK IT IT'S TIME AND
WE ARE BEGINNING TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO THINK ABOUT
PERHAPS WHETHER WE NEED SOME
MORE INTENSE SEVEN MORE
INTENTIONAL.
SORT OF SPECIFIC TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THOSE.
IN A FACILITY THAT WE REALLY
BELIEVE ARE IMPORTANT PARTS OF
THE CARE NETWORK AND WE INTEND
TO TALK TO THE ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT.
IDEAS -- IDEAS FOR DOING JUST
THAT -- THAT CONTRACTING -- THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONTRACTING
ISSUE I THINK IT'S ONE THAT THAT
BEARS KEEPING OUR EYE ON THERE'S
ONLY NINETEEN S. T. R. T. PEAS
IN THE STATE HAVE HAVE PASSED
ALL THREE STEPS -- AND SO.
THERE'S ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES IN
THE STATE BUT I SHOULD QUALIFY
THAT BY SAYING THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY TO SAY.
THAT WE BELIEVE THERE OUGHT TO
BE NINE HUNDRED BUT BUT NINETEEN
IS A LOW NUMBER -- AND BOB AS WE
GET S. T. R. T. PEAS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT.
THROUGH THE LICENSING PHASE I
THINK WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO PROBLEM SOLVE.
ABOUT HOW THOSE FACILITIES GET
MENTAL HEALTH CONTRACTS FROM
COUNTY MENTAL COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS AND THAT'S AN AREA
I THINK THE BEARS.
ARE OUR INTENTIONALITY AND YOUR
AND AND YOUR OVERSIGHT -- AND
THEN THE LAST THING I'LL SAY IS
THEM AJ BUT THEY'RE PEDIC FOSTER
CARE.
WAS OF AN OUTCOME OF THE KD ES
SETTLEMENT THE KATIE A LAWSUIT
WITH THE LAWSUIT THAT THE STATE
LOST -- THAT -- FOUND THAT THE
STATE WAS NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL EPA STT LAW.
AND PART OF COMING INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH WITH THE PST TO
THE COURT REQUIRED WITH REST
THAT DEVELOP TREATMENT FOSTER
CARE.
AND THAT'S BEEN VERY SLOW TO GET
OFF THE GROUND AND AND I DON'T
THINK THAT'S BECAUSE ANYONE'S
BEEN DRAGGING THEIR FEET -- BUT
WE MADE ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT TREATMENT FOSTER
CARE WOULD BE A VIABLE.
APPROACH -- TO TO SERVE SOME
CHILDREN WHO SEE SEE OUR SAYS
GET OUT OF THE GROUP HOPES.
BOMB AND I THINK WE NEED TO WORK
ON EITHER DEVELOPING TREATMENT
FOSTER CARE WITH INTENTIONALITY
OR COMING UP WITH A CONTINGENCY
PLAN IF IT TURNS OUT THE
TREATMENT FOSTER CARE TO IT.
IT IS PERHAPS NOT VIABLE IN THE
WAY THAT THAT KATIE A COURT --
THOUGHT IT WAS -- THE LAST AND
LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS THAT --
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS IT'S
TAKEN MORE TIME.
THAN PERHAPS SOME ORIGINALLY
IMAGINED I SHOULD SAY PROBABLY
NOT MORE TIME THAN MY MEMBERS
IMAGINE -- BUT WE WERE
INCREDIBLY AUDACIOUS IN SCOPE AN
AMBITIOUS AND TIME FRAME.
AND SO WE'LL TALK LATER ON IN
THE PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT BUT
OUR MEMBERS EXTREMELY ORRIED
ABOUT PULLING OUT THE RUG.
PULLING THE RUG OUT FROM UNDER
THOSE UP FROM UP FROM UP FRONT
INVESTMENTS LIKE RFA AND THE
FAMILY STABILITY FUND BECAUSE
THE FAMILY.
ARE THE ALTERNATIVE -- TO
GROUPON PLACEMENTS AND WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH OF THEM AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT I THINK THAT WE
NOT.
BECAUSE OF AN UNREALISTIC TIME
FRAME THAT WE SET OUT AT THE
BEGINNING BECAUSE WE WERE REALLY
AUDACIOUS AN AMBITIOUS.
THAT WE NOT PULLED THE RUG OUT
FROM UNDER THE REFORM IN MID
STREAM.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SHARING THE
CHAIR SHIP -- WE BOTH HAVE BILLS
WE'RE PRESENTING.
SO WE SINCERELY APPRECIATE YOUR
UNDERSTANDING IN THAT REGARD --
ALL RIGHT.
BEFORE THE FIFTY ABSOLUTELY YEAH
SO SO BEFORE WE CONTINUE OUT WE
TALKED ABOUT THE NINE HOT.
NINE HUNDRED OF FACILITIES IN
NINETEEN HAVE PASSED ALL THREE
STEPS SOUL CAN YOU ELABORATE
JUST A LITTLE BIT NOT TOO MUCH
BUT I JUST WANT TO KNOW.
IF THERE'S ONLY NINETEEN PASS
DOES THAT MEAN THAT SOME KIDS
ARE CURRENTLY IN THOSE
FACILITIES.
AND IF THERE IS ONLY NINETEEN
AND HAVING FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS TO THE?
THE I'M OF LET'S JUST ASSUME
JUST FOR MY PURPOSES THAT
THERE'S NOW IN NINETEEN COUNTY
THAT ACTUALLY HAVE ONE RIGHT
WHAT HAPPENS.
TO THOSE OTHER COUNTIES OR THAT
DON'T HAVE THOSE FACILITIES
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THOSE KIDS SO OF
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IN TWO
PARTS THE FIRST PART OF YOUR
QUESTION -- THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONTRACT -- IS NOT A
PREREQUISITE AT THIS MOMENT FOR
A FACILITY TO CARE FOR A CHILD.
THEY EITHER HAVE TO HAVE A
CONTRACT TO DELIVER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES OR THEY HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR RANGING FOR
ALL NECESSARY.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IT'S NOT
THE OPTIMAL SORT OF STATE OF CCR
OCT OPERATIONS BUT IT BUT IT IS
ALLOWED -- BUT AS WE TO TEAR
SECOND PARTY YOUR QUESTION --
THAT CC ARE INTENTIONALLY
ENVISIONED REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES.
AND YOUR QUESTION HITS TO A
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE ONCE WE GET
TO THE POINT WHERE.
ALL THE FACILITIES QUALITY
FACILITIES THAT CAN MEET THE
TEST OF C. C. R. EXIST ARE THEY
WHERE THE KIDS ARE.
AND SO THERE ARE SOME REALLY
EXCELLENT AS T. R. T. P. TH --
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU'RE NOT I MEAN IF YOU'RE
NOT IN VENTURA COUNTY YOUR YOUR
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IT'S YOUR
AUTO COUNTY IF YOU'RE GONNA GO
TO VICTOR.
SO -- WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS
QUESTION BUT I I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW THAT.
I CAN SIT HERE RIGHT NOW AND SAY
WE'RE SURE THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE A SUFFICIENT GEOGRAPHIC.
SORT OF AVAILABILITY.
OF TREATMENT PROGRAMS WHERE THE
WHERE THE CHILDREN ARE RESIDING
AND I KNOW WHAT'S ONE THING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS CROSS MAPPING.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO ACTIVELY MANAGE BYE BYE ON
FOLLOW UP ON THE THE NOT SO
THESE.
NINETEEN HUNDRED FACILITIES THAT
ARE POTENTIALLY GOING TO BE --
QUALIFIED ARE THE SEEN CHILDREN
RIGHT NOW SOLE SO I GUESS MY MY
QUESTION IS ARE THEIR KIDS
CURRENTLY BEING SEEN.
OKAY SO THAT THAT MAKES MORE
SENSE THEY'RE NOT.
EMPTY AND JUST WAITING FOR THE
APPROVAL PART PROCESS ARE STILL
SEEING CHILDREN BUT YOU HAVE A
RACK SO.
ALL OF THOSE FACILITIES HAVE --
HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE IN THEM SOME
SOME ARE STILL MAINTAINING THEIR
GROUP HOME LICENSE AND FOOD AND
AND MEETING THOSE OUGHT THAT
LEVEL OF CARE OBLIGATION.
SOME ARE LICENSED AS AS SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAMS BUT DON'T YET HAVE A
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM SO THEY'RE
AT THEIR MEETING THAT THAT THE
HIGHER ACUITY NEEDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE BYE BYE -- BY ARRANGING
FOR OR ARE PARTNERING WITH LOCAL
MENTAL HEALTH TO ARRANGE FOR
THAT THE SERVICES AND THEN
NINETEEN ARE FULLY INTEGRATED ON
THIS POINT.
SO THERE THERE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE
IS BEING SERVED IN THOSE THERE
ARE A GROUP THE GROUP I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE EIGHT
HUNDRED OR SO THAT -- THAT WON'T
MEET S. T. R. T. P. REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE IN SOME OF THAT --
BECAUSE THE CURRENT CONGREGATE
CARE FACILITIES THAT MAKE THAT
HAVE TOLD US EITHER THEY'RE NOT
GONNA TRANSITION OR IT SEEMS
UNLIKELY THEY WILL ARE THE THAT
GROUP OF YOUNG PEOPLE ARE THE
THE THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE AND
THE DEPARTMENT ARE WORKING WITH
OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES.
ON AT IMMEDIATELY TO LOCATE --
FAMILIES ARE ALL OF THAT CAN
CARE FOR THEM IF IN JUST I AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING THAT MR ROSE
SAID -- WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE IS
THAT GOING FORWARD THOSE
FACILITIES THAT ARE RECEIVING
AND CARING FOR CHILDREN NOW WHO
AREN'T FULLY LICENSED -- AT SOME
POINT THEY HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION RIGHT TO CONTINUE IN
THE LIMBO PERIOD OR DECIDE THIS
IS NOT -- A SERVICE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MEET.
AND FOR THOSE THAT EITHER CAN'T
OR DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE TO TO
BE AN S. T. R. T. P..
IT'S IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT THEY
NOT BECOME PART OF THE THE S. T.
R. T. PEMEX BUT FOR THOSE.
THAT CAN AND ARE NECESSARY AND
COULD BE GOOD PROVIDERS WHAT WE
DON'T WANT IS FOR THEM. TO GIVE
UP AND SAID THIS IS THIS IS WAY
TOO MANY HURDLES FOR US WE'RE
OUT.
AND AND IT'S IT'S THAT.
I MEAN IN THE SHORT RUN THEY'RE
THEY'RE CARING FOR AND SOME OF
THEM ARE CARING FOR KIDS BUT AT
SOME POINT.
THEY HAVE TO DECIDE ARE WE GONNA
CONTINUE IN THIS IT TO TO TRY TO
DELIVER THE SERVICE ON BEHALF OF
STATIC CALIFORNIA OR DO WE HAVE
TO BACK OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT ENDS IN DECEMBER.
IS THAT CORRECT WHAT ENDS IN
DEATH WHAT ENDS IN DECEMBER IS
THE PERIOD AFTER DECEMBER ANY
CHILD THAT IS IN -- A CONGREGATE
CARE FACILITY THAT DOES NOT HAVE
ITS S. T. R. T. P. LICENSE.
IS NO LONGER ELIGIBLE FOR STATE
REIMBURSEMENT.
SO IN FACT GIVEN THE GIVEN THE
COST IT IT SORT OF MEANS THAT
THAT PLACEMENT BECOMES.
NOT A VIABLE PLACEMENT AND YOU
EXTENDED.
FROM THE YEAR BEFORE BACK TO
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST -- WITH
CONDITIONS THAT I COUNTY COULD
ASK FOR AN EXTENSION IF IT
PROVED TO THE STATE.
EXCUSE ME THAT IT WAS TAKING.
APPROPRIATE STEPS TO TRY -- TO
GET FAMILIES AND TO GET S. T. R.
TO HELP GET US YOUR TEEPEES
APPROVED.
THE QUESTION THAT THAT OUR
MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO
ANSWER WITH YOU AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BEFORE THIS
BUDGET AND IS DO WE THINK
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF
NINETEEN CONTINUES TO BE A
REASONABLE DATE.
AND I BELIEVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WILL START PROBABLY TOMORROW
MORNING AROUND EIGHT O'CLOCK.
CLEARLY THAT WOULD BE THE NEXT
BEST A PARTY BUT NUMBER SAID SHE
IS A BAR IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE
THAT IT'S GOING TO BED THAT.
ALL THE FACILITIES THAT THAT WE
WANT BECAUSE THEY DELIVER GOOD
CARE AND THEY CAN REALLY -- NEED
A CHILD'S NEEDS TO HEAL -- IT'S
HARD TO IMAGINE THAT ALL OF THEM
WILL WILL GET PAST THE FINISH
LINE BY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE REASONABLE TO EXPECT IT TO
HAPPEN BY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
IT IS IT YOUR INTENTION THAN TO
ASK FOR AN EXTENSION. TO ANY TO
BEGIN THAT PROCESS.
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WERE ABOUT
TO HAVE WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
IS TO SORT OF IDENTIFY WHETHER
OR NOT WE HAVE A SORT OF A
COMMON ASSESSMENT OF THE
LIKELIHOOD OF DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST BEING REASONABLE OR NOT
AND AND IF IT TURNS OUT THAT MY
SUPPOSITION HERE TODAY -- IS
BORNE OUT IN THE ADMINISTRATION
CAN KERR'S WE WOULD NEED A
STATUTORY CHANGE TO ALLOW -- FOR
EXCEPTIONS AND I ASSUME THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD WOULD WANT
TO SIMILARLY.
ENSURE THAT -- ANNEKE.
IN THOSE CASES WERE EXTENSIONS
OCCUR DUE DILIGENCE AS BEING
MATT.
AND TERMS OF FINDING FAMILIES
AND AND BECAUSE IT'S NO ONE'S
INTENT. TO HAVE AN INDEFINITE
PERIOD OF YOU KNOW OF OF OF
FACILITIES THAT ARE CONVERTED TO
AS CHAIR TEEPEES DICK TO BE
CONTINUED TO CARE FOR KIDS.
BUT IF WE ONLY HAVE NINETEEN OF
FIVE MILLION.
NINE HUNDRED THAT'S WHAT THERE
ARE.
OTHER THERE ARE WORTH IT I'M
SORRY EACH OF THOSE.
HOMES EACH OF THOSE FACILITIES
HAVE OUR YOUTH.
THEY'VE GOT TO GO SOMEWHERE AND
IF THERE ISN'T A FAMILY
[inaudible]
WE CAN'T PUT HIM ON THE STREET
IT'S ABOUT HALF OF THE KIDS --
IN IN CONGREGATE CARE RIGHT NOW
ARE IN A FACILITY THAT DOESN'T
HAVE AN S. T. R. T. P. LICENSE.
AS CHAIR TO BE LICENSE IS THE
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST THAT --
DEADLINE AND SO IT'S THE THE
TEST WOULD BE FINDING FAMILIES
FOR FOR THOSE CHILDREN OR END.
OR BY GETTING THOSE FACILITIES
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY ARE
LICENSED AS S. T. R. T. PEAS.
SO YOU CAN YOU ADDRESS YOU
TACKLE THE PROBLEM FROM TWO
DIRECTIONS FINDING FAMILIES IN
TRYING TO HELP PUT FACILITIES.
GET LICENSED AND WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING BOTH AND THE QUESTION IS.
OUR OUR MUTUAL EFFORTS IN THIS
INVOLVES HELP FROM THE STATE.
BOTH STATE AGENCIES AND OTHER
COUNTY PARTNERS WELL OUR EFFORTS
YIELD ENOUGH RESULTS SUCH THAT
WE WOULD NOT NEED AN EXTENSION
PAST TWELVE THIRTY ONE NINETEEN
AND IT'S HARD FOR US TO IMAGINE.
THAT THAT WOULD BE THE CASE THIS
REVIEW YES.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO FIND --
FOUGHT THE PARENTS BUT I MAY BE
OFF ON THIS BUT IF YOU LOOK BACK
ON PAGE SIXTEEN THE I CC ARE
SPENDING UNDER TWENTY NINETEEN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE FOSTER PARENT
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION AND
SUPPORT IS DECLINED.
WITH ACTUALLY ZERO SO HOW ARE WE
GOING TO FIND THESE FAMILIES
WHEN.
IT INDICATES THAT WE HAVE. ZERO
MONEY TO FOR RECRUITMENT I IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE ANY.
UNLESS I'M WE ARE WE THINK THAT
FUND IS REALLY IMPORTANT THE DIP
THE DEPARTMENT IS IS.
BRINGING CONTRACTORS LIKE
DANNY'S GOODMAN TO HELP US WITH
TECHNOLOGIES TO FIND FAMILIES
BUT IT'S EXPENSIVE LABOR
INTENSIVE ACTIVITY.
AND SO FROM FROM THE VERY STRONG
VIEWPOINT TO THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
IT IS PREMATURE TO REDUCE
FUNDING FOR THE FAMILY STABILITY
FUND FORMALLY KNOWN AS FIFTY
SOUGHT NOT JUST PAYMENT CHAIR
IT'S I'M IT'S CLEARLY GOING IT
HUNTER PRODUCTIVE ABSOLUTELY
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE SAYING THAT IN
ORDER TO COMPLY.
WE ARE TO HELP THESE KIDS OUT OF
CC ARE ARE OUT OF THE I'M SORRY
THE THE HOMES WE NEED FAMILIES
BUT WE ARE NOT RECRUITING
FAMILIES THERE WERE JUST.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SPINNING OUR
WHEELS ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
IT'S WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE.
AND UP.
IT'S AN ADDITIONAL COMMENT BY SO
WE HAVE TO HOW CAN WE FIX THIS
OR IS VERY PLAN.
SINCE THE MONEY IS.
ARE.
NOT AVAILABLE FOR THE
RECRUITMENT AND HOW CAN WE HELP.
AND WE WE WE BROUGHT THE ISSUE
TO FOR YOUR DISCUSSION HERE
TODAY WE WE DEFINITELY INTEND TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
TRY TO GET TO OF A PLACE WHERE
WE ALL AGREE.
IS THE RIGHT PLACE AND IT WOULD
RESULT IT IT IT.
ASSUMING A STATUTORY CHANGES
NEEDED WE ABSOLUTELY INTEND TO
BRING IT TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES -- FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU TESTIMONY FROM THE
NEXT WITNESS [inaudible]
JUSTIN.
IT.
DOESN'T REDUCE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- A IS THERE A SPECIFIC
QUESTION THAT YOU WOULD LIKE ME
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE ON WHAT --
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR JAMAICA
AND TO BE DIRECTOR ROSE HAVE
EXPENDED ON FOR ME THE MOST.
BUT NUMBER AND THE MANY THAT'S
BEEN REDUCE I MEAN IS IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT HAS EVEN BEEN
DISCUSSED -- I UNDERSTAND IT'S A
NEW ADMINISTRATION BY THIS IS A
PRESSING ISSUE AND FOR VARYING
OUT THE RECRUITMENT MONEY HAS
THERE BEEN ANY DISCUSSION AS TO
REINSTATING SOME OF THAT MONEY
OR HOW WE'RE GOING TO HELP --
THE THE COUNTIES IN THE
RECRUITMENT [inaudible]
THROUGH A WHAT I CAN SEE IS THAT
THE THE ADMIN AT THE KERN
ADMINISTRATION AND MAINTAIN THE
SAME PROPOSAL THAT DAY THAT.
WAS ORIGINALLY AGREED UPON BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND AND THE PAST
RESTORATION WHEN -- CCR WAS
ENVISIONED SO -- WHICH I THINK A
CLEAR DISTINCTION HERE'S MAKE IS
THAT THERE'S NOT A REDUCTION AND
AT WHAT WE WE'VE BEEN REFERRING
TO AS VAPERS OUR FOSTER PARENT
RECRUITMENT RETENTION SUPPORT
FUNDING -- RECRUITMENT PROCESS
SO IT ENDS UP BECOMING A COUNTY
RESPONSIBILITY IN AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ROSE SAID COMMENTED ON
EARLIER.
THE THE DISCUSSION OF OF CCR AND
RECOGNIZING THAT WE NEEDED TO
MOVE THE SITE AT THE GROUP HOME
POPULATION FROM THE CONGREGATE
CARE. TO THE HOME BASED SETTING
I WAS LOOK AT THAT THERE IS IT'S
AN INITIAL INVESTMENTS -- SO ACT
AS YOU READ THIS TIME THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T HAVE A
PROPOSAL BEYOND'S MAINTAINING
THAT SARAH THAT ORIGINAL INITIAL
UP FRONT INVESTMENT NOW TO THE
EXTENT.
THAT A THIS IS A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY -- AS USUAL WERE VERY
HAPPY.
TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WERE RECOUNT ON THAT'S BUT WHAT
KNOWN BUT LET ME JUST STOP YOU
RIGHT THERE BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE
WHAT I'M WHAT I'M HEARING IS
THAT THERE IS AN INITIAL
INVESTMENT BUT ACCORDING TO THIS
CHART IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
INITIAL INVESTMENT WAS -- TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND IT'S TWENTY ONE SIX
THIRTY BOB BUT THERE IS NO THE
MAIN.
MAINTAINING THAT ORIGINAL
INVESTMENT BECAUSE IT'S IT'S THE
IF YOU LOOK ABOUT CHARLIE YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING IS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IS -- FOR THE CURRENT YEAR THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
MAINTAINING -- THE THE TWENTY
ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
THEN PROPOSED FOR THE GOVERNOR
AND THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
THERE IS NOT A PROPOSAL.
TO MAINTAIN OR AT ANY ENTITLED
THAT THAT IS NOT MAINTAINING THE
ORIGINAL INVESTMENT IT'S AS WELL
AS WHERE I'M GETTING HUNG UP ON
BECAUSE HE SAID THAT THERE IS AN
INTENT TO MAINTAIN THE ORIGINAL
INVESTMENT.
AND BUYS HEARING IT OUT IS NOT
MAINTAINING IN MY UNDERSTANDING
IT.
UNDERSTANDING IT NO I UNDERSTAND
YOUR YOUR YOUR QUESTION AND THE
ORIGINAL INVESTMENTS WAS THIS
THREE YEAR PERIOD OF TIME --
AGAIN JUST A TO RESET AGAIN ADD
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
WE'RE HAPPY TO HELP.
ALSO IN THAT CONVERSATION IS IS
TO SHOULDN'T IT BE ARE ALSO A
PRIORITY OF THE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION I MEAN I THINK WE
YOU KNOW THE SO I APPRECIATE.
THAT YOU'RE HERE BY BUT IF THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS A PRIORITY
FOR ALL OF US WHICH WAS
INDICATED BY MAINTAINING THE
ORIGINAL INVESTMENT THAN.
THAT THE ORIGINAL INVESTMENT
INDICATED TO ME THAT THERE WAS A
PRIORITY FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
I I I KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
BACK AND FORTH BUT THE POINT
BEING.
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING IT BACK ON
US I WHICH I CAN APPRECIATE
HOWEVER THE THE THE ORIGINAL
INVESTMENT INDICATED THAT THERE
WERE SOME WILLINGNESS FROM THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE
WITH THIS.
CELL. EIGHT I DON'T SEE THE I'M.
THE INTENT.
I GUESS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
TO CONTINUE YOUR YOU KEEP
INDICATING THAT IF THERE'S AN
INTENT FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
THAN THAN -- THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL COMPLY BUT
THE NICHOLS CAUGHT UP BACK TO
WHAT YOU ORIGINALLY SAID THAT.
THEY WERE MAINTAINING THE
ORIGINAL INVESTMENT THE IN IT
JUST THERE THERE'S NO INTENT
ISN'T WHAT MY QUESTION IS ARE MY
POINT IS.
BY THE NINE INVESTMENT THIS TIME.
AND MADAME CHAIRS -- THE FROM
THIS FROM THIS THAT FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF THE COUNTIES THAT
ARE THAT ARE IMPLEMENTING THIS
REFORM ON YOUR BEHALF WE ASSUMED
A LOT OF THINGS THREE YEARS AGO.
SO IT MAY BE TRUE THAT THREE
YEARS AGO WE ASSUMED THAT WE
WOULD HAVE ALL THE FAMILIES WE
NEEDED -- WE ASSUMED THAT ALL
THE S. T. R. T. PIECE WOULD HAVE
CONVERTED.
THE KD ES COURT ASSUME WE HAVE
TREATMENT FOSTER CARE WE ASSUMED
A LOT OF THINGS SOME OF THEM
HAPPENED AND SOME OF THEM DID
NOT AND SO.
IT SEEMS I WOULD ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT INHERITED CC
ARE FROM THE PRIOR%
ADMINISTRATION TO UNDERSTAND
THAT -- WE'RE ALL IN GOOD FAITH
MAKING MID COURSE CORRECTIONS
AND WORKING AS HARD AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN TO IMPLEMENT THIS
REFORM SOME THINGS ARE GOING AS
PLANNED AND SOME THINGS AREN'T.
SO TO SAY WELL THREE YEARS AGO
WE THOUGHT IT WAS ALL GOING TO
BE DONE AND IT'S NOT SO IF YOU
WANT TO DO IT AFTER THREE YEARS
IT'S ON YOU BUT THAT'S NOT OUR
PRIORITY.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT IS AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO VIEW OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT
CURRENT LAW BECAUSE CCAR'S
CURRENT LAW.
AND IF WE'RE ALL TOGETHER MAKING
A GOOD FAITH MID COURSE
CORRECTIONS AND ASSESSMENT OF
HOW WELL WE'RE DOING.
THEN WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THOSE SAME ADJUSTMENTS ON THE
FINANCING SIDE.
I THINK THAT THE THE BOTTOM LINE
IS.
ARE THESE REDUCTIONS GOING TO
HELP OR HURT C. C. R..
AND I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
HURT IT I MEAN I ASSUME WE CAN
ALL AGREE THAT THE REDUCTIONS
WILL HURT IT.
I THINK THAT THE THE IF WE TALK
ABOUT PRIORITIES IT ISN'T
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY ONLY I
THINK IT HAS TO BE A MUTUAL
PRIORITY.
AND I THINK IF WE VIEW IT THAT
WAY JUST AS YOU SAID WE'RE ALL
IN THIS TOGETHER.
ARE WE WE WE END.
WE HAVE TO AT TIMES TAKE A
REFRESHED LOOK.
AT ANY VALUATION AS OPPOSED TO
SAYING THIS IS WHAT WE DECIDED
ON AND THAT'S IT.
EVERY YEAR I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS AGAIN AND YOU'RE
RIGHT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO DO.
THE ABSOLUTE BEST THAT WE CAN
WILL HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
RESPONSIBILITY DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
MORE TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE
DO IN THE END.
WILL HELP US TAKE CARE OF THAT
SUIT THE C. C. R..
IT HELPS TO TO REACH THE THE THE
GOALS THAT WE WANT FROM THE C.
C. OURS THIS WAS ONE OF ONE
ADDITIONAL COMMENT MISTER FOR
THIS -- I SAT HERE FIVE FOR TWO
YEARS UNDER ALL GOVERNOR BROWN
AND I KEEP GETTING -- THE SAME
KIND OF STANDARD ANSWERS -- FROM
YOU KNOW THAT ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT YOU KNOW WILL HELP YOU
WITH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
ALL OF THAT WHICH IS REALLY
FRUSTRATING AND I SAW THIS
GOVERNOR.
OUT WITHOUT A FRESH NEW LOOK
WITH HOPE WITH -- MORE
ENCOURAGEMENT THAT WE WERE GOING
TO TRULY BE PARTNERS IN THIS AND
SOLD IF YOU.
I DON'T MEAN TO I AM BE BRASH.
ABOUT THIS BUT I THOUGHT WE WERE
PARTNERS IN THIS AND AND AGAIN
FOR ME IT WAS HOPEFUL TO HEAR
THE GOVERNOR INDICATE THAT WE
WERE ALL GOING TO BE IN THIS
TOGETHER AND SOUL.
SOUL I'M DON'T WANNA SEEM
FRUSTRATED BUT I'M GOING TO GET
FRUSTRATED WHEN I KEEP HEARING
THE SAME YOU KNOW WHAT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND WHICH
IS REALLY DOESN'T DO ANYTHING I
DON'T WANT TO START OUR
RELATIONSHIP -- THAT WAY I WANT
US TO REALLY SIT DOWN AND TALK
ABOUT SOLUTIONS AND RATHER THAN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND YOU
KNOW ALL THE RHETORIC.
FRANKLY THAT I GOT FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS FROM THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION I WAS REALLY
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN GET
DIFFERENT ANSWERS BECAUSE THIS
IS CHILDREN THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND SO I WILL LEAVE IT AT
THAT BUT PLEASE.
YOU KNOW FROM NOW ON THAT'S WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR THE I GOT THE
LIP SERVICE ALREADY FROM THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION AND I
DON'T WANT.
TO GET IT HERE.
THESE ARE TWO CRITICAL --
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH TO GET THE SAME LIP
SERVICE AND I AGAIN MY HOPE IS
THAT THIS NEW ADMINISTRATION WE
CAN GET ANSWERS AND IT'S NOT
PUNITIVE IN ANY MEANS I JUST
WANT SOME -- WILLINGNESS TO TO
SIT DOWN AND REALLY BE PARTNERS
IN THIS INSTEAD OF YOU KNOW
GETTING THE LIP SERVICE SO I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT THAT IT IN
THE FUTURE.
I I WE CAN WE LIMIT THE YOU KNOW
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT.
RESPONSES BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
HELPFUL WE NEED ACTUAL --
ANSWERS THAT ARE GOING TO HELP
US IN DECEMBER YOU KNOW BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TO MAKE
THIS A SOLUTION I'M NOT HERE --
TO BATTLE WE'RE HERE.
TO I HAVE SOLUTIONS AND CREATE
PATHWAYS SO THAT WE CAN ASSIST
THE COUNTIES AND ASSIST THESE
CHILDREN AND AND AND THE
SERVICES THAT WE IN OUR
PROMISING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO I I I DON'T THINK THAT THE
THE APPROACH OF THE MINISTRATION
IS TO TO TAKE THIS AS YOU SAID
THIS COMBAT EVER NOT BE
SUPPORTIVE I THINK THAT'S WHEN
THE BEAUTIES OF THIS BUDGET
PROCESS RIGHT IN THE IN THE
HEARINGS THAT WE GO THROUGH IS.
THE ADMINISTRATION PUTS ON ITS
BUDGET PROPOSAL IN AND AND THERE
IS LISTED THE PRIORITIES AT THE
TIME AND WE HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY HERE SO I'M
DEFINITELY HERE ON ON YOUR
CONCERN ON ON THE THE COMMENTS
AND DONATED THINK THAT IT'S
ANYTHING LIKE THAT OF OF A OF A
LIP.
SERVICE IT'S IT DOES COME FROM A
GENUINE -- RESPONSE OF IF THIS
IS A PRIOR TO THE TIME WHEN I OR
INTO BEING ONE WERE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THE TECHNICAL
ASPECTS OF IT CREDITS DISTANCE --
BECAUSE TAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE HERE TO SIT FOR AN A
LIST AND YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S ALSO
HERE.
YOUR PRIORITIES SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MS RUBIO --
RYAN THE LAND IS HELLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARED MEMBERS
MILLINERS ILIO -- SO WE WOULD
JUST LIKE TO REITERATE SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE RAISED IN OUR
HUMAN SERVICES BUDGET
PUBLICATION -- RECENTLY -- TWO
PRIMARY ISSUES -- ONE BEING.
THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
IMPLEMENTATION AS HAS BEEN
ALREADY NOTED -- THIS IS
CRITICAL FOR THE BECAUSE OF THE
SUCCESS OF THE GOALS OF CCAR
SPONSORED THE GUIDE TO MAKING
SURE THAT MORE.
CHILDREN ARE IN HOME BASE FAMILY
CARE SETTINGS -- AND AS AS ALSO
PREVIOUSLY NOTED -- YOU KNOW
THERE ARE THE REMAIN CHALLENGES
RELATED -- TO THE APPLICATION
APPROVAL TIME.
A TIME FRAMES THAT -- FAMILIES
HAVE TO GO THROUGH -- INCLUDING --
FOR CAREGIVERS WITH THE
PLACEMENT PRIOR TO APPROVAL --
OVER NINETY DAYS AS REQUIRED --
BY LAW.
AND SO GIVEN THESE CHALLENGES
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THERE HAS
BEEN SOME MODERATE --
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE WAIT TIMES.
WE WOULD RECOMMEND NOT ONLY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO
CLOSELY MONITOR -- THIS
PARTICULAR COMPONENT OF CCIR BUT
CONSIDER EXTENDING.
THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT THAT IT
HAS BEEN GIVING TO COUNTIES. TO
HELP THEM.
IMPLEMENT THIS CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF CCAR -- A AND AND
BRING THOSE WAIT TIMES DOWN.
AS WELL TO CONSIDER -- EXTENDING
THE FUNDING FOR THESE PARTICULAR
CARE GIVERS WITH THE PLACEMENT
PRIOR TO APPROVAL -- OR HAVING
THEIR WELL A APPROVAL WAIT TIMES.
GREATER THAN NINETY DAYS -- IN
ORDER TO INSURE THAT THESE ARE
FAMILIES PLACEMENT SETTINGS ARE
REMAIN STABLE AND THAT CHILDREN
DON'T HAVE -- TO AND UP.
OF CHANGING -- THERE CARE GIVERS
OF THE OTHER -- IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT -- IS READ THE
CARD TO THE LEVEL OF CARE --
TOOL AND RATE STRUCTURE -- THERE
REMAIN SEVERAL OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS RATHER REGARDING THIS
COMPONENT OF CCIR -- THAT IS
ALSO EXPERIENCED -- SIGNIFICANT
DELAYS -- ONE BEING -- WHAT THE?
KIND OF THE LATEST ITERATION OF
THAT TO LOOKS LIKE -- AND WHAT
CHANGES HAVE BEEN MADE.
OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS --
INCORPORATING THE INPUT FROM THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH -- WITH GARDEN THIS TOOL
AND WHAT.
ANY OUTSTANDING UNCERTAINTIES.
REMAIN -- AS THE TOOL -- IS
ROLLED OUT TO OTHER.
POPULATIONS THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
THE STRUCTURE -- WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT -- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GET A BOOK FROM VERY SPECIFIC
DETAIL TIMELINE FOR THE ROLL OUT
OF THE RATE STRUCTURE -- TO
DIFFERENT -- CAREGIVERS OUTSIDE
OF THE THE NEW -- FFA -- CARE
GIVERS.
AND THE DETAILS ON THE PLANNED
VALIDITY TEST.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION PLANS --
TO CONDUCT ON THE TOOL AS IT'S
ROLLED OUT AND HOW IT PLANS TO
INCORPORATE -- ANY FINDINGS FROM
THAT A TEST -- TO LATER
ITERATIONS OF THE TOOL -- AND
FINALLY TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE --
IT YOU WE THINK IT WOULD BE A
WORTHY IF OF THE NEGOTIATION
COULD -- OF PROVIDE A KIND OF AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE COMBINED THAT
FINANCIAL IMPACT THAT -- FOSTER
FAMILY HOMES -- WOULD HAVE
WHAT'S THE NEW RATE STRUCTURE IS
IMPLEMENTED -- COMBINED WITH THE
NEW -- SUPPLEMENTAL CARE
INCLEMENT PLANS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE MIGHT MAYBE
SOME FAMILIES THAT ON THAT HAVE
A HIGHER OR LOWER -- RATE OF OF
GRANTS COMPARED -- TO THEIR X.
WHAT THEY WORKS WOULD HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING UNDER THE THE OLDER
AGE BASED RATE STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE LA -- BEFORE
REMOVED TO THE NEXT.
ISSUE.
ALRIGHT THEN I'D LIKE TO ASK
THAT -- JENNIFER REX ROAD --
COME JOIN US PLEASE.
AND WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
THIS REYES.
MR FRAZIER HAS AN EXCUSED
ABSENCE MISTER MATHIS.
MISTER PATTERSON.
MISTER RAMOS MISS RUBIO.
MEET DOCTOR WOULD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME --
GENEREX READ WHAT CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS.
AND EXCITE IT'S EXCITING TO BE A
PAIR WITH I AM SUCH A HOT ISSUE
THAT -- YOU'VE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN.
AND I'D DEFINITELY WE FEEL THAT
AND THIS IS NOT THE TIME.
TO PULL THE RUG OUT -- FROM
UNDERNEATH RETENTION AND
RECRUITMENT ACTIVITIES.
SO MANY COUNTIES HAVE DEVELOPED.
I'M REALLY IMPORTANT AND
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS -- INCLUDING
AND FAMILY FINDING ACTIVITIES
AND CAMPAIGNS -- THERE ARE A LOT
OF SUPPORT GROUP AT TANGIBLE
SUPPORT AT PROGRAMS FOR CARE
GIVERS INCLUDING.
A MENTORING PROGRAMS -- FOSTER
PARENT LIAISONS -- RESPITE
PROGRAMS AND OTHER TANGIBLE
SERVICES THAT MAKE -- PLACEMENTS
POSSIBLE WHERE THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE BEFORE
INCLUDING -- SIBLING SETS AND OR
LARGER SIBLING FATS AND AND
OTHER YOUTH WHO ARE STEPPING
DOWN FROM CONGREGATE CARE.
SO WE REALLY FEEL LIKE -- THE
TIME THAT THAT FIT BIRDS WAS
IMPLEMENTED KIND OF GOT SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS OFF THE GROUND.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THAT MONEY
WAS DIVERTED -- THROUGH THE
WHOLE RFA CRISIS WHICH WAS
IMPORTANT BUT NOT REALLY.
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
FUNDING SO SOME OF THE COUNTY IS
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT
PROGRAMS THEM THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE -- HAD THEY OTHERWISE NOT
HAD TO DETER FOR DIVERT THE
FUNDING.
SO AB AND WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE
AN COUNTY IS BE ABLE TO BUILD ON
THE SUCCESS -- OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND OTHER COUNTIES YOU KNOW
START.
THE SIXTH START DOING SUCCESSFUL
ACTIVITIES ARE ACTIVITIES THAT
SHOWED -- PROMISE OUR SUCCESS.
AND AND SO WE CAN REALLY MEET
THAT DEMAND FOR HOMES BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T STEP KIDS
DOWN.
UNLESS WE HAVE FAMILY HOME
SETTINGS TO PUT THAT MEANT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- REACTION PLEASE
FROM -- FEEDBACK FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION -- DEAL F. AND
ALEJO.
WELL I THINK REALLY BRIEFLY A
MEMBER TALKED ABOUT RECRUITMENT
IN THE END IN THE PRIOR
CONVERSATION WE JUST HAD I MEAN
I I WOULD SAY. TO I MEAN IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW TO AS YOUR
AGENDA DESCRIBED IN THE
BACKGROUND WE DIDN'T GO THROUGH
ABOUT THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
THAT SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR
CHILD WELFARE WAS REALIGNED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN AND
ALONG WITH THAT CAME THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR FAMILY
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION.
THAT SAID WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
CHANGE IS HARD CHANGES DIFFICULT
WE NEED MORE FAMILIES THAT'S WHY
THE STATE INVESTED IN THE SYSTEM
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WE'RE HAPPY AS MS RACKS ROAD AND
MISTER MAC OF BEFORE HER -- AND
YOUR OWN REQUEST FOR
CONVERSATION WE'RE HAPPY TO
ENGAGE IN THAT CONVERSATION ME
WHAT I DIDN'T JUMP IN AND SAY AT
THE TIME.
JANUARY TEN WAS RIGHT AFTER
JANUARY SIX AND THERE WHILE THE
GOVERNOR WEIGHED IN ON
PRIORITIES HE DIDN'T HAVE
PRIORITIES ON EVERY ISSUE IN THE
BUDGET RIGHT.
AND SO I'M GONNA.
SAY WITHOUT SAYING WHAT I JUST
SAID.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE HAPPY TO
ENGAGE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND YOU KNOW -- WONDERFUL THANK
YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
I THINK MAYBE THE IF I MAY THE
ONLY OTHER THING THAT I WOULD
ADD TO THIS IS THAT -- AS WE'VE
SEEN WITH OTHER INVESTMENTS LIKE
THE RFA BACKLOG REDUCTION.
WHEN WE PUT MONEY INTO SOMETHING
BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
WE SHOULD ALSO BE CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT WE EXPECT TO GET OUT OF
THAT INVESTMENT OR WHAT THE
PROGRESS OR MILESTONES ARE THAT
WE'RE EXPECTING AND SO I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT TO THE
CONVERSATION?
THIS ISSUE AGAIN DOESN'T HAPPEN
IN ISOLATION MR ROSE TESTIFIED
WE'D ALREADY REDUCED A THOUSAND
KIDS OUT OF CONGREGATE CARE.
MEANING THOSE OF ALREADY GONE
SOME PLACE WE HAVE AN RFA --
BACKLOG IN A DELAY IN APPROVALS.
ADDRESSING THAT CAN CREATE MORE
HOME BASED CARE PLACEMENTS AND
FURTHER REDUCING THE NEED FOR
SOME OF THE FACILITIES THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT.
IT'S A LOT OF WORK A LOT OF
DIFFERENT MOVING PARTS AND
PIECES WERE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION SO FOR SHEER
INDULGENCE.
AND JUST IN CASE MY BRAIN IT'S
AN AND JUST TO ADD ON WITH THE
TO BE DIRECTOR TO MAKE IT SAID
THE THE THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS IN ITS
FIRST BUDGET IN HHS SO -- BEGIN
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS A
PRIORITY -- WILL HAPPEN GAUGING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND JUST
RECOGNIZE.
THAT YOU KNOW ALL OF ALL OF
THESE SERVERS AS WE TAKE FROM
ONE TO ANOTHER THOSE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT WE ALSO WANT TO
CONSIDER AS WELL.
THANK YOU -- THAT WE HAVE HEARD
ABOUT POTENTIAL UNSPENT FUNDS.
A AND F. P. R. R. S..
CAN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COUNTIES IN THE ADVOCATES SPEAK
TO THIS.
AND HOW IT RELATES TO THE
PROPOSAL.
I THINK I THINK THERE ARE AND IN
SOME CASES SOME OF THE CONTRACTS
AND SERVICES WERE DELAYED IN THE
BEGINNING I WAS ABLE.
THERE WAS SOME LAG TIME -- IN
SETTING OUT PROGRAMS AND GETTING
THE CONTRACTS IN PLACE.
AND I THINK WHAT I'VE SEEN AS
THAT AND BECAUSE COUNTIES NEIL
THAT THE PROGRAM -- OR THE
FUNDING WAS ENDING THEY STARTED
THEY SUCH AN SOME COUNTY IT'S A
STARTED TO SCALE BACK -- THE
PROGRAMS AND FUNDING -- SO.
THAT'S THE BEST I CAN.
OFFER.
GREG MAY KNOW MORE.
LAUREN HUNTER.
RIGHT SO I JUST I WITHOUT GREAT
RISK IN THE DEPARTMENT I'D ALSO
NOTE THAT PREVIOUS YEARS OF
UNSPENT FUNDS HAVE BEEN ROLLED
OVER AND AVAILABLE THIS YEAR AS
WELL SO THE THE THE THE
INVESTMENT THE THREE YEAR
INVESTMENT THAT WE TALKED SO
MUCH ABOUT EARLIER.
HE HAS HAS CARRIED THROUGH YOU
KNOW IT SO IT HAS IT HAS BEEN
AVAILABLE -- AND SO I WANT YOU.
TO SO WOULD YOU ASKED ABOUT THE
AND YOU KNOW UNSPENT FUNDS THEY
THEY ARE THEY ARE AVAILABLE THIS
YEAR [inaudible]
AND I'LL ADD ONE MORE AND PEACE
TO THAT I KNOW OF A PROGRAM AND
FOR LA PROBATION FOR EXAMPLE
THEY'RE USING.
AND A VERY -- HIGH QUALITY
EVIDENCE BASED MARKETING AND
RECRUITMENT -- PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE GETTING A LOT OF RESULTS
SO.
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
THINK MAYBE TOOK A LITTLE WHILE
TO GET OFF THE GROUND BUT NOW
THEY HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTERESTED.
AND THEY HAVE KIND OF HAVE THIS
WAVE OF SUCCESS WHEREAS IF THE
PROGRAM.
IF THE IF THE FUNDING DOES THAT
CONTINUE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
INTERESTED.
PARTY IS AN A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
GOING BUT NO -- NO WAY TO
CONTINUE TO KIND OF CAPTURE AND
TRAIN AND AND UC'S FAMILY IS FOR
PROBATION YOUTH.
SO THAT MIGHT BE AN EXAMPLE OF
OF HOW THIS.
THIS INVESTMENT IF WE IF WE CUT
IT OFF RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOSING
YOU KNOW WHERE IT CAN A LOSING
THAT. THREE YEAR INVESTMENT.
CUTE BUT WHEN FINANCE
[inaudible]
NO COMMENT.
BUT I I THINK AGAIN JUST AND
REYES FINANCE I THINK WE'VE
WE'VE CONTINUED ON WITH THE
DISCUSSION AND IT'S AT RESPECT
FOR NOT PROVIDING THE SAME
RESPONSE -- JUST TO GET OUT ON
WITH THAT W. DIRECTOR ROSE SAID
WE'VE -- INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL WAS
LANGUAGE TO RE APPROPRIATE ANY
UNSPENT FUNDS THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF FLEXIBILITY.
TO PROVIDED TO COUNTIES FOR ANY
OF THOSE UNSPENT FUNDS TO GIVE
THEM A LONGER TO USE THOSE --
GOOD [inaudible]
HELLO.
COMMENTS VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU -- ADVOCACY PROPOSAL
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM FERS.
CAN WE CALL UP CAN DEREK
[inaudible]
APRIL [inaudible]
GREAT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I CAN'T BEGIN TO TELL YOU HOW
HAPPY I AM TO BE HERE TODAY --
MY NAME'S KEN BERWICK I'M THE
FOUNDER AND CEO OF SENECA FAMILY
OF AGENCIES WHERE ONE OF THOSE
NINETEEN STI TEEPEES IN THE
STATE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WERE ONE OF
THE LARGEST WRAPAROUND PROVIDERS
IN THE STATE.
AND WE PROVIDE SERVICES ACROSS
CHILD WELFARE MENTAL HEALTH
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND EDUCATION
IN INTEGRATED SYSTEMS. TO THAT
END AND BECAUSE OF THAT WORK
WE'VE SEEN UP CLOSE.
THE IMPACTS OF SOME OF THE GAPS
IN OUR SERVICE SYSTEM FOR KIDS
AND FAMILIES.
AND SEEING THOSE GAPS THREE
YEARS AGO WE GOT A GRANT FROM
THE IRVINE FOUNDATION. TO BRING
LEADERS IN THE STATE TOGETHER TO
LOOK AT HI NEEDS YOU.
AND THE SAY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT COULD BE MOST IMPACTFUL FOR
THOSE WHO.
AND AND THROUGH THAT PROCESS
WHAT WE SAW IS THAT YOUTH ARE
ENDING UP.
IN HOSPITALS.
IN JUVENILE HALLS.
AND HOMELESS.
THAT NEVER NEEDED TO BE.
AND THEY DIDN'T NEED TO BE
BECAUSE THERE ARE MOMENTS IN
THOSE WHOSE LIFE AND THEIR
FAMILIES LIVE.
WHERE WE CAN OPTIONALLY
INTERVENE USING A MOBILE CRISIS
RESPONSE SYSTEM THAT CAN CHANGE
THEIR TRAJECTORY?
THE TRUTH IS I DON'T THINK WE
KNOW HOW MANY S. T. R. T. P.
BETS WE NEED IN THE STATE.
I DON'T THINK WE KNOW HOW MANY
FOSTER VETS WE NEED IN THE STATE
BECAUSE UNTIL WE BUILD THAT ARE
OUR SYSTEM OF FOSTER CARE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY US T. I. T.
PEOPLE AT TWENTY EIGHT AND UNTIL
WE BUILD OUTS THAT THINGS LIKE
MOBILE RESPONSE.
THAT DIVERT KIDS AN OPPORTUNITY
MOMENTS INTO AWAY FROM PLACES
LIKE HOSPITALS AND GROUP CARE
AND INTO MORE -- SUPPORTED HOME
BASED SERVICES THEN WE'LL KNOW
WHAT WE NEED FOR HIGHER AND
SERVICE.
WE'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
RUNNING FOR CONTRA COSTA AND SAN
FRANCISCO MOBILE RESPONSE TEAMS.
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN I STARTED I
HAD WRITTEN DOWN HERE OF THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN 80% DIVERSION RATE
BUT OUR CLINICAL DIRECTOR IS
HERE TODAY AND SHE REMINDED ME
THAT WAS EIGHTY THREE POINT
SOMETHING PERCENT.
YOU CAN'T FORGET THE DECIMAL
POINT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS MORE THAN
EIGHT OUT OF TEN KIDS DON'T END
UP IN A HOSPITAL WAITING ROOM
GOING TO PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK.
THEY DON'T END UP IN JUVENILE
HALL AND THEY DON'T USE A LOCAL
POLICE OFFICER AS THEIR CRISIS
COUNSELOR.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM A YOUTH IS IN
CRISIS THE PARENT DOESN'T KNOW
WHO OR WHAT WHO TO CALL OR HOW
TO GET HELP.
IN THE END UP COMING INTO A
SYSTEM THAT WAS NEVER DESIGNED
TO MEET THEIR NEEDS AND TO KEEP
THEM OUT OF HIGHER AND SYSTEMS
AND PROVIDE SUPPORT.
WE'VE DONE SO MUCH IN THE STATE
BY PROVIDING WRAPAROUND SERVICES
ACROSS THE STATE BY CREATING
SYSTEMS TO INTERVENE AND SCHOOLS
BY CREATING SYSTEMS THAT CAN
INTERVENE EARLIER.
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF THE OF
THE IRVINE GRANT AND TALKING
WITH LEADERS AROUND THE STATE
ABOUT WHAT WE COULD DO
DIFFERENTLY I BELIEVE THERE IS
NOTHING WE CAN DO.
THAT WOULD BE MORE IMPORTANT AND
MORE IMPACTFUL THAN TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM
I'M HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
JOHANNA IS HERE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS BECAUSE SHE ACTUALLY
KNOWS WHAT SHE'S TALKING ABOUT.
WE CALLED JOHANNA I THINK WE
SHOULD.
HI JOHANNA OF OUR BREATH MOBILE
RESPONSE TEAM SENECA.
AND I PARTICULARLY TRIED TO USE
ONLY TWO MINUTES THAT I'D LEAVE
YOU A MINUTE OR SO TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
DOMINANCE HOW MY PROGRAM.
SO WE'VE BEEN RUNNING OUR
PROGRAMS ARE IT WOULD YOU GAVE
YOU MADE IT FOR THE HARSH AS I
THOUGHT ARE COMING UP FOR ONE
MINUTE TO TELL US NUMBER.
SO WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN RUNNING A
PROGRAM FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS IN
OUR COUNTY -- WHICH IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT A REALLY LONG TIME
TO BE RUNNING A PROGRAM HALF OF
OUR STAFF HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
US FOR MORE THAN FIVE YEARS
WHICH IS WHILE CONSIDERING THAT
IT'S MENTAL HEALTH IT'S
COMMUNITY BASED AND IT'S CRISIS
WORK -- I THINK THE BEAUTY OF
OUR PROGRAM IS THAT WE'RE JUST
REALLY ABLE TO SERVE.
FAMILIES AT A TIME THAT'S
CONVENIENT FOR THEM AT THEIR
HOME ADD IN A SPACE THAT'S
COMING UP FOR THEM IN THEIR
LANGUAGE -- IT'S REALLY MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS RESPONDING
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES -- REALLY
THERE TO ADVOCATE FOR THEM AND
REALLY SUPPORT THEM THROUGHOUT
THAT ENTIRE PROCESS WHAT WE DO
HAVE A GREAT DIVERSION RATE IT
WE DON'T ALWAYS GET TO DIVERT
BUT WE DO GET TO HELP -- CHANCE
FOR THEM TO THE HOSPITAL BE WITH
THEM THROUGHOUT THAT PROCESS AND
REALLY SUPPORT THEM AND PROVIDE
FOLLOW UP SERVICES IF THEY NEED
ANY -- SO THE CONFLICT OVERVIEW
OF WHAT WE DO -- HAPPY AND IF IF
I COULD JUST ADD TO THAT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN.
WE IN MOST OF OUR COUNTY STACK
PROVIDES PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE.
AND MOST OF OUR CAN AS WE DON'T
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF HAVING
LEVEL RESPONSE.
AND SO WHAT WE SEE IS A CYCLE
WHETHER WHERE EITHER POLICE OR
SOMETIMES MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEING.
A CHILD ENDS UP IN AN EMERGENCY
ROOM IN THE HOSPITAL USUALLY
THOSE WAIT TIMES WHEN SOMEBODY'S
IN THE KID PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS.
IS OUR FOUR SIX EIGHT AT THE
I'VE HEARD NIGHTMARE STORIES OF
MUCH LONGER YOU KNOW THE STORIES --
OFTEN ARE TEENAGERS SIMPLY WALK
OUT.
THEY DON'T EVEN WAIT TO GET HELP.
THAT'S BEST CASE SCENARIO.
WORST CASE SCENARIOS LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS CALLED.
THE SOMETHING HAPPENS THAT TAKES
THEM DOWN THAT TRAJECTORY AND
THEY'RE IN JUVENILE HALL AND
THEN IN RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT OR
IN A GROUP HOME.
OF AT AND AND SO MANY OF THOSE
SITUATIONS ARE UNNECESSARY.
SO MANY OF THE SITUATIONS WHEN
WE GET TENER BEING AT THE
OPTIMAL POINT.
CAN PROVIDE THE PIVOT POINT THAT
ALLOWS US TO KEEP KIDS AT HOME
OR IN A FOSTER HOME.
OR IN THE COMMUNITY AND IN THE
COMMUNITY -- I KNOW THAT THE SO
WE HAVE MANY SOCIAL WORKERS HERE
AT THE CAPITOL FOR THEIR LOBBY
DAY.
AND THEY HAVE SHARED THE TO WHAT
A NIGHTMARE FOR THEM IS TO PICK
UP THE PHONE AND TO HAVE A
PARENT SAY.
I'VE GIVEN UP ON GIVING MY CHILD
TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO GET OUT OF
HERE -- THE AFTER OUR CHILDREN
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE HAVE
ALREADY EXPERIENCES TRAUMA FROM.
TO BE PLACED INTO FOSTER CARE.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THAT AND I THINK THAT
THIS FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM.
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT -- WE WE
NEED TO PRESERVE THE PLACEMENT.
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND NOT FOR
THE TRAUMATIZED THAT FOSTER
YOUTH.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT AND I I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE -- THE COMP
YOUR COMMENTS ON THIS AS WELL --
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
THAT WE HAVE LOTS OF FOSTER
YOUTH.
THERE WAS ONE INSTANCE WHERE
THEY WERE ALL HOLDING UP THEIR
SIGNS TO HOW MANY TIMES HAVE
BEEN PLACED [inaudible] FOURTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT THE THIS THIS IS WE
ALL LIKED WE ALL AGREE THIS IS
ALL.
UNACCEPTABLE HAVING A HOTLINE
HAVING DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE
HAVE TO DO. TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ARE OUR
CHILDREN TO KEEP THEM FROM.
BEING FURTHER TRAUMATIZED AND TO
FIGURE OUT TO DATE DOING THE THE
TRIAGE. TO FIND OUT THE TO KEEP
THEM AWAY FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO KEEP THEM AWAY FROM HOSPITALS --
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
I KNOW THE DOCTOR ARAMBULA --
THIS HAS BEEN ONE OF HIS TOP
PRIORITIES AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE IT
A TOP PRIORITY. FOR FOR THIS FOR
THIS COMMITTEE -- I THINK
CREATING THIS NURTURING
ENVIRONMENT JUST AS YOU'VE
DESCRIBED IT NOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE A PRE PLACEMENT.
VISIT THE TO MAKE YOU DO WITH
THE PARENTS SO THAT THE PARENTS
THEN KNOW WHO CAN SUPPORT THEM
TELL US ABOUT THAT WE DO WE'VE
RECEIVER FARRELL'S FROM A
VARIETY OF PLACES WE HAVE A
PRETTY.
AWESOME RELATIONSHIP BUT OUR
LOCAL THANK EMERGENCY SERVICE
AND SO KIDS THAT GO THROUGH
THERE THAT AREN'T FULLY LINKED
ON WE GET ALL THEIR DISCHARGE
PAPERWORK AND WERE ABLE TO REACH
OUT TO THEM -- AND I WOULD SAY
ABOUT 20% OF OUR YOUTH ARE
FOSTER YOUTH RIGHT NOW BUT WE
GET TO CALL.
THE FAMILY SAY HEY WE
UNDERSTANDING JUST WENT THROUGH
THIS CRISIS CAN WE COME OUT
THERE INTRODUCED OUR SERVICE TO
YOU IF THIS WAS THE COME UP
AGAIN HOW CAN WE SUPPORT YOU
WHAT OTHER.
RESEARCH CAN PROVIDE FOR YOU WE
ALSO GET REFERRALS FROM TEACHERS
SOCIAL WORKERS -- LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOMETIMES LONG
PERSONAL WHAT THE HOUSE SEVERAL
TIMES AND THEY DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT TO DO AND SO THEY ACTUALLY
REFER TO US -- A FEW MONTHS AGO
THERE WAS A WOMAN.
WHO ARE HER SON WAS HAVING A
TANTRUM IN THE STORE AND ANOTHER
PARENT SAID TO HER HATE CALL
THESE PEOPLE THEY CAN HELP YOU
AND SO THAT'S MY MOST PROUDEST
REFERRAL THAT WE'VE GOT IN --
BUT WE DEFINITELY CAN THEN REACH
OUT TO THOSE FAMILIES AND SAY --
YOU KNOW WE WE HEARD ABOUT YOU
MIGHT BENEFIT FROM OUR SERVICES
CAN COME OUT AND INTRODUCE
OURSELVES -- WE FIND THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT INITIAL
ASSESSMENT WERE ABLE -- TO IT'S
LIKE A WARM HAND OFF AND THEY'RE
MORE LIKELY TO UTILIZE US DURING
A CRISIS.
THANK YOU WERE PLAYING MUSICAL
CHAIRS.
ACTUALLY THE LAST TWO WEEKS HAVE
BEEN THAT WAY SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR OF FLEXIBILITY HERE -- SOUL
ANY REACTION OR FEEDBACK FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE ALEJO.
I'D SAY THE GREG ROSE AGAIN FOR
THE DEPARTMENT CERTAINLY WERE
AWARE OF THESE TYPES OF SERVICES --
AND PROGRAMS AND IN OTHER STATES
AND AND IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AND I THINK THAT THE KEY FOR US
IS THAT THE KEY FOR ME WHEN I
THINK ABOUT IS.
HOW WE GO ABOUT HOW
IMPLEMENTATION AGO ABOUT IT MANY
OF THE PLACES I'M AWARE IT ARE
RIGHT OUR SMALL SMALLER --
JURISDICTIONS AND DO WE DO HAVE.
URBAN AND RURAL AND DISTANCE AND
A NUMBER OF THINGS TO CONSIDER
BUT WE ARE IN FACT AWARE OF OF
OF THE UTILITY OF THESE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS AND WE'VE SEEN THEM IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
AND IF I MAY THE ALLEN BEATS SO
WAS ONE OF THE ENGINEERS OF THE
NEW JERSEY SYSTEM WHICH IS
ACTUALLY A LARGER MORE SKILLED
SYSTEM AND HE WORKED.
WITH US ON SOME OF THE IDEAS
AROUND CONSTRUCTION OF THE
SYSTEM AND HOW IT CAN BE SCALED --
MOBILE RESPONSE ACTUALLY.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH IS IN A
MORE COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM AT
SCALE THE THE SMALLER IT IS THE
MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO HAVE AVAILABILITY.
AND AN UNUSED AVAILABILITY IS
REALLY EXPENSIVE.
SO SO TO THE DEGREE THAT YOU CAN
HAVE DEPTH IN TEAMS TO RESPOND
TO A BROADER AREA YOU DO GET.
NOT JUST SMALL ECONOMIES OF
SCALE BUT BIG ECONOMIES OF SCALE
AROUND THE INITIAL RESPONSE
ESPECIALLY SO THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT REALLY WORK ABOUT A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT IN THE SMALLER SYSTEMS
THAT WE'RE RUNNING.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT.
JUSTIN PRENTICE BERMAN FINANCE --
AS WITH ALL THE PROPOSALS ARE WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON ANY OF
THEM AT THIS TIME -- SO AGAIN.
TO THE EXTENT IT'S PRIORITY OF
THE LEGISLATURE WERE HAPPY.
TO ENGAGE WITH ON THE DON'T.
THANK YOU FOR THE LAST YOU HEAR
THAT [inaudible]
ELIA.
THANK YOU RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
AND THEN I'LL GOING TO COLLAPSE --
SUSAN AND IF [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL BE DISCUSSING
CONTINUED EMERGENCY CARE GIVER
FUNDING AT THE TIME OF PLACEMENT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
EARLIER BETWEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO IN THE STATE -- US ALL OF
THE LA US COMMENTS HIM TO BE
TALKING A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THE FUNDING -- AS A STATE
MANSION LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION CAME TOGETHER HEN
THEY STAND A CRISIS.
AND YOUR FOR YOUR FUNNY AT THE
TIME A PLACEMENT HAS JUST BEEN A
LIFESAVER. FOR TEN THOUSAND THE
FAMILY TO ME JUST SO MANY FOLKS
ON WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
HOWEVER WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE COMING YEAR.
SO IN THE DEAL THAT WAS MADE
LAST YEAR WE THOUGHT WE WOULD BE
AT NINETY DAYS ISSUE NOTED THE
STATE THOUGHT WE WOULD BE THERE
AND SO.
IN THE LEGISLATION WE NOW CUT
OFF THAT FUNDING IT NINETY DAYS
STARTING ON JUNE THIRTIETH.
AND THERE'S ALSO NO GOOD BECAUSE
EXEMPTION ANYMORE SO ALL THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE AND ALL
THIS GOOD NEWS THAT THE STATE
GAVE YOU.
ALL ENDS ON JUNE THIRTIETH.
SAYS ADVOCATES WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WE WOULD
ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY
WHO WORK WITH US TO CONTINUE THE
AMAZING WORK THAT HAPPENED. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE EXTEND TO AT
LEAST A HUNDRED AND TWENTY OR A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
DAYS.
BECAUSE A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS IS
THE CURRENT AVERAGE.
SAID ANYTHING BELOW THAT REALLY
IS GOING TO PUT FAMILIES AT RISK
WE ALSO REALLY ENCOURAGE THE
GOOD BECAUSE EXEMPTION WOULD
NEED THAT BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
FAMILIES THAT.
FOR REASONS BEYOND THEIR CONTROL
IT GOES PAST THAT THEY CAN'T
JUST LOSE FUNDING OVER THINGS
THAT ARE NOT UNDER THEIR CONTROL.
IT HARMS NOT ONLY THESE FAMILIES
BUT ALSO THE CHILDREN IN THEIR
CARE.
THANK YOU FOR POINTING THAT OUT
BECAUSE I'M -- AS WE SPOKE
EARLIER -- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE BY
NOW WE HAVE TO OBVIOUSLY
CONTINUE BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO LOSE THAT AGAIN PUTTING IN
DANGER THOSE FAMILIES.
THAT HAVE STEPPED UP TO SUPPORT
THOSE CHILDREN SOUL WHAT CAN WE
TOGETHER DO AND OUT WHAT
SPECIFIC -- SUGGESTIONS
RECOMMENDATIONS -- CAN YOU
PROVIDE SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
WITH THIS.
ABSOLUTELY AND APPRECIATE THE
EGG KNOWLEDGE MEN OF THEIR
EARLIER CONVERSATION I MEAN THIS
IS AN EXAMPLE OF AN AREA WHERE A
CONVERSATION AMONGST MULTIPLE
GROUPS GROUPS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND COUNTIES IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
RESULTED IN A GOOD SOLUTION TO A
KNOWN PROBLEM THE WORLD'S
DYNAMIC -- AS WITH MANY THINGS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY AND YOU KNOW --
IN THE THERE'S AN UNWRITTEN RULE
SOMEWHERE THAT IF IF I TOLD YOU --
THAT WE WERE LOOKING AT ISSUES
FROM REVISION -- THAT THAT WOULD
BE A FAUX PAS SO I'M NOT GONNA
TELL YOU THAT.
HELLO BUT I WOULD IN NO WAY TEN
I DIDN'T HEAR -- BUT YET BUT BUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY -- AS
I MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T
WEIGH IN ON C. C. R. NOGEN TEN
PROPOSAL SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATION NOW THAT HE'S BEEN
IN OFFICE FOR A FEW MONTHS
PERHAPS IT'S A TIME.
FOR YOU KNOW FOR HIM TO TAKE A
BETTER LOOK AT WHAT'S I HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO DOUBT HE'D BE
INTERESTED IN THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU NO I APPRECIATE THAT
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT
OUT BECAUSE AGAIN YOU KNOW AT WE
I WANT TO AGAIN COMPLIMENT.
YOU ON THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE
DONE BY CLEARLY THERE'S MORE
WORK TO BE DONE SO PLEASE DON'T
LET THIS FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS --
AT AT SOME POINT -- WE NEED TO
BE ENGAGED AS PARTNERS WITH
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T BRING IT UP
AND WE DON'T BRING IT UP.
THERE AND THEN IT GOES BY THE
WAYSIDE SHELTER YOU WILL WERE
FALLING CONFIDENCE THANK YOU
DROPS I APPRECIATE AND I LOOK
FORWARD -- TO MAKING SURE THAT
WITH THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE HAD
AND AND FOR THE GOVERNOR TO NOT
LOOK AT THEM ME REVISION OR LOOK
AT IT WHATEVER IT IS THAT HE
WANTS TO DO BY THESE ARE --
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS IF WE WANT
TO KEEP CALLING THEM THAT I
THINK IT'S AN INVESTMENT BUT FOR
ME IT'S LIFESAVING MEASURES FOR
SOME OF THESE THESE FAMILY SOLD
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
THEN WHAT TIME YOUR FAVORITE
OKAY -- THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
HELLO YES IF I MAY I MEAN I I
BROKE A LITTLE BIT OF A ROLL
TALKING ABOUT THAT I DO I WANT
TO BE.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR I DID
NOT COMMIT THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING NOT MANY DIDN'T HEAR
ANYTHING THIS YEAR BUT I DON'T
NOT CREATION IS ABSOLUTELY PART
OF THE CONVERSATION AROUND IT'S
NO NO AND I AND AND I APPRECIATE
THAT -- BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW IF
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
THIS WORK WE NEED SOME SOME --
INDICATION THAT AT LEAST THE POT
IS IN THERE AND I THAT'S WHAT I
HEARD THAT THERE'S SOME THINKING
ABOUT IT I KNOW THAT YOU DIDN'T
MAKE A COMMITMENT BY IT BUT IT'S
REFRESHING. FOR ME TO TO HEAR
THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME
THOUGHTS PUT INTO IT AND SO I'M
NOT COMMITTING YOU TO ANYTHING
YET -- BUT IT'S OUR PASSION A
COMMON APPLIES TO A NUMBER OF
THINGS C. C. R. AS A LIVE ANIMAL
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
THANK YOU AND THEN -- FRANK --
WE ARE.
YOU ARE UP AGAIN TALKING ABOUT
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL AND
CANCER ASSESSMENT AND I KNOW WE
HAD SOME DISCUSSION ALREADY
ABOUT THE APPROVALS.
SO IF WE CAN -- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR POP FRANK MACKESY WTA WE
HAVE INDEED MADE OUR CASE FOR
CONTINUING THE RFA FUNDING SO I
WON'T -- REITERATE THAT HERE AND
ON CANS IT'S A NEW FAMILY CHILD
ASSESSMENT TOOL WE'VE COME UP
WITH A PRELIMINARY ESTIMATE WITH
THE STATE OF HOW MUCH IT'S GOING
TO COST THE COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT IT.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO WORK WITH US TO TRACK THE
ACTUAL COSTS SO GOING FORWARD WE
CAN RIGHT SIZE BUDGETS MOVING
FORWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE ALEJO
DEPARTMENT.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
AND TRANSPORTATION OKAY MORE
MOVING ON TO TRANSPORTATION TO
SCHOOL AND OR OR SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN AT TIME OF PLACEMENT --
KRISTIN POWER.
AND JORDAN SOSA THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KRISTIN
POWER FOR THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS I WE TRUE WE
APPRECIATE THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION OF FUNDING AT THE
TIME OF PLACEMENT.
AND THIS ITEM IS RELATED TO THAT --
THIS IS FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD CHEN. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT RIGHT THE CHILD IN
FOSTER CARE HAS IS THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN IN THEIR SCHOOL OF ORIGIN.
AND TO BE SURE THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY GET TO THAT SCHOOL AND
THE SCHOOL BOARD IN RIGHTS.
ARE IMPLEMENTED WE MUST HAVE
FUNDING REIMBURSEMENTS THE CARE
GIVER FOR TRANSPORTING THAT.
CHILD TO THE SCHOOL THE PROBLEM
THAT WE SEE EXISTING IS THE CARE
GIVERS ARE ONLY ENTITLED TO
REIMBURSEMENT FOR PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION TO A SCHOOL BOARD
AND ONCE THEY'RE APPROVED AS A
RESOURCE FAMILY.
RELATIVES AN EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBERS GENERALLY ACCEPT
PLACEMENT OF A CHILD BEFORE
THEY'VE BEEN APPROVED AS YOU
HAVE THAT PREVIOUS DISCUSSION
TODAY.
AND THE APPROVAL PROCESS IS
LENGTHY AND WE KNOW IT'S
AVERAGING AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS CURRENTLY.
A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS IS AND CAN
BE THE MAJORITY OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR.
FAMILIES CAN'T WAIT THAT LONG TO
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT AND WITHOUT
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO COVER THE
COST OF TRANSPORTATION IT'S
OFFICE UNTENABLE FOR THE
FAMILIES TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT.
AND TRANSPORT THAT CHILD AT THE
SCHOOL BOARD CHEN.
WHEN WE SPEAK -- TO HOW
IMPORTANT SCHOOL CONNECTIONS ARE
AND THIS FUNDING MAKES THAT
STABILITY A REALITY.
WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT
REIMBURSEMENT FOR TRANSPORTING A
CHILD THEIR SCHOOL OF ORIGIN IS
INITIATED AT THAT TIME OF
PLACEMENTS.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JORDAN SOSA I'M ALL OF
FORMER FOSTER YOU FROM LAST LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I SERVE AT
THE STATE WHY POLICY COORDINATOR
FOR CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION.
OF BEFORE JUST PROVIDE THE
PROVIDING MATHIS MONEY I LIKE TO
THINK -- SHEA HOUSE AND MY
SISTER ANNA SOSA FOR OPENING MY
EYES TO THE TRIALS AND
TRIBULATIONS MANY YOUTH PHASE OF
UP FROM INSTABILITY WITHIN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE AND
CALIFORNIA'S TROUBLE FOR SYSTEM
EXPERIENCE BOTH PLACEMENT AND
EDUCATIONAL STABILITY AND IT'S
FAR TOO COMMON HEARING THE LACK
THE PERMANENCY OF OUR YOUTH
EXPERIENCE INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
THE CLASSROOM.
WE ALWAYS HEAR THE VICIOUS CYCLE
OF THE EDUCATIONAL.
OUTCOMES FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH
50% GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL
10% PURSUE A COLLEGE EDUCATION
AND ONLY 3% OF GRADUATE FROM
HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT RESEARCH
STATES THE EDUCATIONAL DISPARITY
BETWEEN FOSTER YOUTH AND THE
GENERAL POPULATION IS DUE TO THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTABILITY FOSTER
YOUTH EXPERIENCE AS A RESULT.
OF MULTIPLE PLACEMENT CHANGES
EVEN THOUGH I MOVED TO MULTIPLE
HOMES AND FAMILIES AND FOSTER
CARE I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO STAY
IN THE SAME HIGH SCHOOL.
HOWEVER THIS IS NOT THE SAME
STORY FOR MY THREE YOUNGER
SISTERS WHO ARE STILL LIVING IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
I HAVE TO WITNESS MY SISTERS
MOVED FROM ONE HOME TO ANOTHER
BECAUSE THE SYSTEMS LET THEM
DOWN.
ST I HAD THE WITNESS SAYING
THERE SEE AND SAYING THEIR
GOODBYES BECAUSE OF THE SEVEN
DAY NOTICE ACTING ALL THEIR
BELONGINGS AND SEVEN DAYS AND
QUESTIONING IF THEY WERE LOVED
OR WANTED WHICH IS THE QUESTION
THAT WILL LAST LONGER THAN SEVEN
DAYS.
WITH THIS WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
RAISE TO ENSURE THAT
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR
TRANSPORTATION A CHILD TO THEIR
SCHOOL OF ORIGIN IS INITIATED AT
THE TIME OF PLACEMENT SO THAT
OUR YOUTH CAN THRIVE.
AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY AND ONE HOME AND ONE
SCHOOL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS WE'LL.
I THINK OUR PRIOR REMARKS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORTING
FAMILIES WHO MAY BE BEFORE AFTER
APPROVAL NEED SUPPORT -- SPEAKS
FOR ITSELF.
THANK YOU I'M DO.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THE ESTIMATE
FOR THE PROPOSAL -- AND LET ME
JUST KIND OF ELABORATE ON THAT
SO WE TALKED ABOUT AT LENGTH
EARLIER ABOUT THE THE GREAT.
JOB THAT WE'VE DONE AND
APPROVING THE FAMILIES -- IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
ENTER IN THE INTERIM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE ARE FAMILIES ARE
RECEIVING THE TRANSPORTATION
COSTS AND AGAIN DO YOU AGREE
WITH THE ESTIMATE.
SO I ARE ALIVE YOU SPEAK TO THE
ASPECT BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
PERSONALLY SEEN IT SO I I'M NOT
QUALIFIED PROBABLY TO TALK ABOUT
IT I WILL TELL YOU THAT SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING WAS
REALIGNED IN TWENTY ELEVEN TO
COUNTIES SO STATE VISIBILITY
INTO EXACTLY WHAT'S BEING SPENT
TODAY AND HOW.
MUCH A CASE COSTS IS SOMEWHAT
LIMITED.
JUST IMPRISONMENT FINANCE WHO I
BELIEVE -- THERE'S ALSO
COMPANION LEGISLATION THAT'S
RELATED TO THAT SO I THINK IT'S
A ASSEMBLY BILL -- THREE THREE
SEVEN AND AND FINANCES -- I
BELIEVE OUR ANALYSIS MIGHT BE
OUT I'M NOT SURE BUT I THERE
MIGHT BE SOME QUESTIONS WITH THE
THE ACTUAL LAST IMMINENT -- WE
HAVEN'T REALLY DUG DEEP INTO
EVERYTHING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE CASELOAD IS AND BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPONENTS THAT
GO INTO THIS SOME.
OF THE WAY THE PROGRAM WORKS --
FOR THOSE FAMILIES THAT ARE
APPROVED IN YOUR FUNDING AMOUNT
IS DEPENDENT UPON YOUR MILEAGE
FROM THE HOME.
OR IF -- IT'S A A MONTHLY BUS
STIPEND AND SO ON SO.
THE SIMPLE ANSWER FOR YOU IS --
WE'RE NOT SURE IF THAT'S THE
CORRECT ESTIMATE WE'RE NOT SURE
IF IT'S TO HIRE IF IT'S TOO LOW --
BUT THERE ARE BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME VARIABLES TO LOOK INTO ON
THAT -- SO.
I I WON'T SAY WHAT YOU DON'T
WANT ME TO SAY -- BUT BUT WE I I
I CAN DOUBLE CHECK FOR YOU AND
FIND OUT OF OUR ANALYSIS IS
PUBLIC RIGHT AND AND AND HOW.
NOT ONLY -- IF THE ANALYSIS IS
CORRECT BUT HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
DETERMINE.
IF IT IS TOO HIGH OR TOO LOW --
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A A KIND OF
AN ACCOUNTING TYPE OF ISSUE WELL
IT'S JUST IT'S LIKE USUAL
EVERYTHING IS AN ESTIMATE FOR
ITS RIGHT BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT THE CASE THAT IS GOING TO
BE AWARE YOUTH MAY.
NOT BE PLACED -- GETS A ONE BY
ONE TIME A YOUTH COULD
POTENTIALLY BE PLACED. THREE
MILES FROM -- THEIR SCHOOL BOARD
CHEN AND THEN A NEW PLACE
SPENDING GREG IF YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING.
THEY COULD BE PLACED SOMEWHERE
WHERE IT'S TEN MILES AWAY SO --
WE WE DO TAKE AND ALL THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS WITH WORKING WITH --
THE DEPARTMENT WHEN WE TRY TO
COME UP WITH THAT CEMENT SO
YOU'RE CORRECT THERE'S NO.
PERFECT POINT WE CAN SAY EXACTLY
WHAT IT IS BUT WE NEED TO TRY TO
DO OUR BEST TO TO GIVE AN
ACCURATE OR A BEST ESTIMATE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN WE MAKE OUR
ANALYSES.
REGRETS THE DEPARTMENT I JUST
SAY TO HISTORICALLY WHAT WE DO
WE OFTEN DO IS LOOK AT PREVIOUS
EXPENDITURES FOR A SIMILAR --
POPULATIONS OF THE FOR THOSE
APPROVED VERSES THE OF FOLKS
THAT ARE TO PROVE WE COULD LOOK
WE CAN LOOK AT THOSE PREVIOUS
EXPENDITURES.
AS AS AS MISTER SPEAKER JUST
SAID -- SOME OF THOSE BECAUSE OF
REALIGNMENT THAT THE PRECISION
OF THE OF KNOWING EXACTLY WHAT
WAS SPENT -- IS IS A LITTLE LESS
PRECISE THAN IT HAS HISTORICALLY
BEEN BUT THERE ARE SOME.
WAYS IN WHICH WE COULD PARTNER
WITH FINANCE AND THE ADVOCATES
TO KIND OF LOOK THROUGH TO ME I
WOULD HOPE SO.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU COULD YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY AN
IMPORTANT PIECE TO THIS IF WE
CAN'T -- PROVIDE THE THE MONEY
IF WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY
WE'RE GOING TO NEED FOR IT SO.
THAT OUR FAMILY FOUNDER COUNTIES
TO BE HELPFUL AND COLLECTING
DATA OR SURVEY IN A COUPLE
SELECT COUNTIES FOR US TO HELP
ENABLE THOSE ESTIMATES.
THAT ALWAYS A GROUP EFFORT ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT.
ALL OF YOUR PARTICIPATION AND
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE -- PLEASE
EXPECT MORE CONVERSATIONS LIKE
THIS -- ALSO -- THERE'S ONE LAST
YOU SHOULD LIKE TO RAISE IN
REGARDS TO OVERSIGHT LANGUAGE
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY ADOPTED IN --
TWENTY SIXTEEN STAFF HAS
INFORMED ME THAT ARE AT WORK TO
UPDATE AND CODIFY THIS LANGUAGE
HAS BEEN INITIATED AND I AGREE
THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD ADOPT THIS PART OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET -- THANK
YOU TO THE LA -- FOR GREEN TO
WORK WITH US ON THIS I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING A PRODUCT AND
THIS IS I BET.
ACTUAL PRODUCT THAT WE CAN TAKE
ACTION ON AS WE CLOSE OUT THE ME
REVISION HEARING AND SOMEONE
NEXT MONTH AND IT'S APRIL.
I'M FOR AYE IT HOW IT IS IT
APRIL TENTH IS.
CRAZY ENOUGH BY MAY IS RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER WE'VE ONLY GOT
A COUPLE WEEKS I LOOK FORWARD --
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS OBVIOUSLY
SOON BECAUSE YOU KNOW MADE JUNE
IS COMING UP RIGHT AFTER THAT
AND SO WORK.
I DON'T WANNA BE FOUND IN A
POSITION WHERE WE'RE NOT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME FOR THIS.
THANK YOU VERY.
OKAY.
SURE OKAY I'M VOCAL HAND AND
TAKE IT OUT PUBLIC COMMENT ON
EVERYTHING THAT ISSUE ONE PLEASE.
AND AGAIN WE WHICH ISSUE.
YES AND PLEASE IDENTIFY WHICH
ISSUES YOUR THINKING ON AND IF
WE CAN YOU KNOW WE HAVE QUITE A
FEW PEOPLE CAN LIMIT THE
COMMENTS I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT.
THANK YOU JESSICA BARTH UP ON
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY ON COMMENT ONE AA.
WITH REGARDS.
TO TO READ AT BRINGING FOSTER
YOUTH AND FINDING FAT AND
FAMILIES FOR THEM TO BE WITH A
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED IN SERVING
FAMILIES -- WITH -- YOUTH WHO
ARE IN -- WHO'VE GONE TO
JUVENILE HALL OR HAVE BEEN
ADJUDICATIVE OF CRIME WE'VE
IDENTIFIED AN ISSUE WITH -- WELL
FOR INSTITUTIONS CODE WHICH
ALLOWS FOR RESTITUTION TO BE
CHARGED TO A GUARDIAN.
AND AND THAT MEANS THAT WHEN.
YOU HAVE A YOUTH WITH A YOU WITH
AN EDUCATION.
THEIR FAMILIES EXTENDED FAMILIES --
OR FRIENDS ARE GOING TO BE LESS
LIKELY TO TAKE THEM INTO THEIR
HOME IF THEY THEN HAVE TO PAY
THE RESTITUTION OF THE YOUTH --
FOR THEIR DEDICATION AND SO THAT
THE LAW IS VERY OLD.
IT -- IT SAYS THAT FOSTER
PARENTS ARE EXEMPT AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO ALSO EIGHT BE INCLUSIVE OF A
GUARDIAN TYPE PERSON A NON
PARENT -- AND SO WE WOULD WE
WOULD ASKED FOR SOME
CONSIDERATION OF CHANGE OF THAT
RULE WE'LL SEND YOU AN EMAIL AS
FOLLOW UP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CNN FMI CHILDREN NOW HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ALL THE
ITEMS THERE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR CHILDREN BUT PRIMARILY FOR
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM.
AND THIS WILL JUST RADICALLY
ALTER HOW WE SUPPORT CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT CARE
GIVERS ARE RESPONDING TO THEIR
NEEDS.
THIS IS ALSO ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVING SOMEONE THAT THEY CAN
CALL WHEN THEY'RE FRUSTRATED
ABOUT THE SITUATION THE HOME OR
DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GET HELP A
YOUNG PERSON CAN ALSO CALL THIS
LINE.
AND GET THEIR CONCERNS ADDRESSED
AND GET HELP FOR THEMSELVES SO
JUST WANTED TO KNOW THAT BUT
IT'S A GREAT WAY TO AVOID LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ALL THE OTHER
THINGS YOU'VE HEARD AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
LET ME CENTERS ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA ONE ALIGN MYSELF WITH
EVERYTHING FRANK MAC ASIDE AS
ALWAYS PARTICULARLY IN RELATION
TO THE PRETTY PLEASE WITH SUGAR
ON TOP DO NOT THROW THE BABY OUT
WITH THE BATHWATER -- REGARDING
THE SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT WE'VE
MADE ON WE NEED ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS WE NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL TINKERING AROUND THE
EDGES TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO WITH THE GARDEN
IMPORTANT WORK.
THAT WE'RE DOING -- BUT WE NEED
SOME TIME TO TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT -- WANT TO REGISTER OUR
STRONG SUPPORTER AND EXCITEMENT
ABOUT THE FIRST PROPOSAL ON ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT COMPONENTS
OF THAT THE OUTCOME THAT WERE
HOPEFULLY OPTIMISTIC I'VE.
IS MAKING SURE THAT KIDS IN
CRISIS WHEN THEIR FAMILIES CALL
OR WHEN THEY CALL THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GET REMOVED FROM THE
HOME AT THAT TIME EVERY TIME A
CHILD IS REMOVED ADDITIONAL
TRAUMA.
IS INDUCED AND SO WE WANT TO
PREVENT THAT IN EVERY WAY
POSSIBLE ALL WHEN A REGISTER
SUPPORT -- FOR THE PROPOSAL TO
NOT REDUCE THE RFA ALLOCATION AS
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUDGET BY TWENTY FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
WE ARE DOING FABULOUS WORK IN
THAT ARENA TO PULL THE RUG OUT
FROM UNDER US -- AND SORRY.
SO PLEASE DON'T TAKE THAT MONEY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I DANIEL SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS ON THE HEARING VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY
STABILITY FUND WERE PLEASED TO
BE PART OF A COALITION -- WITH
MANY THE PARTNERS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD HERE TODAY AND SO WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AROUND THE IMPORTANCE
OF THOSE FUNDS AND REALLY -- AS
A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT THAT
GOES A LONG WAY TO ENSURING THE
SUCCESS OF C. C. R. IN AND
ENSURING THAT WERE ABLE -- TO
BUILD OUT THE SUPPORTS AND
ALTERNATIVES ON THAT WE NEED IN
THIS REGARD SO WE ENCOURAGE IN
AND ASK FOR YOUR STRONG SUPPORT
OF THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- IS
SUCCESSFUL. TO SEE OUR MEANS AN
IMPORTANT PARTY FOR COUNTIES IN
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH --
AND SO WE REALLY ARE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THESE INVESTMENTS
WILL HELP COUNTIES BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO RECRUIT RETAIN
APPROVE SUPPORT FAMILIES HERE
CARING FOR CHILDREN.
I'M AS WELL AS BE READY TO
RESPOND IN THOSE EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
VITAL SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAN LUIS MULTIPLE HATS TODAY I'M
ON BEHALF OF THE AT ITEM ONE BE
THE FIRST SYSTEM THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH IS IN
SUPPORT OF THAT.
AND THEN ON THE EMERGENCY CARE
GIVER AT TIME OF FUNDING AT TIME
OF PLACEMENT HAVE BOTH CITY WHY
AND A SPIRIT THAT WHICH IS ONE
OF THE FIRST I THINK ESTHER
TEEPEES.
AND THE STATE INSOFAR THAT
PROPOSALS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
KRISTIN PARA THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS ON BEHALF OF
CARE GIVERS AND THE CHILDREN IN
THEIR CARE SUPPORTING AT FAMILY
STABILITY FUND FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM IN THE CONTINUED
EMERGENCY CHARACTER FUNDING AT
THE TIME OF PLACEMENT.
THANK YOU.
JULIE MCCORMICK CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT OVER THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND YOUTH IN SACRAMENTO LOS
ANGELES AND PLASTER COUNTY.
ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS SO MANY
OF THESE.
ISSUES -- BROUGHT UP IN ISSUE
ONE ARE IMPORTANT TO THEM AS
YOU'VE HEARD THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM WILL ADDRESS
YOUTH AS WELL NOT JUST CARE
GIVERS -- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM OR
HOSPITALIZATION IS NOT THE ONLY
ALTERNATIVE FOR THESE YOUTH IN
TIME OF CRISIS.
THE CONTINUED EMERGENCY CARE
GIVER FUNDING IS ESSENTIAL WE
HAVE FOUND THESE YOUTH --
RELATIVE PLACEMENTS -- I THINK
SOMEONE JUST USE THE PHRASE TO
PULL THE RUG OUT FROM UNDER THEM
AT THIS POINT -- WOULD BE
EXTREMELY DETRIMENTAL WE ARE
ALSO -- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
TRANSPORTATION TO THE SCHOOL
VIRGIN AT THE TIME OF PLACEMENT.
PLACEMENTS ABILITY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BUT SCHOOL STABILITY
THAT IS ANOTHER COMMUNITY THAT
THESE CHILDREN ARE LOSING IF
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
TYPE OF FUNDING THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK MAKE
WITH C. TO BEGIN IN ADDITION TO
THE ITEMS THAT I SPOKE -- TO
EARLIER WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
OTHER ITEMS ALL THE OTHER ITEMS
IN THE SECTION IN PARTICULAR THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM IS
A CRITICAL PART OF FORGET TO
DELIVER ON THE PROMISE OF CCR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTY BALLOT I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER IN SAMBHAR TO DINO COUNTY
AND I'M HERE WITH SEIU.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE FOR PACKED REFORM
PACKAGE I CAN SPEAK FIRST HAND
TO THE NEED OF OUR FAMILIES
THEY'RE NOT FEELING SUPPORT YET.
I CAN SPEAK TO THE NEED FOR THAT
FIRST RESPONSE TEAM WE HAVE A
MOBILE RESPONSE TEAM FOR CRISIS
BUT IT'S GENERALIZED IT'S NOT
SPECIFIC TO FOSTER YOUTH.
SOMETHING THAT'S ACTUALLY DRIVEN
FOR FOSTER YOUTH FAMILIES AND
NEEDS.
THAT WOULD BE SO HELPFUL AND
WOULD MAKE ALL THE DIFFERENCE
OUR FAMILIES DESERVE PERMANENT
SEEN OUR CHILDREN DUE.
TO THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS DON ENDS
ON WHILE I'M A PUBLIC HELPFUL AS
YOU ARE YOU SEVENTY ONE MEMBER
AND A PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE FROM
LOS ANGELES COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
OKAY I AM IN THE BRISTOL BOARD
OF THE FAMILY URGES RESPONSE
SYSTEM AS WELL AS RESTORING
FUNDING FOR OUR FACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARQUITA HERIS
SOME ALSO PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
THE WORDS IN THE LA COUNTY AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE FURS AS
WELL AS THEY ARE A FACE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI I'M VANESSA JOHNSON PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE INFORMED CORRIDOR.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I SUPPORT
THE FURS AN RFA.
HELLO MY NAME'S AMY LAMB LAMB
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE FIVE THAT SET OF OUT BUDGET
PROPOSALS TO FULFILL THE PROMISE
OF US EASIER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR --
MEMBERS MARTHA CARRERA
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY
STABILITY FUNDED THE CONTINUE TO
BRIDGE THE CARE GIVER FUNDING
THAT TIME A PLACEMENT.
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
TRANSPORTATION TO SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN AT TIME OF PLACEMENT
THESE ARE ALL IMPORTANT --
BUDGET -- SUPPORTS FOR THE
FOSTER FAMILIES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE WITH THE PROMISES THAT
WE MADE THREE CC ARE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS -- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION PLEASE TO BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE.
THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS BUT I WANT A
ESPECIALLY EMPHASIZE SPURS AND
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY MAC MILLAN
ON BEHALF THE CEMETERY -- COUNTY
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE FIRST
PROGRAM THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK ALONG WITH
GRACE AND HELP ARE BEING
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE SUPPORT OF
THE FIRST THE PROPOSAL AS WELL
AS THE TRANSMISSION TO SCHOOL
WORK AND THANK YOU.
DAPHNE DESIGNEE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THE MARGIN TO CARE GIVER FUNDING
AS WELL AS TRANSPORTATION TO
SCHOOL OF ART AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI JANE CHARTER WITH FIRST PLACE
FOR YOUTH HERE IN SUPPORT OF
FURS WE THINK THIS WILL BE
REALLY BENEFICIAL TO TRANSITION
AGE FRUSTRATING BECAUSE WELL
THANK YOU.
CHRIS STONER MERTZ CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF THE FIVE
ISSUES AND I WANNA.
PARTICULAR COLA THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION TO SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN.
THANK YOU.
GENEREX READ WITH CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT FOR ALL OF ALL OF THE
FUNDING FOR ISSUE ONE THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CARA MUDAH
SEKALI PUT FAMILIES WE WORK WITH
OVER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
RELATIVE CARE GIVERS IN THIS
REGION AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF CONTINUING EMERGENCY CARE
GIVER FUNDING AT TIME OF
PLACEMENT AS WELL TRANSPORTATION
TO SCHOOL MARGIN.
A TOP PLACEMENT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANY AGUILAR FROM
YOU COMMUNITY COLLEGE I'D LIKE
TO FIRST APOLOGIZE -- WE I'M
ACTUALLY HERE TO ADDRESS ITEM TO
I ACTUALLY BROUGHT SOME OF OUR
STUDENTS FROM CHICO CALIFORNIA
WE ARE SHORT ON TIME WE'VE BEEN
HERE SINCE EARLY THIS MORNING ON
A COUPLE OTHER BILLS.
IN IF YOU JUST ALLOW IT'S JUST A
MOMENT TO ADDRESS SUPPORT ON
ITEM. TO TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AMONG FORMER POSITIVE I'M IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M CHARLES STEVENS I ARE
CURRENTLY BENEFITING FROM THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLACEMENT
PLUS FOSTER CARE PROGRAM.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER TWO ORCHARD USE
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARCY WILLIAM FROM
BUTTE COLLEGE -- AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE TO REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS AMONG FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH.
ADVOCACY PROPOSAL -- WITHOUT T.
H. P. PROGRAM A PLUS PLUS I
PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE HERE TODAY
ARE PROBABLY ON THE STREETS AND
DOING SOME OTHER DIFFERENT
THINGS AND I APPRECIATE IT MAN.
PUSHED OUT FOR A DAY THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELIZABETH MORE
AND I'M A STUDENT AT BIãU
COLLEGE TIME HERE IN SUPPORT OF
MORE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID V. D. I'M A
CHILD WHILE FOR SOCIAL WORKER
AND I'M HERE WITH SEIU.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL.
IS WELL AS THE FIRST.
AND IT THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM PACKAGE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIO
PROMOTERS I'M WITH SEIU LOCAL
SEVEN TWO ONE I'M ALSO A CHILD
WELFARE SOCIAL WORKER WITH INTER
COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE ASKING FOR SUPPORT
WITH THE FURS AND ALSO THE
RESOURCE FAMILY PROFIL THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA EARLIER I AM
A NAVY VETERAN AND I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER AT AS STANISLAUS COUNTY
COMMUNITY SERVICES AGENCY -- I'M
PART OF SEIU LOCAL PHONE FIVE
TWENTY ONE AND I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE -- REFORMS CAM
SPECIFICALLY THE FIBERS AND THE
FURS AND THE RFA.
AS A SOCIAL WORKER I SEE THEIR
GREAT IMPORTANCE.
APART THEM [inaudible]
HI -- I'M JERRY CRIED -- LA
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER -- HERE
FROM -- SEIU SEVEN TWO ONE
ATOMIZED TO SUPPORT THE FUNDING
FOR JUST A FUNDING.
FOR FIRST AT M. A. B..
TWELVE AN RV FOR THE I THANK YOU.
HELLO -- TONYA REELS FROM
COLLEGE AND AND TALKING ABOUT
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO OF FULLY APPROVE OF IT -- AS
A FAST STUDIOS -- THAT CONTINUES
THE OF BE IN AND TEACH PEOPLE AS
WELL IN THIS CASE HOMELESSNESS --
LIKE OVER ALL THE PROGRAM HAS
REALLY HELPED NOT ONLY ME BUT A
LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE I KNOWING --
BALLS SCHOOL WISE AND OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
I DO APOLOGIZE WE ARE ALSO
TRAVELING AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE NUMBER TWO I HAVE A FEW
YOUTH BEHIND ME THEY WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD REVENUE NAM MY NAME IS
MARCUS CRAZINESS ON FROM THP
INFAMOUS ACCOUNTING.
HERE TO SUPPORT THE HOMELESS FOR
THE YOU THINK IF THANK YOU.
HI MERIAL RUBIO -- I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER -- TWO
TEACH BE PLUS I'VE BEEN A
PARTICIPANT FOR TWO YEARS AND
IT'S BEEN REALLY BENEFICIAL --
SO YEAH I SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRENCE FLAG --
TWENTY YEARS OLD I'VE BEEN PART
OF THE CHIEF PLACE OR I'M BOUT
TO BEING PART OF THE TATE GHB
PLUS -- I'VE BEEN I AM TWENTY AT
THE MOMENT AND THIS PROGRAM IN
VERY.
VERY HELPFUL FOR ME TAUGHT ME
HOW TO GET HIM DEPEND SEE FOR
MYSELF AND THANKS FOR THEM I
HAVE A STEADY JOB THAT I LIKE TO
GO TO EVERY DAY AND IT MAKES ME
HAPPY WORKING THERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ABBOTT THAT US AS
WITH OBLIVION WE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE SERVICES STATEWIDE IN --
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND CHILD
WELFARE WERE IN SUPPORT OF ALL
THE ITEMS IN ISSUE.
ONE THANK YOU.
HOW YOU DOING AND YOU COME HERE
SIX IN -- I'M A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND I'M PART OF THAT --
TEACH BE PROGRAM.
AND WITH THE T. H. P. PROGRAM
IT'S ALLOWED ME TO GO TO SCHOOL
IN -- AND IT'S IT'S A GREAT
PROGRAM BECAUSE I'M NOT HOMELESS
OR ANYTHING.
SO I THINK IT'S GREAT AND I
THINK WE SHOULD KEEP ITS AREA.
THANK YOU.
I NEED A LOT FROM THE PLASTER
COUNTY TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLUS
PROGRAM AND I'M JUST
REPRESENTING SOME OF THE YOUTH
THAT WEREN'T ABLE TO COME TODAY
BECAUSE THEY ARE.
WORKING AND GOING TO SCHOOL.
AND CAN'T BE HERE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT WILL GO
AHEAD AND CONTINUE ON TO ISSUE
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AMONG
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ADVOCACY
PROPOSAL I WOULD LIKE TO CALL UP --
DETAILS IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
FOSTER YOUTH AT AN IMMEDIATE
FAMILY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THAT JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES OF
THE VIEW [inaudible]
AND YEAH AND EVERYBODY ELSE'S
CURRENTLY THERE THANK YOU.
YES SHARE WITH ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING THE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO.
TRAVELED FROM CHICO AND MERCED
AND ALL AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL OUT OF
ORDER.
IT MEANS A LOT TO THEM AND TO US
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AMY LEVEL IAN AT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AND
I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
HIS STATEWIDE COALITION.
OF OVER TWO WOULD ORGANIZATIONS
TO REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN THE STATE'S TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM.
KNOWN AS TEACH PEOPLE US.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
CREATED TEACH PEOPLE US IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE IN THE MOST RISK IT
RECENTLY COMPLETED FISCAL YEAR
IT PROVIDED SAFE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
210-009-0040 SIX FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND THEIR FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT CHILDREN.
WHEN CALIFORNIA EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE TO AGE TWENTY ONE IN?
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE
POPULATION SERVED BY TEACH
PEOPLE PLUS CHANGED CONSIDERABLY.
INSTEAD OF LARGELY SERVING
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE YEAR OLDS
THP PLUS NOW SERVES OLDER MORE
VULNERABLE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
THIS INCLUDES PRIMARILY
CUSTODIAL PARENTS AND YOUTH WITH
DISABILITIES.
TEACH PEOPLE ALSO SERVES AS A
VALUABLE SAFETY NET FOR A NOT
SMALL BUT LARGELY INVISIBLE
GROUP OF YOUNG PEOPLE THESE ARE
YOUNG PEOPLE AGED EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY ONE WHO DON'T QUALIFY FOR
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
THIS IS A GROUP THAT WE WE VERY
RARELY SPEAK OF AND UTILIZE
TEACH PEOPLE IT'S CONSIDERABLY.
THIS PROGRAM IS BEEN EVALUATED
EVERY YEAR SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SIX A CONSISTENTLY
FOUND TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
YOUTH NOTABLY IN AREAS OF
HOUSING STABILITY MONTHLY
EARNINGS AND EMPLOYMENT.
SO CLEARLY THIS IS A WELL
ESTABLISHED EFFECTIVE STATE
PROGRAM.
HOWEVER IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THIS PROGRAM IS AT RISK.
THE STATE BUDGET FOR TEACH
PEOPLE PLUS HAS REMAINED
UNCHANGED SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN DURING THE
SAME SENSE THAT SAME PERIOD OF
TIME THE COST OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
HAS INCREASED BY 50%.
SO NOT SURPRISINGLY AS THE
DEMAND FOR HOUSING HAS
SKYROCKETED SO HAS DEMAND FOR
THIS VITAL SAFETY NET PROGRAM.
WE DID A MOMENT IN TIME SNAPSHOT
IN A AND IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THERE WERE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN ELIGIBLE
YOUTH WAITING TO ENTER TEACH
PEOPLE PLUS.
LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES EACH HAD A WAITING LIST
OF OUR FIFTY YOUNG PEOPLE AGAIN
OVER HALF OF WHO ARE CUSTODIAL
PARENTS.
THESE ARE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WHO WERE IN CARE UNTIL AGE.
EIGHTEEN WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
ACHIEVE PERMANENCE AND NOW FIND
THEMSELVES YOU DON'T.
SEVERAL YEARS AFTER HOMELESS.
SO THE CURRENT BUDGET PROPOSAL
IS AN EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TEACH PEOPLE US.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE EXPANSION
OF THIS VITAL SAFETY NET PROGRAM
IT WOULD ALSO SLIGHTLY MODIFIED
THE ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM
REALLY IT'S CLOSING MORE OF A OF
A LOOPHOLE.
CURRENTLY TO BE IN THIS PROGRAM
YOU HAVE TO BE IN CARE AT AGE
EIGHTEEN IT WOULD SLIGHTLY
MODIFY THE PROGRAM SO THAT IF
YOU WERE IN CARE BETWEEN SIXTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN IF YOU LATER BECAME
HOMELESS YOU COULD.
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM THERE
ARE A LARGE NUMBER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO CHEAT PERMITS DURING
THAT TWO YEAR WINDOW.
HOWEVER THESE YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
LARGELY THE SAME EXPERIENCE OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO REMAINING CARE
TELL EIGHTEEN AND YET WE CUT OFF
ACCESS TO THIS VITAL PROGRAM.
AND WE ACTUALLY CREATE A
DISINCENTIVE FOR PERMANENCE.
SO THIS IS A VERY LONG STANDING
SUCCESSFUL STATE PROGRAM THAT IS
REALLY OFFERED A BETTER BRIGHTER
FUTURE FOR THOUSANDS OF FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE STRONGLY URGE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL AND
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
INTRODUCE J. T. WHO IS THE
CURRENT PARTICIPANTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON PHONE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S J. T. OF
TWENTY YEARS OF MY FRESHMAN YEAR.
SEXY COLLEGE ON A PARTICIPATING.
A DOUBLES TSC PLUS PROGRAM.
I'M HERE HERE TODAY REQUEST
SUPPORT FOR THE THE IN EIGHTEEN
FOR A BIT. EIGHT MILLION A
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN TWO
YEARS HE PLAYS.
I ENDED FOSTER AT THE AGE OF
FOUR REMAINED IN UNTIL A FEW
MONTHS BEFORE TURNING.
TWENTY ONE BEING IN FOSTER CARE
IS DIFFICULT WHO'S PRETTY STABLE
UNTIL THE AGE OF TWELVE WHEN I
MOVED FROM PLACEMENT A PLACEMENT
LIVING IN SOLANO COUNTY.
COUNTER CUSTER.
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY THESE MOVES
MADE A HARD FOR ME TO TRUST MANY
PEOPLE EXCEPT A LOT OF THINGS
WELL GONNA.
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY MY FOSTER
MOM WAS EVICTED FROM ROMAN --
QUOTE AND SHE TOLD ME THAT I
COULDN'T MOVE WITH HER I WAS
HOMELESS AND LIVING LIVING WITH
MY FRIENDS ON A COACH IS.
DURING THIS TIME OF I WAS
CALLING SHOULDERS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS FINALLY HAVE FOUND THE
PROGRAM.
ADOLFO.
SINCE ARRIVING AT A DOUBLE
THEY'VE HELPED ME.
PROACTIVELY.
MOVE ABOUT MOVING FORWARD WITH
MY LIFE AND NOW LIVING IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT AND CREATING A
POSITIVE FUTURE FOR MYSELF.
ALSO A DOVE LESS HELP ME GET A
JOB AS A TEACHER'S AIDE TO POUR
MY DREAM OF BEING AN ARTIST.
THEY'VE PROVIDED ME VOCATIONAL
GUIDANCE HELP WITH CERTAIN
CERTAIN THINGS IN OUR SUPPLIES
TRANSFERRED MY OUR DEFENSE WAS
Y. DISPLAYED MORE WORK AND SOLD
MY PAINTINGS.
CONNECTED ME WITH OTHER ARTISTS
AND MENTORS AND EMPOWER ME.
TO PURSUE MY PASSION MY THG PLUS
PROGRAM HAS HELPED ALSO HELP ME
ROLE IN THE SEXY.
WELL I'M STUDYING GRAPHIC
DESIGNING IN WORKING FOR MY
ASSOCIATES DEGREE.
ADULTS WILL HELP ME APPLY IN
COMPLETE MY FAST FOOD UNTIL -- A
MUCH FASTER MY FINANCIAL AID
OPTIONS IN CONNECT WITH OTHER
FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAMS EVEN PAID
FOR MY STUDENT FEES.
THEY'RE ALWAYS ENCOURAGING
SUPPORTIVE SUPPORTIVE AND HELPED
ME MAINTAIN MY PASS AND GOALS.
ALSO THEY'RE VERY PATIENT WHEN
THINGS GET HARD FOR ME IN THE
PAST I'VE HAD I'VE HAD STRUGGLED
BUT HAVING THEIR SUPPORT HAS
HELPED ME.
WELL BETTER THAN.
I'VE DONE BEFORE I HAVE ADHD
WHICH REQUIRED A LOT OF PATIENTS
THEY HAVE CONNECTING WITH GOOD
THERAPISTS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT.
THIS SUPPORT CAN BE DIFFICULT
AND ALSO ARE TO DEVELOP.
ESPECIALLY AS A FORMER FOSSIL
WHO HAS BEEN A SYSTEM FOR A LONG
TIME WITHOUT TEARS YOU PLUS I
PROBABLY HOMES.
AND I'D STILL BE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO
AND FOCUS ON HOME.
THEY'VE HELPED ME FOCUS ON WHAT
IT TAKES TO BE SUCCESS IN.
MORE OF FOSTER YOUTH IN.
CALIFORNIA NEED NEED THIS HELP
SO I STRONGLY AGREE THROUGH. TO
URGE THIS PROPOSAL.
IN THE STATE AS RUMORS HE BERMAN
LIKES A LOT TO TAKE IN BUT LIKE.
I REALLY THINK THAT LIKE THE
TEARS HE PLACES WITH IT'S A
REALLY IT'S A REALLY.
GOOD THING N. ANYTHING THAT'S
FOR ITS HELPFUL SO.
IN IS A LOT OF OTHER.
YOU'VE BETTER LIKE IN THE SAME
POSITION AS ME LIKE THEY MIGHT
NOT KNOW WHAT THEY WANT TO DO AT
SCHOOL AND STUFF BUT LIKE.
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS HELP LIKE A
HELP US GAIN AN IDEA -- SO.
ANY SUPPORT WOULD BE REALLY
GREAT SO I RECOMMENDED.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING YOUR TESTIMONY -- IT'S
ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE AFFECTED.
GIVE ALL THE THE THE THE REST OF
US TALKING ABOUT AN ISSUE.
BUT WHEN SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN IN
THE SYSTEM HAS EXPERIENCED IT
THE GOOD AND THE BAD CAN COME IN
AND TALK TO US.
MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE A
CONGRATULATIONS ON BEING AT SAID --
SEX CITY.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THE
BEGINNING RIGHT YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT IN YOUR YOUR
SON.
EVEN A SON WITH YOU.
HOW DID YOU SAY YOU HAVE A SON
NO NO?
EVER BRING A PIECE OF HIS
ARTWORK BUT WE WERE IT WAS
APPROPRIATE TO BRING IT UP
[inaudible]
WE'RE NOT.
I THOUGHT I HEARD THAT.
ALL RIGHT WELL WONDERFUL I I DO
WANT TO HEAR FROM DSS AND THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THE ESTIMATES
OF THE PROPOSAL DO UNDERSTAND
THE PROPOSAL YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL.
A JET GENERAL MARK THAT RIGHT SO --
SHE SHE WILL ALLUDED TO CHANGING
A LITTLE BIT THE ELIGIBILITY IN
A PROGRAM AS I'VE SAID A COUPLE
TIMES TODAY ALREADY THE CHILD
WELFARE WAS A REAL LINE PROGRAM
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE REALIGNED
PROGRAM FUNDING.
OUR AVAILABILITY OF DATA IS
SOMEWHAT LIMITED TO EVALUATE A
REQUEST.
IT'S NO SECRET IN CALIFORNIA THE
SUPPLY AND COST OF HOUSING IS A
MAJOR BARRIER FACED BY WHO --
MAYBE MORESO BY FOSTER YOUTH
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THAN ANY
OTHER POPULATION.
IN THE STATE A G. BEING AN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE GENERALLY
MEANS PURSUIT OF WORK OR
EDUCATION BOTH OF WHICH ARE
WORTH SUPPORTING -- SO I DON'T
REALLY HAVE A WAY TO TELL YOU
EIGHT MILLION IS THE RIGHT
NUMBER FIVE MILLIONS OF RIGHT
NUMBER TEN MILLION SO RIGHT
NUMBER I DON'T THINK IT WE CAN
OFFER.
IN ON THAT BUT I THINK YOU YOU
AS YOU AS YOU YOURSELF JUST SAID
IT WE TALKED EARLIER YOU KNOW
THE USE VOICE TALKING ABOUT
THEIR LIFE YOU DON'T COMPETE
WITH THAT STORY AND SO WE
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF THE
PROGRAM.
AND ITS IMPORTANCE TO THE YOUTH
PARTICIPATING IN IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE SPACE BAR FINANCE OF WHILE
YOU WERE JUGGLING YOUR MANY HATS
EARLIER -- JUST MADE A BLANKET
STATEMENT FOR FINANCE AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANY POSITION ON ANY
OF THE AFRICAN PROPOSALS AT THIS
TIME.
DOES THE NUMBER OF HERE CORRECT
TO YOU THOUGH.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
WITHOUT GIVING IT AN OPINION A
WAS TO WHETHER OR NOT IT'S GOOD
FOR OR NOT BUT TO PART OF THAT
WOULD BE WHY WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON IT -- THE ONLY THING
I CAN REITERATING AGAIN IS THE
SAME THING THAT THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR THANK YOU THAT THAT --
THE THE PROGRAM THAT IS
REQUESTING FUNDING FOR THIS IT
WAS REALIGNED AS A PART OFTHE
TWO THOUSAND AND REALIGNMENT SO --
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS AND THAT
BEING -- PRIORITY ANY GENERAL
FUND -- ERR ANY WHETHER IT'S A
BUDGET PROPOSAL OR LEGISLATION
THERE ON THAT'S A GENERAL FUND --
RESOURCES WOULD BE NECESSARY.
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS SOME
PROPOSED LEGISLATION -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM WHO IS.
THE BUDGET CHAIR -- DOES HAVE A
BILL IN THIS IN THIS AREA.
WONDERFUL COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ON ISSUE.
THREE ALL RIGHT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT LIBERTY SONGES IS TAKING
KATHY'S PLACE.
AND YOUR CAR A CARSON.
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
MISTER CURRY HERE [inaudible]
YES OKAY.
ISSUE THREE PROMOTING HOUSING
STABILITY FOR TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH ADVOCACY PROPOSAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS LIBBY SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF A C. R. U. CALIFORNIA ALSO
PRETENDING TO BE KATHY SUDDENLY
MCDONALD TODAY SAME CURLS
DIFFERENT COLOR -- SO AB TWELVE
IS ONE OF OUR PROUDEST
ACHIEVEMENTS THE LEGISLATURE'S --
OUR SOCIAL WORKERS -- COUNTY
PARTNERS AND ALL OF CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES PARTNERS AT A
SHINING MOMENT RATE OF OF
PROGRAM THAT REALLY REALLY WORKS
AND WE HAVE.
REALLY VERIFIABLE OUTCOME
MARKERS THAT WE CAN POINT TO WE
KNOW THAT AB TWELVE YOUTH --
PARTICIPANTS SEE BETTER
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES BETTER --
WORK OUTCOMES AND BETTER HEALTH
OUTCOMES OVERALL -- WHAT WE HAVE
ALSO NOTICED THAT TEN YEARS AND
TO THE PROGRAM IS THAT THERE ARE
SOME UNANTICIPATED THINGS THAT
LEAD US TO BE HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING?
ON WE DIDN'T REALIZE HOW GREAT
OF A TAKE OPERATE THERE WAS
GOING TO BE -- IN THIS PROGRAM
AND WHAT A NEED THAT WAS FOR
THIS PROGRAM FOR YOUTH.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE NOR DID
WE UNDERSTAND REALLY THE
INTRICACIES INVOLVED IN EACH
CASE -- THE WORKLOAD INVOLVED IN
EACH CASE AND THE NEEDS OF THESE
YOUTH MANY OF WHOM HAVE BEEN IN
CARE THEIR WHOLE LIVES -- HAVE
GONE FROM PLACEMENT TO PLACEMENT
AND SO THE VERY -- BASIC THINGS
THAT I THINK MANY OF US WHO ARE
PARENTS AND ARE TRANSITIONING
THEIR KIDS TO COLLEGE AGE -- ARE
ABLE TO HELP OUR KIDS WITH.
THESE KIDS NEED EXTRA CARE EXTRA
TIME -- EXTRA RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE STABLE AND
SITUATED -- SO WE ARE ASKING FOR
A FEW THINGS THE FIRST OF WHICH
IS WERE ASKING FOR THIRTY TWO
POINT NINE MILLION ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS. FOR CASELOAD WE ARE
HAVING -- AS WE MENTIONED A HUGE
TAKE UP RATE FOR THIS PROGRAM
AND EACH CASE IS REALLY REALLY
LABOR INTENSIVE SO THE ABILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE MORE
SOCIAL WORKERS.
I'M ABLE TO SPEND MORE TIME ON
ALL OF THESE CASES IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
AND THEN WE'RE ASKING FOR SOME
HOUSING TRANSITION DOLLARS WERE
ASKING FOR HOUSING NAVIGATORS ON
THOSE BUT WE YOU KNOW THERE'S
THIS HOUSING CRUNCH WE'RE ALL
AWARE OF AND REALLY REALLY HARD
WITH LIMITED RESOURCES.
AND NOT A LOT OF RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE TO BE ABLE TO
FIND AN APARTMENT AND THE
PLACEMENT AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR FUNDING FOR THAT WERE ALSO
LOOKING FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THINGS LIKE FIRST AND LAST
MONTH'S RENT.
AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS -- TO HELP
TRANSITION SO -- I WANTED TO FOR
THE REST OF MY TIME TO MR CARSON
WHO HAS SOME FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE WITH BEING AN A. B.
TWELVE TH THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HOW YOU DOING [inaudible]
THE GAP [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS COREY
CARSON AND TODAY I WANT TO TELL
YOU ABOUT SOME OF MY EXPERIENCES
IN CHALLENGES I FACED ON A ROAD
TO INDEPENDENCE IN ADULTHOOD.
BEFORE I TURNED EIGHTEEN I
DECIDE TO GOING TO THE EXTENT OF
FOSTER CARE SO I CAN GET THE
SUPPORT AND I NEEDED TO REACH MY
FULL POTENTIAL.
I'VE BEEN A TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
THE FIRST PLACE FOR YOU FOR
THREE YEARS NOW THE FIRST WITH
YOU BY MY OWN APARTMENT THE
ROOMMATE WHO'S ALSO IN PROGRAM
AND HAVE A SUPPORT TEAM.
WHICH INVOLVES MY YOUTH ADVOCATE
IN MY EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
SPECIALISTS.
GROWN UP ON NEW THERE WE WERE
AND ALWAYS WILL BE UPS AND DOWNS
AND FOR ME I'VE ENCOUNTERED SOME
CHALLENGES DURING MY TIME IN
PROGRAM.
THERE'S A TIME IN MY LIFE AND I
HAD GOT INVOLVED WITH THE WRONG
PEOPLE WHO WEREN'T SUCH A GOOD
INFLUENCE ON MY LIFE AND WE'RE
HELPING ME GROW.
I WAS LIVING IN OAKLEY IN FIRST
PLACE WITH YOU AND IT'S HOT AT
TIMES THE NEGATIVE SITUATIONS I
WAS INVOLVED WE GOT TO THE POINT
WHERE THE COPS HAD TO BE
INVOLVED.
AND I WAS EVEN AT RISK OF
GETTING KICKED OUT OF PROGRAM TO
BE AN OTTOMAN ON MY YOUTH
ADVOCATE DIDN'T GIVE UP ON SHE
PUSHED HARD FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO
STAND PROGRAM EVEN THERE HAVE
BEEN INCIDENTS WITH THE POLICE.
NOT ONLY DID SHE FIVE FOR ME SHE
ALSO WORK WITH ME HELP IDENTIFY
ROOT OF THE PROBLEM.
I MOVED TO AN APARTMENT ANY AXE
TO A FIRST PLACE FOR YOU.
AND I WAS WORKING REALLY HARD TO
GET MY LIFE ON A GOOD TRACK BUT
THAT WASN'T THE END OF MY
TROUBLES.
SOME OF THE GUYS I KNEW FROM
OAKLAND HAVE FOUND ME IN MY JOB
I FOUND OUT WHERE I LIVE IT WAS
THE DANGERS INCIDENT AND COULD
HAVE GONE REALLY BADLY.
I WASN'T SAFE IN IT WASN'T SAFE
FROM MY ROOMMATE BECAUSE THE
GUYS TO SHOW UP AT MY PLACE AT
ANY TIME MY WIFE A MY E. WANTED
TO MOVE ME TO ANOTHER PLACE TO
CONQUER FOR SAFETY.
BUT IT COULD BE READY RIGHT AWAY
THERE IS NO SHIRT SHORT TERM
PLACE TO GO BEING THAT I WAS AT
THE AGE OF UNDER.
TWENTY ONE THEY COULDN'T PUT A
MINOR IN A MOTEL ROOM SO I HAD
TO CALL AROUND TO FIND A FRIEND
WHO HAD A COUCH I COULD CRASH ON
LOCALLY I FOUND SOMEONE.
IS BUDGET REQUEST IS IMPORTANT
FOR YOUNG ADULTS UNDER TWENTY
ONE WHO NEEDS TEMPORARY SUPPORT
AND STABILITY.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE SYSTEM
IS DESIGNED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE BUMPS ALONG THE WAY DON'T
BRING EVERYTHING AROUND IS
CRASHING DOWN AS WELL.
HIS BUDGET REQUEST WILL HELP
BECAUSE IT WILL GIVE US MORE
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX TO HELP
SOLVE PROBLEMS AND GET ON A PATH
TO PROGRESS.
EVEN WHEN HARD TIMES COME UP I
THINK FOR HIM TODAY ACTION WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FOR SHARING THAT IS
AS I SAID EARLIER IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AS WE DO OUR
EVALUATIONS.
I WOULD LIKE AGAIN THE REACTION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AND DEAL
WITH.
JUSTIN GREATEST BERMAN FINANCE
WHO -- THE TICKET SO GO FOR ALL
THE AT PROPOSALS ON BEING THAT
THEY'RE OUTSIDE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL WE ON
THE POSITION ON THEM AND WE
HAVEN'T DONE A AND AN ESTIMATES
ON THE NEED. TO REALLY CAN'T
COMMENT ON WHETHER OR NOT ANY OF
THE PROPOSED DOLLAR AMOUNTS ARE
ACCURATE OR NOT [inaudible]
HELLO.
WELL I MEAN COMPARING EARLIER
REMARKS AND HE PUT A VERY HUMAN
FACE ON EXACTLY THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE AND AT THE
SAME TIME I WOULDN'T BE DOING MY
JOB IF I DIDN'T TELL YOU THIS
WAS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A REAL
LINE PROGRAMS THAT HAD.
RISKS AND ISSUES AND WE KNEW
THAT AT THE TIME WE REALIZED IT --
AND MOVED THERE'S A TRADE OFF
BETWEEN FINANCIAL DECISIONS AND
HUMAN DECISIONS ON THAT
SOMETHING WE WOULD HAVE TO
NEGOTIATE TOGETHER.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU BOTH FOR FOR
JOINING US.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR ELIMINATING
BARRIERS TO ENTER AND REENTER
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE ADVOCACY.
YES.
MR GIVES.
YOU CAN PROGRAM.
WHERE IT'S A SEVERE ON?
AN ERRAND PHILOSOPHY OF SOMEBODY
[inaudible]
ANYWAY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE MISTER
GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
SPEAK ABOUT ELIMINATING BARRIERS
TO ENSURE THAT YOU.
IN NEED OF TRANSITIONAL SERVICES
ARE ABLE TO ENTER OR RE ENTER
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE BENEFITS
ARE CRITICAL AS A YOUTH
TRANSITION INTO ADULTHOOD.
THESE YOU FACE GREAT CHALLENGES
IN COMPLETING THEIR EDUCATION.
FINDING A STABLE EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING.
HOWEVER A NUMBER OF THE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE COURTS
THAT HAVE PREVENTED A VERY
NARROW.
GROUP OF FOSTER YOUTH FROM
RECEIVING BENEFITS THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE FOR
CURRENTLY FOSTER YOU. SIX TO
ACCESS EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
SERVICES EIGHT OUT NO ONE UNDER
SCORE AIDS OUT.
IF THEY'RE TURNED EIGHTEEN
BEFORE THEIR CASES ARE FULLY
DECIDED.
AND YOU THE ALSO PREVENTED FROM
ACCESSING INSTEAD OF FOSTER CARE
WITH THE GUARDIAN OR THE
ADOPTIVE PARENTS CONTINUES.
ARE TO RECEIVE BONDS EVEN THOUGH
THAT THE FAMILIES NO LONGER --
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT THE YOU THIS
BUDGET REQUEST SIX TO CLOSE THE
GAP FOR VULNERABLE TRANSITIONING
H. FOSTER YOU IN THESE VERY
NARROW NARROW NARROW SITUATIONS
BY ENSURING THAT WE DO ALL THE
WE CAN'T TO EQUIP.
ARE YOU WITH THE TOOLS TO
SUCCEED.
OF THE ADVOCATES AND I HAVE --
CONTINUE TO MEET WITH A D. S. S.
AND ALSO D. F. O. TO DETERMINE
AT ESTIMATE.
CASELOAD.
WE RECEIVED A REPORT FROM LA --
X. -- ECSTATIC SEEING --
ESTIMATING COSTS HOWEVER WE HAVE
YET TO REACH CONSENSUS -- ON
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM -- IT IS
OUR HOPE AND OUR DESIRE THEY D.
S. S. AND D. O. ELF CAN --
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US TO
RESOLVE THE DIFFERENCES ON CASE
LOAD ESTIMATES SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD AND CLOSE THE GAP.
OF FOR THESE VERY VULNERABLE BUT
NARROW YOUTH HERE IN OUR STATE.
I'M HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES AS A
YOUNG PERSON -- WE'RE HAPPY THAT
WILL HAVE HERSELF INTRODUCED
HERSELF.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MORE
IT'S A STUDIO I AM A NON MINOR
DEPENDENT FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL WHICH
WOULD REMOVE A BARRIER TO EXTEND
FOSTER CARE FOR YOUTH WHO.
ENTER CARE OR RETURNED TO KERR
AT AGE.
SEVENTEEN I KNOW FROM PROPOSED.
I KNOW FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
HOW IMPORTANT THE SERVICES AND
OPPORTUNITIES OF EXTENT FOSTER
CARE CAN BE AND HOW HARD IT IS.
TO ACCESS AFTER A CERTAIN AGE I
WAS RAISED BY MY GRANDPARENTS
STARTING ONE WHEN I WAS AN
INFANT MY FATHER'S DISABLED
THERE WAS NEVER ABLE TO CARE FOR
HIMSELF OR ME.
MY MOTHER COULD NOT CARE FOR ME
EITHER BECAUSE SHE STRUGGLED
WITH SERIOUS DRUG ADDICTION.
WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN BOTH OF MY
GRANDPARENTS DIED WITHIN A FEW
MONTHS OF EACH OTHER?
IT WASN'T LONG BEFORE I HAD NO
PLACE TO GO.
I STARTED COUCH SURFING A
REACHING OUT TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE PROVIDERS I WAS
SERIOUSLY DEPRESSED AFTER MY
GRANDPARENTS DIED IT WASN'T SURE
WHERE TO TURN.
BY THE TIME IS CFS SOCIAL WORKER
MET WITH ME AND ACTUALLY EXPLAIN
FOSTER CARE AND THE SERVICES
AVAILABLE I WAS ABOUT SEVENTEEN
AND A HALF.
THE SOCIAL WORKER TOLD ME THAT
BECAUSE I WAS SO CLOSE TO
EIGHTEEN THERE WASN'T ANYTHING
CFS WOULD DO FOR ME.
SHE TOLD ME THAT THEY WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO COMPLETE THINGS IN
COR IN TIME TO PROVIDE ME WITH
ANY LONG TERM HELP IN IT.
AND THAT IT DID NOT MAKE ANY
SENSE FOR TO ENTER FOSTER CARE
FOR JUST A SHORT TIME.
WITHOUT OTHER OPTIONS I KEPT
COUCHSURFING AND WORKING WITH
OTHER OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT YOU SENT SHELTERS AND TO
COME UP WITH THE PLAN. ONE OF
THE SHELTER WORKERS REFERRED ME
TO A LAWYER WHO WAS FINALLY ABLE
TO ASSIST ME WITH ACCESSING
FOSTER CARE SERVICES.
MY LAWYER COULD NOT GET A CFS
CASE THE RECORD AND TIME EITHER
SHE WAS FOUND SHE FOUND IT ALL
TO SEE CASE AND HAD A CONVERTED
TO APPEND TITIAN NOT ALLOWED THE
COURT TO PLACE ME IN FOSTER CARE.
THE FACT IS I GOT LUCKY AT THE
LAST MINUTE.
WORKING WITH MY PROBATION
OFFICER WHO HAS BEEN REALLY
SUPPORTIVE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING WAS FIRST PLACE FOR YOU.
I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO STAY IN
THEIR PAEAN KEEP WORKING THROUGH
THE LOSS OF MY GRANDPARENTS A
FEELING AND FEELINGS ABOUT MY
PARENTS.
I AM CLOSE TO FINISHING HIGH
SCHOOL AND I HAVE A JOB IN
TRYING TO SAVE SOME MONEY.
I AM WORKING WITH MY PROVIDERS
TO COMPLETE COLLEGE APPLICATIONS
AND BELIEVE COLLEGE IS A REAL
POSSIBILITY.
PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
ABOUT EXTENDING FOSTER CARE FOR
ME IS I WAS ABLE TO FIND PEOPLE
WHO CARE ABOUT ME.
AND THIS HAS MADE ME ABLE TO
CARE ABOUT MYSELF AGAIN WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT I CURRENTLY HAVE I
BELIEVE THAT I WOULD BE LIVING
IN A CAR OR WORSE.
I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CONTINUE SCHOOL AND I KNOW I
WOULD HAVE LOST ALL MOTIVATION
TO WORK.
I AM SURE THAT COLLEGE WOULD NOT
EVEN BE ON MY MIND.
I AM ASKING THAT YOU SUPPORT
THIS BILL SO THAT CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES ARE ABLE TO HELP YOUNG
PEOPLE LIKE ME SO THE OTHER
YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T LOSE
IMPORTANT AND LYFT.
LIFE CHANGING SUPPORT JUST
BECAUSE THE COURT CASE TAKES TOO
LONG TO COMPLETE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME THEIR INFLUX YES AND I'M
HERE FROM BAY AREA LEGAL AID
LARGELY TO SUPPORT THIS IDEA
WHO'S BEEN BRAVE ENOUGH TO COME
IN AND TESTIFY AND I'LL JUST
NOTE THAT WE DO BELIEVE THIS IS
A NARROW POPULATION OF YOUNG
PEOPLE.
I'M TO OF THE COMPONENTS WE
THINK ARE PRIMARILY TECHNICAL
FIXES FOR EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
THE PORTION THAT WOULD ALLOW
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO COME IN AT AGE.
SEVENTEEN AND DO NOT COMPLETE
THEIR CASES IN TIME.
TO REMAIN AN EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
COURT NOT COMPLETING THE
JURISDICTIONAL OR DISPOSITIONAL
HEARINGS IN TIME.
SHOULD BE RELATIVELY SMALL WE'VE
ALWAYS MAINTAINED IT IS
RELATIVELY SMALL BUT THIS IS OUR
THIRD YEAR ATTEMPTING TO REACH
CONSENSUS ON THOSE NUMBER SO
WE'RE HOPING THIS YEAR THAT.
WE CAN FINALLY COME TO A A TRUE
COST ESTIMATE AND GET SOME SOME
HARD NUMBERS SINCE WE SHOULD BE
ABLE [inaudible]
TO EVALUATE THAT.
THANK YOU BEFORE I ASK THE
QUESTIONS I WOULD TELL YOU THAT
I I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT YOU'RE FINISHING
HIGH SCHOOL.
NOW COLLEGES NEXT.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
THEY ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
STATISTICS FOR FOSTER YOU.
AND HOW FEW OF FOSTER YOU
ACTUALLY GET A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
BECAUSE OF THAT STATISTIC THERE
ARE LOTS OF UNIVERSITIES THAT
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU.
THEY'D LOVE TO HAVE YOU BECAUSE
EVERYBODY WANTS TO PROVE THAT
THEY ARE THE UNIVERSITY THAT HAS
THE BETTER STATISTICS.
WHAT DO ONE STUDY?
I WANT TO WORK WITH ANIMALS I'M
NOT REALLY SURE PROBABLY IN --
MARINE BIOLOGIST OR SOMETHING.
VERY GOOD I I'M SURE THAT
THEY'LL FIND THE RIGHT
UNIVERSITY FOR YOU COULD BE SAN
DIEGO ONE OF THE OTHER
UNIVERSITIES ALONG THE COAST
[inaudible]
BUT LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES WOULD
BE AVAILABLE TO YOU.
AND AS SOON AS YOU GET TO A
COUNSELOR TO BE SURE YOU TELL
THEM YOU WANT TO KNOW.
EVERYTHING THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
YOU.
THERE'S A LOT THAT'S AVAILABLE
AND THEY'VE LOTS OF PROGRAMS
WITH THE STARTED A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LIKE THIS SPEAKER JUST
BEFORE YOU OR YOU GO STRAIGHT TO
A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE.
LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES.
INSIST THAT THEY TELL YOU ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT'S AVAILABLE.
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUE ABOUT TO
THE THIS CASE THE CASE LOAD
NUMBER.
WHAT'S THE EARLIEST THOSE
NUMBERS CAN BE PROVIDED.
FEATURING A WHAT THE DEPARTMENT --
I I THINK AS HAS BEEN POINTED
OUT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
I I THOUGHT IT WAS TWO YEARS NOT
THREE UNDER DISCUSSION -- I
THINK THERE'S BEEN SOME BACK AND
FORTH THERE I'M NOT PERSONALLY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT SO I I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE STATUS OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE.
THE STAFF IS YEAH GREG ROSE THE
DEPARTMENT WE'VE BEEN WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON STAFF AND OTHER
ADVOCATES -- WE GET THAT THE
NUMBERS THAT THE NUMBERS SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE RELATIVELY SOON IT
WE BUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR SOME
ACTUAL LANGUAGE TOOK TOOK TAKE A
LOOK AT SO THAT WE CAN -- SEE IN
FACT IF THE IF THE THAT THAT
THAT THE NARROWNESS THAT THAT
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS
ARTICULATED THERE AS WELL -- ARE
ARE ARE.
CLEARLY WE AREN'T INTERESTED WE
ARE WE ARE INTERESTED IN NOT
HAVING YOUNG PEOPLE FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS BECAUSE OF SOME KIND
OF YOU KNOW DELAY IN COURT OR
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS -- THE THE
NUMBER THAT WE HAVE BEEN GIVEN
AND BECAUSE WE DON'T A WE HAVE A
HARD TIME ACTUALLY VERIFYING
THEM -- ARE IN FACT VERY SMALL
SO -- I WE WE WERE WAITING ON
SOME LANGUAGE AND WE ARE GOING
TO FINISH CRUNCH IN SOME NUMBERS
AND AND AND PRIVATE PROVIDING
THAT BACK TO THE TO THE THE
ADVOCATES. TO THE THE EARLIEST
WE CAN GET THE UPDATED CASELOAD
NUMBERS.
RETHINKING A MONTH.
LESS -- LESS LESS THAN LESS THAN
A MONTH I MEAN WE'RE BASED ON
THAT THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT THEY'VE ASKED FOR WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO ONCE WE HAVE THE THE
THE THE THAT THAT LANGUAGE BE
ABLE TO TO VERIFY IT TO TO COME
UP WITH SOME.
NUMBER -- AND THEN IT HAS TO BE
PART OF THE OVERALL BUDGET
PROCESS.
TO RECONCILE EVERYTHING BUT
CERTAINLY WE CAN DO THAT.
IT REALLY APPEARS LIKE A
BUREAUCRATIC ISSUE YES -- I I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE ARE
DAHLE SUPPORTING THIS.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT ONCE WE
HAVE THE NUMBERS AND PERHAPS
WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE.
IS THERE ANY REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT THE NUMBER.
IS LARGER THAN THE CASE THAT THE
CASELOAD THAT THE LA -- HAS
ESTIMATED.
I THINK THAT WE I DON'T I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY INFORMATION
THAT WOULD BE DIFFERENT THAN THE
LA -- TESTAMENT [inaudible]
THE END.
FINALLY I THINK THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IS
CONSIDERING.
THAT THIS IS A RELATIVELY SMALL
GROUP WAS THE SMALL NUMBER -- IN
DESPERATE CIRCUMSTANCES I THINK
THAT THAT IS CLEAR AND ALSO FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIBSON'S --
TESTIMONY OF THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN.
THAT IS CLEAR -- ARE THERE ANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT.
DO NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AS A
RESULT OF AS A RESULT OF THIS.
AGAIN I THINK IT WILL BE ONLY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE -- THAT I
COULD IMAGINE IS -- IS IF THERE
ARE SOME IF THE THE L<c.cyan>G THE</c>
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD -- THAT IS
BEING CLARIFIED SOMEHOW HAS A
HAS HAS AN OPENING IN IT THAT
WHERE THAT IS IS IN IS DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT HAS BEEN DESCRIBED
MADE BUT I'M WAITING TO ACTUALLY
SEE THE THE SPECIFIC THE THE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE OTHERWISE.
ANY ENDED THE ONLY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES COULD BE DOES DOES
THAT IS THERE ANY KIND OF
PERVERSE INCENTIVE FOR FAMILIES
TO NOT DO THE RIGHT THING AND
HAVE THEIR YOUNG PEOPLE AND UP --
IT IN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
THERE'S BEEN -- THERE HAVE BEEN
OTHER STATES WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE
THAT -- NOT IN THIS SPECIFIC
INCH IS INSTANCE BUT THAT WOULD
BE THE ONLY THING I WOULD SAY WE
HAVE TO GUARD WE WOULD WANT TO
GUARD AGAINST.
I HAVE NO INDICATION AT THIS
POINT THAT THERE WILL BE.
ON UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES BUT
AGAIN AND TELL WE ARE CAN
ACTUALLY SEE THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE I THINK WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO BE AS DEFINITIVE THAT
YOU'D LIKE US TO BE AT THE
MOMENT.
AND SO THAT SO THAT I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE NOT SEEN THE
LANGUAGE I HAVEN'T SEEN THE
LANGUAGE FOR THAT THERE'S A
THERE'S A THERE'S A UP.
A BILL AND THAT BUDGET ASKED
TOGETHER AND WE HAVE SEEN -- WE
WE HAVE WE HAVE AYE AYE WE HAVE
BEEN TOLD THAT THERE IS UPDATED
LANGUAGE TO BE IT'S COMING
[inaudible]
THE GIPSON.
CAN WE GET THAT LANGUAGE TO THEM
IMMEDIATELY YES I'M.
LOOKING FOR MONTHS WE'VE WE'VE
ACTUALLY WE'VE WORKED ON THAT
LANGUAGE AND WE MET WITH A
VARIETY OF ADVOCATES VERY
RECENTLY WE'VE BEEN MEETING WITH
THEM FOR THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS
AND WE DID.
AND I ACTUALLY THANK.
MR ROSE HE HAD HE IS VERY
HELPFUL IN AND GETTING BACK TO
US WITH CONCERNS AND WE'VE TRIED
TO ADDRESS I THINK WHAT.
WE WERE LOOKING AT OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS SOME HOPEFUL
THAT THAT'S DONE THAT LANGUAGE
IS READY AND SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
FOR YOU TODAY.
BUT OKAY IT WILL THERE IT IS. TO
THE LANGUAGE WILL BE READY TODAY
AND THEN WITHIN A WEEK OR TWO
WE'LL GET THE THE THE UPDATED
NUMBERS.
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
MADAM CHAIR.
YES MY ROOM BY MAY I I THINK.
THIS IS A GREAT OPTION AND OF
THE TESTIMONY THAT WAS GIVEN --
IN AND PRIOR IT REALLY GOES TO A
PASSION -- THAT WE'VE SPOKEN
ABOUT ALSO WITH THE HOMELESS
YOUTH IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BEING MORE PROACTIVE
IN MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
RESOURCES THAT ARE THERE FOR
THEM.
SO IN LOOKING AT THAT AND
GETTING THAT FINAL LANGUAGE --
TO YOU WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT --
KEEP IN MIND THAT THIS IS A
PROACTIVE MEASURE -- TO KEEP A
BALANCE ON FINANCIAL RESOURCES
ARE BEING USED IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE OF WERE ABLE TO BE
PROACTIVE GET THOSE RESOURCES
NOW THAT WE HAVE THAT GREATER
IMPACT ON THE HOMELESS YOUTH
POPULATION THAT WERE SEEN.
IN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GEN SEEN THOSE THINGS MOVE
FORWARD.
WE WE WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS MOVING FORWARD BUT WHEN YOU
SAID LOOK AT IT PLEASE KEEP IN
MIND THAT ASPECT OF IT IN THE
SAVINGS THAT WILL HAPPEN DOWN
THE ROAD.
BECAUSE THE MONEY WE'RE SPENDING
NOW THANK YOU.
AND AS HAS BEEN NOTED THESE ARE
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF YEAR OLDS.
INCOMPLETE PERIL.
THE THE THE WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING I MR GIPSON YOU'VE
ALWAYS BEEN A CHAMPION FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
I THANK YOU FOR THAT TO YOU YOU
HAVE BEEN.
YOUR HEART HAS ALWAYS BEEN THERE
AND YOU PUSH THE REST OF US AND
YOU MAKE US ALL UNDERSTAND WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE SO THAT WERE
ALWAYS ON BOARD WITH YOU I THANK
YOU FOR FOR ALL THAT ADVOCACY.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- LA -- OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S GO TO ISSUE.
FIVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
YOU'RE STAYING RIGHT WITH US
SOUNDS THEIR ANNA JOHNSON.
AND JUSTIN VERY THIS IF WE CAN
BRING YOU BACK.
THANK YOU AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M HERE -- BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT REDUCING
THE FREQUENCY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVOLVEMENT AND DELINQUENCY
PETITION FOR FOSTER CHILDREN IN
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
THIS IS -- THIS ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF NINE MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS WE
WANT PROVIDE TRAUMA INFORMED
TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
INTERACTION.
WITH BARBEL YOU.
AND EXPAND IT DIVERSION PROGRAMS
AND DEVELOPMENT TO A PRIEST --
APPROPRIATIONS APPROPRIATE
SERVICES TO YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE.
THE GOAL.
OF THIS PROPOSAL IS TO FIND A
COMMUNITY BASED INFRASTRUCTURE
UP TO DIVERT FOSTER YOU AWAY
FROM THE JUVENILE SYSTEM IN WAYS
THAT IS BOTH SOCIALLY AND
FISCALLY.
RESPONSIBLE NOT ONLY DO WE SAVE
MONEY BY PREVENTING -- THESE
YOUTH FROM CROSSING OVER INTO
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM --
WE REVITALIZED COMMUNITIES BY
HELPING THEM BECOME PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS.
WHO ARE YOU -- EMOTIONALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY STABLE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING A TESTIMONY
FOR THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS MADE
ON A JOHNSON UP FROM THE
NATIONAL CENTER OF YOUTH AND LAW.
WHO?
THAT ORGANIZATIONS ALSO A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
WONDERFUL JOHNSON THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING AT CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON SENIOR
POLICY ASSOCIATE AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND I AM
HERE TO SPEAK -- IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ONE TIME BUDGET ALLOCATION
OF NINE MILLION TO AUGMENT THE
FOSTERING SUCCESS FUND.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN FACILITIES
LOCATED IN NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES MADE EXCESSIVE CALLS TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE.
THESE FACILITIES AVERAGE CALLS
EVERY SINGLE DAY SOME AVERAGE
FOUR TIMES A DAY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOME SEVEN TIMES A
CALLING
THEIR CARE -- YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE IN THESE FACILITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY CRIMINALIZE
FOR NORMAL CHILDHOOD BEHAVIOURS
BEHAVIORS THAT ARE RELATED TO
TRAUMA OR BEHAVIORS THAT ARE
GENDER NON CONFORMING.
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
LGBT Q. YOUTH AND YOUTH WITH
DISABILITIES DISPROPORTIONATE
NIGHTLY IMPACTING USE OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY NATIVE YOUTH.
MOST PARENTS WOULD NOT CALL THE
COPS ON THEIR OWN CHILDREN ABOUT
A THROWN GLASS OF WATER A POKE
OF A SIBLING WITH A CANDY CANE
ON A HOLIDAY OR RUNNING IN THE
HOUSE.
BUT FOR USE IN THESE FACILITIES
SPECIFICALLY THE THIS IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND THIS IS NOT JUST A
SIMPLE ENCOUNTER WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS MANY OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HEARD IN THE
SPECIAL YOU'RE HEARING YESTERDAY
ON AB THREE NINETY TWO THIS IS A
COMPLEX.
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY'RE
DEALING WITH AND IT'S A FEARFUL
RELATIONSHIP THAT THAT THAT
THERE MAY BE -- THIS IS ACTUALLY
THE BEGINNING OF FOSTER CARE TO
PRISON PIPELINE.
AS AS THE MEMBER MENTIONED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON MENTIONED
WHAT THIS FUND WILL DO YOU -- SO
I WILL SKIP OVER THOSE POINTS
THERE BUT CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY
ALREADY BEGUN TO MOVE TOWARDS
THIS HEALTH BASED APPROACH TO
DEALING WITH YOUTH AND CONFLICT
OF THE WITH THE LAW.
INCLUDING INVESTING IN DIVERSION
PROGRAMS AND TRAUMA INFORMED
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES FOR
YOUTH.
IN -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
MADE AT THE FIRST FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET ALLOCATION TO
ESTABLISH THE FUND INSISTS BEGIN
TO DEFER EAT DIVERT YOUTH IN
STATE CARE AWAY FROM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THESE
INITIAL FUNDS IS WELL ON ITS WAY
WITH CDS WITH THE APARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES RELEASING THE
REQUEST FOR INFORMATION.
AND TO DISTRIBUTE THOSE FUNDS
CONDUCTED THROUGH A WEAPON ARE
WHERE THERE WERE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY PARTICIPANTS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT TURNED OUT
FOR THAT WEAPON ARE AND ARE
INTERESTED IN DELIVERING THE
SERVICES IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT INITIAL
ALLOCATION WILL ONLY COVER ABOUT
THREE TO FOUR COUNTIES OF THOSE
NINETEEN WAS STATED NEED -- IF
THE COUNTIES REPRESENTED ON THIS
COMMITTEE ALONE WOULD EXCEED THE
AMOUNT COVERED BY LAST YEAR'S
ONE TIME AUGMENTATION ARE
ALLOCATION.
AND ARE FURTHER MORE THEY'RE
COMPARING THE TWENTY SIXTEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT CALLS TO THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE THERE IS A 10% INCREASE
IN THE TOTAL NUMBER OF CALLS TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASING
TREND SO WE KNOW THAT THIS ONE
TIME ALLOCATION IS -- WOULD BE
VERY WELCOME IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
BUT CHILDREN IN THE SYSTEM AS
YOU KNOW HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS
ABUSE NEGLECT AND TRAUMA.
AND THOSE IN GROUP CARE ARE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO
CROSSING OVER AND RELYING ON
POLICE TO DEAL WITH YOUTHFUL
BEHAVIOR PUSHES CHILDREN INTO
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY NEED.
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE IN THEIR
HOME COMMUNITY -- YOU
DEVELOPMENT A DIVERSION PROGRAM
IMPROVES YES BEHAVIOR AND
OUTCOMES IMPROVES PUBLIC SAFETY
AND IS A SMARTER INVESTMENT --
AND THIS I'M JUST GOING TO KIND
OF BE QUICK HERE WITH A SKIP
OVER SOME STUFF SINCE I KNOW YOU
ALL KNOW THAT SO -- BY REDUCING
OUR OVERLOOKED AND RELIANCE ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PRIORITIZING
COMMUNITY BASED TIME IN FORCE
FROM INFORMED CARE CALIFORNIA
WILL IMPROVE LIFE OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
BETTER UTILIZE SCARCE LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES AND
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND I URGE YOUR IPHONE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY FEEDBACK FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
A PICTURE RECORD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT I REALLY DON'T HAVE
MUCH TO ADD WE WORK CLOSELY
TOGETHER AND YOU KNOW I COULD
HAVE ON THE LAST ITEM THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AS WELL IN NON
DISCUSSION PORTION OF THE AGENDA --
THERE ARE SEVERAL PROPOSALS FROM
OUR OFFICE OF THE FOSTER CARE
OMBUDSMAN AND A LOT OF WORK AND
ON ON THE BILL OF RIGHTS AS WELL
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
ISSUE FORWARD.
OBVIOUSLY REDUCING THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF YOUTH AND
THEIR BEHAVIORS IS A GOOD THING
WE WENT ALL SUPPORT THAT -- I I
WOULD SAY IT'S PROBABLY TOO
EARLY TO TELL WHETHER THE MONEY
THAT WAS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET IS HAVING AN IMPACT OR
THE IMPACT THAT WAS INTENDED OF
IT.
THE COMMENT THAT I'VE MADE
PREVIOUSLY ABOUT YOU KNOW WHEN
WE MAKE AN INVESTMENT WHAT ARE
WE GETTING FOR IT WHAT WE EXPECT
TO SEE FOR IT.
PER SHARE THE CLARIFICATION THIS
IS A ONE TIME REQUEST.
THAT COMES ALONG WITH SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT STARTING
SOMETHING AND THEN STOPPING
SOMETHING OR WHAT COMES NEXT AS
THE NEXT STOP FOR THESE
PROVIDERS AS THEY EXPAND THE
CAPACITY.
UP SO AGAIN COMING BACK TO THE
HOW DO WE PROVE THAT IT WORKS SO
THAT WE KNOW WHETHER WE WANT TO
CONTINUE IN THE FUTURE OR NOT.
SO THOSE WOULD BE SOME KINDS OF
THE QUESTIONS I WOULD
ADDITIONALLY NOTE -- AND COULD
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE DONE IT
EARLIER THERE'S A LOT OF OVERLAP
IN THE ADDRESSING OF THE ISSUES
BETWEEN THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
YOU HEARD THP PLUS TALK ABOUT
BAD CAPACITY AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF BEDS AVAILABLE.
THEN WE HEARD A PROPOSAL ABOUT --
AT ADVOCATING FOR NAVIGATORS TO
HELP PEOPLE FIND PLACES TO STAY
HERE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
HELPING THEM ACHIEVE PERMANENCY
WHEN THEY'RE ALREADY IN A
CONGREGATE CARE SITUATION.
AND DIVERTING THEM FROM CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SO THERE'S A CERTAIN
PIECE TO THAT WE WOULD LIKE A
PART IN THE CONVERSATION NOT
JUST WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE IN ARE WE GETTING AT BUT
ALSO HOW DO THESE THINGS
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER SO IT'S
A MORE COMPLICATED CONVERSATION.
VALID ISSUE AND AGAIN FIRST
THING I SAID REDUCING THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF YOUTH AND
THEIR BEHAVIORS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT HUMAN THING TO BE
DOING.
BERMAN FINANCE -- ARE JUST
INTEREST FROM FINANCE ANSWERED
LIKE THAT ON THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS TAKEN SOME APPROACHES ON
THIS I BELIEVE -- REGULATIONS
WERE JUST FINALIZED IN OCTOBER
OF LAST YEAR TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
IN AND IT WITH -- A LOT OF THESE
FACILITIES ON ADDRESS SCENE --
PICTURED COULD END IN AN EFFORT
TO LIMIT THE NEED FOR CALLING
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO I JUST WANT
TO ADD THAT ON THERE.
THANK YOU AND I THINK YOU'RE
CORRECTIVE PARENTS AREN'T GOING
TO CALL.
POLICE LAW ENFORCEMENT TO COME
AND HELP THEM.
OUT.
SOLVE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE RIGHT
THIS THE USER TEENS AND THEY'RE
ACTING OUT AND BUT ONCE THEY'RE
CRIMINALIZE ONCE THEY ARE PUT
INTO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THEN IT'S SO HARD TO GET THEM
OUT BECAUSE THAT REMAINS WITH
THEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS TO US.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
SIX THAT'S NOT.
THAT'S NOT YET [inaudible]
DAVID DEMOING [inaudible]
SHE ISSUE NUMBER SIX ADDRESSING
THE IMPACT OF MANDATED STATE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE. FOR
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES.
ADVOCACY PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO TO
BE HERE.
MY NAME AGAIN IS DAVID DOWN WHEN
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY THAT PROVIDES A
ADOPTIONS AND FOSTER CARE
SERVICES.
AT LEAST FOR OUR AGENCY IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR WE SERVE ABOUT A
THOUSAND FOSTER CHILDREN.
ARE PRIMARILY CHILDREN OF COLOR
AND MINORITIES.
I I WANT TO FIRST SAY THAT WE
APPLIED.
THE COMMITMENT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR. TO
INCREASE THE WAGES AWFUL WORKERS
BY RAISING THE MINIMUM WAGE I
THINK THAT'S A POSITIVE.
FOR ALL THE WORKERS SEEN IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TO OUR BUDGET REQUEST THAT DEALS
WITH THE IMPACT.
THAT THE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES
ON THE ABILITY OF THE NONPROFIT
SUCH AS THE ONE THAT I WORKED
WITH. TO PAY OUR SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE STATE SAID IF A FAIR RATES
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE BEEN
FROZEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE AND WERE CUT 10% IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE WE SAW A
SLIGHT INCREASE OUR THREE YEARS
AGO.
BUT NOTHING CLOSE ENOUGH TO
COVER THE COST OF INCREASING
SOCIAL WORKER SALARIES.
I THINK YOU KNOW WE ALL AGREE
THAT SOCIAL WORKERS ARE GREAT
ADVOCATES AND MENTORS WERE OUR
FOSTER CHILDREN.
IN THE SYSTEM.
MAKING MATTERS WORSE FOR IF A
FACE.
THE STATE LAW REQUIRES THE EXAM
PROFESSIONAL EMPLOYEES BE PAID
DOUBLE THE MINIMUM WAGE.
WHILE THE MINIMUM WAGE ACT
MANDATES ANNUAL INCREASES TO THE
STATE'S MINIMUM WEIGHT.
FFA RAID DID NOT COVER THE COST
OF PAYING OUR SOCIAL WORKERS
DOUBLE THAT MINIMUM WAGE.
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO DO
WE DO WITH AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE
FUNDING SOURCES.
AND WE DON'T SEE ANY RATE
INCREASES.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
I THERE'S ONLY TWO STATE SET
FOSTER RATES AT THE NOT REESE
WHO RECEIVE A MANUAL ADJUSTMENT.
ONE IS THE FAA RATE AND SADLY
THE OTHER ONE NEEDS FOR INFANT
CARE SUPPLEMENT. TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE WITH THE LAW.
WE'RE ASKING THAT THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION OF TWENTY SIX MILLION
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
554-200-0192.
THOUSAND TWENTY ANY FURTHER
INCREASE OF FFA RATES AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH SUBSEQUENT
CALENDAR YEAR.
AT THE LESSER OF THREE POINT
FIVE OF THE CHANGE IN THE US
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX.
AS YOU KNOW IF IT FOR YOU
PROVIDE CARE SUPPORT AND
SERVICES FOR NEARLY THIRTEEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN.
SOME 25% OF THOSE KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE IN FOSTER CARE.
IF A FACE ARE CRITICAL TO
SUCCESS WILL IMPLEMENT THE
STATE'S CONTIENEN WITH CARE
REFORM.
THAT SIGNATURE HOME BASE FAMILY
CARE FOR EVERY CHILD IN FOSTER
CARE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
BRING IN FFA SOCIAL WORKER
SALARIES INTO COMPLIANCE.
WITH THE NEW STATE MINIMUM WAGE
LAW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITH THIS
SOUNDS LIKE A TOTALLY LOGICAL --
REQUEST.
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE -- IT MAY HAVE
BEEN OVERLOOKED FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
IS A FOR INCREASING THE MINIMUM
WAGE WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THE
FUNDING -- THAT GOES WITH THAT.
OF IT ANY THAT IS THE DSS SERGIO
OUT HAVE [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
YEAH I THINK YOU HEARD ME SAY
THAT ARE ANXIOUS AS HEARING THE
GOOD OUTCOMES FOR THE PEOPLE
WERE CARRYING FOUR DEPENDS IN
PART ON A STABLE AND THUS
PROPERLY COMPENSATED WORK FORCE --
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE RATES
SAYS AS MENTIONED THAT DOESN'T
AUTO ADJUST FOR CHANGES IN
MINIMUM WAGE THE DEFINITION OF
IT IS AS HE DESCRIBED IF IF
YOU'RE A PROFESSIONAL BY WAGE
ORDER NUMBER FOR YOUR YOUR WAIT
A YEAR WAGE MUST BE DOUBLE THE
THE MINIMUM WAGE.
AND AND WHILE WE ARE WHERE WE'RE
AT TODAY WERE ALSO ON A PASSED
TO TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR --
AT A FUTURE POINT IN TIME --
SOME FFA IS ARE ABLE TO MEET
THAT STANDARD TODAY UNDER THEIR
RATE -- OTHERS ARE NOT WE
UNDERSTAND THE RANGE OF WAGES IS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWENTY THREE
AND THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR FOR
THESE FOLKS THESE ARE PEOPLE
WITH MASTERS DEGREES AND SOCIAL
WORK -- AND SO YOU KNOW THAT
SHOULD THAT SHOULD WEIGH IN
THEIR AT THE END OF THE DAY.
AND IF WE CONTINUE TO CLASSIFY
THEM AS A PROFESSIONAL WHICH
WHICH IS THE MOST PEOPLE WOULD
AGREE THAT THEY ARE -- THEN THE
WAGE ORDER IS IS PRETTY CLEAR
THAT THERE WHICH NEEDS TO BE
DOUBLE MINIMUM WAGE.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU [inaudible]
BERMAN FINANCE [inaudible]
HELLO.
I I DO WANT TO JUST COMMENT THAT --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOCIAL
WORKERS THERE ARE.
OBVIOUSLY MANY HERE YESTERDAY
AND TODAY AND THEIR WORK IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THIS FIELD AND SO MANY OTHER
FEELS AND I I THANK YOU -- BY MY
SISTER REMINDS ME THAT IT'S SHE
HAS A DOCTOR AND SOCIAL WORK
THIS REMINDS ME THAT SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE REALLY THE ONES WHO
DO THE WORK YEAH.
THAT THE REST OF US JUST TALK
ABOUT IT BUT THE SOCIAL WORKERS
TO IT.
SO IN HONOR OF MY SISTER ROSA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES SOME
ISSUE NUMBER SIX WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVEN CHILD WELFARE PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSING.
EARLY INTERVENTION PILOT PROGRAM
[inaudible]
MARQUITA [inaudible]
HERIS [inaudible]
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARQUITA HARRIS FOR THE
LAST NINE YEARS I HAVE WORKED AS
A PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE SERVING
CHILDREN EVERY IS.
PLACED INTO FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I'M HERE
TO ASK FOR FUNDING IN THE AMOUNT
OF EIGHT POINT TWO FIVE MILLION
FOR THE STATE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS WHICH WE BELIEVE WILL BE
MATCHED BY EQUAL OR MORE FEDERAL.
TITLED NINETEEN FUNDING THOUSAND
IS COUNTY IS THE HOME OF THE
LARGEST CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AS TO AS CHALLENGE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES WE
SERVE MILLIONS.
AT RISK DETAINED THE TENSION
FAMILIES WHO TYPICALLY SHOULDER
A HIGHER BURDEN OF CHRONIC AND
PREVENTABLE DISEASES AND
COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE IN
EPIDEMICS OF DIABETES AS MOBY
CITY.
ARTISANS EXTRACTING AN INFANTS
WHO ARE EXPOSED.
TO ABUSE WHILE MOTHERS ARE
PREGNANT.
EACH MONTH OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
CALLS IN LA COUNTY REPORT IS A
BIT SUSPECTED CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES DO.
DO NOT GO OUT ON EVERY REFERRAL.
WE GO OUT ON CALLS THAT COME
FROM MULTIPLE PROVIDERS FROM
HOSPITALS CLINICS SCHOOLS OR
WHEN THE SOCIAL WORKER.
HAS DETERMINED THAT THE
SUPPLEMENTAL HEALTH ASSESSMENT
BY PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
NECESSARY I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
A FEW STORIES WITH YOU TO
ILLUSTRATE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
ROLE THE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
PLATE IN THE TOWER FOR
ASSISTANCE.
I HAD A SIX YEAR OLD CHILD WHO
WAS NOT THE PRIMARY REASON FOR
THE REFERRAL THE MOTHER HAD
SEVEN TWO CHILDREN THE CHILD
WITH A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
POUNDS.
THE CHAO HAD A TRAIT DUE TO
MORBID OBESITY N. SLEEP APNEA
WHEN I WENT TO THE HOME AND
DISCOVERED THAT THERE WAS HE
TANKS WHICH OXYGEN TANK THAT WAS
LEFT NEXT TO THE HEATER.
ALSO THAT THE CHILD HAS NOT BEEN
FOLLOWED UP ON THE WITH THE
PULLMAN KNOWLEDGES THAT MANAGES
THE TRADE FOR OVER A YEAR THE
MOTHER THROUGH ALL THE SUPPLIES
IN THE CLOSET.
AND WILL BASICALLY NOT TAKING
CARE OF THE CHILD.
SO DO TO MY A A I'M GOING
DILIGENCE THE CHILD WAS SAID
CONNECTED TO THE POLL MONOLOGIST
I SUBMITTED MY MEDICAL CONCERNS
THE CHILD WAS A MINUTE A NEATLY
INTO.
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT THE CHILD
WAS ALSO MONITOR BY DOCTOR EVERY
TEN MINUTES DUE TO THE CRITICAL
ILLNESS OF THE CHILD THE CHILD
HAD MULTIPLE BACTERIAL.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF INFECTION
AROUND THE TRACK AND IN THE
TRICK AND THE DOCTORS THAT THE
POINT TOLD ME THAT I SAY THAT
CHILD'S LIFE.
ANOTHER STORY I WANT TO MENTION
IS THAT I HAVE A FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD ON CONTROL DIABETIC.
TYPE ONE WHICH MEANS THAT THEIR
INSULIN DEPENDENT.
OF THE SOCIAL WORKER NOTIFIED ME
THAT THE SCHOOL SAID THAT THE
CHILD'S BLOOD SUGAR WAS FIVE
HUNDRED I ASKED THE SOCIAL WORK
AND TAKE THE CHILD TO EMERGENCY
ROOM TO HAVE THAT MEDICAL
ASSESSMENT.
DUE TO I HEARD ABOUT THE PAIR'S
NOT COMPLIANCE AND UNSUPERVISED
IN SUBDIVISION OF THE CHILD.
ALSO I DID COMPLETED THE JOY
HOME VISIT THAT SAME WEEK I WAS
ABLE TO ASSESS THE FAMILIES NEED
SAW THAT THERE WAS SOME EMOTION
THE SO THEY NEED TO BE CONNECTED
TO MENTAL HEALTH.
MOM WAS CRYING AND STRUGGLING
WITH THE TEEN TEEN ALSO
STRUGGLING.
SO I WAS ABLE TO CONNECT THEM
ALSO I WAS ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
THE METER FOR THE BLOOD SUGARS
AND NOTICED THAT THE CHILD HAD.
SEVERE HIGHS CONTINUOUSLY FROM
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED TO
SIXTEEN HUNDRED CELLS ABLE TO
SHOW THAT THAT FAMILY THAT IF
THEY GO ON CHECK AT THE INSULIN
IF THE BLOOD SUGAR IS UNCHECKED
AND NOT COVER.
THE NO CHILD THE BLOOD SUGAR
WILL KEEP GOING UP IN THE CHAO
COULD POSSIBLY DIE.
SO WHAT DO TO MY DILIGENCE I
RECOMMENDED THAT THE FAMILY ALSO
GO BACK INTO THE ENDOCRINOLOGIST
TO BE RETESTED ON HOW TO MANAGE
THE DIABETES REGIMENT WHICH IS
STILL SO IMPORTANT.
ALSO OF THAT IMPACT IF WE WERE
IF I WAS ABLE TO GO IN SOONER.
LIKE THE ONE WITH THE TRICK
THEY'RE NOT PREVENTED THE CHILD
FROM BEING DETAINED AND KEPT THE
CHILD IN THE HOME WITH THE
DIABETIC PATIENTS.
I WAS ABLE TO SO FAR KEEP THE
CHILD IN THE HOME DUE TO THE
SERVICE CONNECTIONS AND THEN
ALSO TO DO A FOLLOW UP VISIT. TO
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING THAT I HAD
SUGGESTED IN RECOMMENDED THAT IS
IN PLACE AND THAT THEY ARE
FOLLOWING IN FOLLOWING THE
DIABETIC A PROPER REGIMENT PRO
THE DOCTOR'S ORDERS SO THEN I
WILL MAKE THAT DETERMINATION AT
THAT TIME. TO PREVENT THE CHILD
FROM BEING REMOVED FROM THE HOME
WE LIKE TO KEEP THE FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
SO PROVIDING THE APPROPRIATE
SUPPORT PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
LINK FAMILIES TO PREVENTATIVE IN
INTERVENTIONAL HEALTH SERVICES.
TO AT RISK CHILDREN BEFORE
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS BECOME
LIFE THREATENING PROTECTING
CHILDREN.
THE TECHNICIAN WITHIN AGAINST
UNNECESSARY HELP THE CLIENT AND
THE WARNING CHILD FATALITY.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE THE FIRST
EXAMPLE THAT I THAT I HAD
MENTIONED I SAY THAT CHILD'S
LIFE.
SO PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES ARE WE
WE HAVE THAT UNIQUE SKILL TO
WHERE WE CAN ASSESS THE CHAO
FROM HEAD TO TOE AND DETERMINE
WHAT IS NEEDED IN THE TYPE OF
SERVICES FOR THAT CHILD.
SOME OPEN IT TO SUPPORT OUR OF
EARLY INTERVENTION PILOT PROGRAM
OF EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION.
WITH A FEDERAL MATCH OF THE
EIGHT POINT.
TWO FIVE I JUST HAD TO
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THIS. ONE IS
THAT IT'S LA COUNTY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST AND I ARE IN SAN
BERNADINO.
SECONDS THAT WE WOULDN'T HAVE
YOU I'VE GOT.
TO I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU THAT --
I JUST IN THE WAY THAT YOU
PRESENT THIS -- IT IS CLEAR THAT
YOU ARE DEDICATED TO THIS
ABSOLUTE AND WHEN WE HAVE
DEDICATED -- TO PEOPLE SUCH AS
YOURSELF IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO BE TO LISTEN -- YOU YOU ARE
DOING THE WORK.
JUST AS WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
WE TALKING TO THE FOSTER YOUTH
THAT'S IMPORTANT OVER TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY DOING
THE WORK NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
IT.
I THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND ALSO
BECAUSE THAT WAS ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS Y. LA COUNTY WHY SO
MUCH FOR JUST ONE COUNTY.
WERE UNDERSTAND LA COUNTY AS ONE
THIRD.
OF ALL THE CASELOAD FOR THE
STATE OF CALLAHAN'S A LITTLE BIT
THERE'S SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
FOSTER YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA ALONE
AND LA COUNTY HAS.
TWENTY THOUSAND SO WE'RE HUGE
COUNTY YES YOU ARE -- IF WE
COULD GET THE PILOT GOING IN AND
THEN EVENTUALLY IF I COULD TO
ONLY DISCREDIT STATEWIDE
ABSOLUTE ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT SEVEN GET OR OR LOOK
AT SOME TYPE OF PILOT PROGRAM --
IN BOTH AREAS I THINK ON A ON A
DIFFERENT SCALES.
SINCE WE'RE THE ONLY ONES LEFT.
RIGHT NOW YEAH YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW COUNTY REMAINS THE
LARGEST COUNTY WITH WITH THE
GREAT GREAT NEED THIS OVERLOOKED
ALSO COUNTY AND WE HAVE MULTIPLE
COMPLEXES BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
SOCIAL ECONOMICS AND ALSO
THEY'RE NOT.
ALWAYS EDUCATED A LOT ON THE
BELOW SIX GRADE LEVEL SO THERE'S
A LOT OF EXTRA THINGS THAT WE
HAD TO DO AN AUDIT TAKE CARE OF
OUR ANOTHER REASON WHY SHOULD BE
A PILOT PROGRAM IN BOTH COUNTIES.
IS BECAUSE A LOT OF THE MEMBERS
AND CLIENTS TO DO -- TRAVEL ON
BECAUSE IT'S SO CLOSE FROM LA
COUNTY IN DECEMBER YOU KNOW
COUNTY SO IT COULD BE SERVING
THE SAME FOLDED STARED JUST A A
FOOD FOR THOUGHT.
AND IF WE KEEP TALKING WILL
DAVID GIVE YOU EVER REASON
POSSIBLE.
THE HOUSING IS LESS EXPENSIVE SO
WE KNOW THAT.
THAT LA COUNTY HI THAT'S RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT BUT THE POPULATION
DOES CONTINUE.
TO MOVE DOESN'T SEE COUNTY LINES
IT SEES THE NEED GOING.
AND EVERYWHERE THIS NEED IT SO
WE WOULD -- AVIC OUR IN OUR
ADVOCATING FOR A PILOT PROGRAM
ALSO ASSEMBLY NO COUNTY.
WE GOT TO GET WATER LA FOR FOR
YOU GUYS BUT BECAUSE THEY ONLY
COUNTIES HAS THE ONE THIRD OF
THE FOSTER USE.
IF WE CAN GET THAT PILOT GOING
TO NAIL BEEN CORRECTED AND THEN
WE CAN DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT
THE OF THE COUNTIES I THINK.
YOU'LL PROBABLY BE HAPPY ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE YOU WON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE ONE LITTLE BUGS
AND DIFFERENT THINGS OTHER
PROBLEMS BUT ENOUGH.
IT IS DEFINITELY THERE IS A NEED
FOR THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MS HARRIS --
IT ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
THE ADMINISTRATION ONE MORE PLUG
FOR SAN BENITO COUNTY YES THERE.
IS THERE A I WOULD GREG ROSE TO
THE DEPARTMENT I JUST AS A
SOCIAL WORKER MYSELF CLEARLY THE
THAT THE SKILL SET FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE -- IS IS --
IS DIFFERENT AND OFTEN
COMPLEMENTARY AND I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST SUGGEST THAT IF THE IF
THIS IS A PRIORITY THAT WE COULD
WE WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A LOOK AT
THE IMPLEMENTATION WORK WITH ON
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS HER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT CONTINUATION OF
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME -- FRANK
MECCA FEEL.
TO THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FRANK MECCA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CWD A I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
AMR SEEKING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY IN. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
CONTINUE AND EXPAND THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM. TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN OR COALITION
ADVOCATED FOR THE CREATION OF
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM.
BASED ON WHAT WE SAW WITH THE
GROWING CONCERN IN CALIFORNIA
OVER THE LINK BETWEEN CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT AND
HOMELESSNESS AMONG FAMILIES.
AT THE TIME NATIONAL DATA
INDICATED ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
CHILD OFFER INVOLVE FAMILIES
WERE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AND MORE HOMELESSNESS BUT CAN
NOT IN AND OF ITSELF BE A BASIS
FOR REMOVAL THERE'S ABSOLUTELY A
LINK BETWEEN REFERRALS TO CPS.
AND HOMELESSNESS.
AND EVEN MORE COMMON FAMILIES
HAVE COMPLIED WITH COURT ORDERS
AND RULES OR OTHERWISE READY TO
REUNIFY WE KNOW ARE NOT BEING
REUNIFIED BECAUSE JUDGES ARE
LOATH. TO REUNIFY CHILDREN TO
THE STREETS.
I'M IN SO WE LITERALLY HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THEIR CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE FOR NO OTHER
REASON.
BUT FOR THE FACT THAT THEIR
PARENTS CAN'T FIND SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE.
AND SO THE BRINGING FAMILIES
HOME PROGRAM WAS CREATED AS A
DEMONSTRATION PROGRAM THE
TRAILER BILL.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT USES
THE HOUSING FIRST MODEL AN
EVIDENCE BASED INTERVENTIONS.
THAT WE'VE SEEN SUCCESSFULLY
WORK IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS IN
THE COUNTRY.
COUNTY AGENCIES COLLABORATE TO
OFFER HOUSING SUPPORTS.
RENT RENTAL ASSISTANCE FIRST AND
LAST MONTH'S HOUSING
MODIFICATIONS FOR EXAMPLE -- TO
ALLOW FOR SUCCESSFUL
REUNIFICATION OF CHILDREN WITH
THEIR FAMILIES ACCORDING TO THE
S. S. IS DATA.
BETWEEN THE START UP IN FEBRUARY
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IN JUST
OVER ONE YEAR OF OPERATION THE
PROGRAM IS PERMANENTLY HOUSE
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR
FAMILIES.
WHICH IS ALREADY EXCEEDING BUT
FIVE HUNDRED FAMILY GOAL THAT WE
ORIGINALLY SET FOR THE PROGRAM.
AND DURING THE COURSE OF THE
DEMONSTRATION WE'VE ALSO GAIN
BETTER DATA ABOUT THE LINK
BETWEEN HOMELESSNESS AND CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT.
ARE COUNTIES FOR EXAMPLE
REPORTING NOW THAT HALF OF CHILD
WHILE BROOMBALL FAMILIES ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS -- SO
FUNDING FOR THE EXISTING
DEMONSTRATION IS SET TO EXPIRE
ON JUNE THIRTIETH AND SOAP WILL
WE WILL BE TAKING NO MORE
REFERRALS -- IN THE TWELVE
COUNTIES THAT ARE PART OF THE
DEMONSTRATION -- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT ONLY IN JUST THE TWELVE
COUNTIES THAT ARE DEMONSTRATING
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME THEIR
FIVE HUNDRED IS TIONAL FAMILIES
THAT ARE DETERMINED ELIGIBLE BUT
ARE WAITING BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE.
THE RESOURCES -- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT IT'S PART OF THE
DEMONSTRATION DSS WAS TASKED
WITH THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
COLLECTING DATA AND REPORTING ON
THE OUTCOMES AND WE KNOW THAT
THAT THAT THAT WORK IS IN
PROCESS.
BUT CLEARLY THE EARLY RESULTS
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THAT THE
REPORTS WERE MY MEMBERS INDICATE
THAT THIS IS AN EXTREMELY COST
EFFECTIVE AND BENEFICIAL PROGRAM
AND SO WE'RE REQUESTING.
THAT THE PROGRAM BE RE
AUTHORIZED FOR TWO MORE YEARS
AND BE INCREASED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION.
SO THAT WE CAN BOTH EXPAND.
THE DEMONSTRATION WITHIN THE
EXISTING COUNTIES BUT ALSO
EXPAND TO NEW COUNTIES WHICH I
SHOULD SAY IS SORT OF THE ARK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
TRUCK WHEN IT CREATED AND THEN
EXPANDED THE COW WORKS HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM WHICH THIS IS IN
SOME WAY MODELED AFTER.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
COMMENTS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
PERHAPS IT'S A SIGN OF OUR CLOSE
COLLABORATION ON THIS OF MISTER
MECCA STOLE ALL MY STATISTICS.
WELL TO BE FAIR -- WE STOLE THEM
FROM PETE'S STAFF THE YOU KNOW
THE THINGS THAT I'VE SAID THE OF
A HE NOTED THE EVALUATION WON'T
BE DONE UNTIL NEXT YEAR.
I WOULD ADD IN ADDITION TO THE
FACT THAT IT'S FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR FAMILIES THAT HAVE
SO FAR BEEN REUNIFIED THAT'S
TWELVE HUNDRED KIDS.
JUST TO ADD THAT NUMBER IN THERE.
AND FROM A PROGRAM OPERATIONS
STANDPOINT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
ALTHOUGH IT'S EXACTLY RIGHT THIS
WAS A ONE TIME THREE MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM WITH AN
EVALUATION COMPONENT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT PROGRAMMATIC LEE TO TO
RUN SOMETHING STOP IT AND
RESTART IT IF THAT DECISION IS
MADE TO RESTART.
ADDITIONALLY I'D NOTE THAT WHEN
YOU REUNIFY FAMILY WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME IN THIS HEARING ON
ISSUE ONE ON C. C. R. WHEN YOU
RE UNIFY THESE ARE KIDS THAT
DON'T NEED A RESOURCE FAMILY
BECAUSE THEIR WITH THEIR
FAMILIES.
SO AGAIN ALL THESE THINGS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP IN A RELATIONSHIP
WITH EACH OTHER.
SO -- SHIP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE FOLLOW UP THAT'S DONE
WITH THE FAMILIES TO SEE IF THE
PLACEMENT HAS BEEN PERMANENT AND
SO THESE THESE ARE FAMILY THERE
ACTUALLY ARE UNDER COURT
SUPERVISION -- EITHER
VOLUNTARILY OR OR THROUGH A
PETITION BEING FILED SO.
ON THE DECISION TO REUNIFY HAS
TO BE APPROVED BY THE JUDGE.
AND SO THE JUDGE WOULD SAY THAT
THIS IS A FAMILY THAT'S REMOVED
ALL OF THE SAFETY CONCERNS.
DAVE COMPLIED WITH EVERYTHING
THAT WE REQUIRED AND AND I THE
JUDGE I'M READY. TO TO ORDER
REUNIFICATION BUT FOR THE FACT.
THAT THE PARENTS DON'T HAVE A
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
LIVE AND SO -- THAT THE
CONDITIONS FOR REUNIFICATION I
E. THAT THE CHILD WILL BE SAFE
WITH THAT FAMILY.
IN THIS CASE HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MATT AND ARE CERTIFIED TO BY THE
JUDGE BEFORE THEY WOULD ISSUE
THE REUNIFICATION ORDER.
WHAT WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF?
FUNDING IS A PROVIDED.
KIDS WILL STAY IN FOSTER CARE
LONGER.
AND PARENTS WHO SHOULD BE WITH
THEIR CHILDREN AND CHILDREN WHO
SHOULD BE WITH THEIR PARENTS
WERE BOTH SUFFER THE TRAUMA OF
BEING SEPARATED.
BRITAIN BUT FOR THE ONLY REASON
BEING THE FACT THAT HOUSING IS
SOEXPENSIVE AND SO DIFFICULT TO
FIND.
AND THEY NEED HELP WITH IT AND
THE CURRENT SYSTEM WAS NEVER
BUILT. TO PROVIDE HOUSING
SUPPORTS AS PART OF THE
REUNIFICATION MILIEU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOUR AVAILABLE SPACE WHICH OF
PLEASE DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF LET'S GO
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE OUR LAST
ISSUE.
WE HAVE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
ANY TABLE ALREADY -- C. W. S.
TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT YES WHAT WE'RE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION.
AND WE'RE SEEKING TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR DSS NOT
FOR COUNTIES.
AND IT'S FOR DSS. TO AUGMENT THE
EXISTING CHILD WELFARE TRAINING
THAT THEY PROVIDE TO OUR WORKERS.
THIS -- INVESTMENT WOULD
LEVERAGE TWELVE ADDITIONAL
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO READ THE RESULT IN
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN REALIGNMENT AND
SH THAT SHIFTED THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF TRAVEL FOR THE
COUNTIES.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF FUNCTIONS
THAT WERE NOT REALIGNED AND
TRAINING WITH ONE OF THEM.
THE BELIEF AT THE TIME AND I
THINK IT'S THOUGH IF IT'S THE
RIGHT BELIEF WAS THAT FOR
PURPOSES OF ENSURING CONSISTENCY.
AND ACHIEVING ECONOMIES OF SCALE
THAT THE STATE SHOULD BE THE
PROVIDER OF TRAINING IN THE
STATE HAS A ROBUST
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE REGIONAL TRAINING ACADEMY SO
SORT OF IF IT'S NOT BROKE LET'S
NOT TRY TO FIX THAT.
THE TRAINING WITH CAP WITH THE
STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT FUNDING FOR
STATE TRAINING HAS NOT KEPT PACE
WITH THE MAJOR CHANGES IN THE
PROGRAM IN RECENT YEARS.
YOU'VE HEARD ALL ABOUT C. C. R.
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMING THE KD ES.
SETTLEMENT FOR EXAMPLE.
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
FEDERALLY REQUIRED PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT PLAN THAT REQUIRES
THAT WE IMPROVE OUR PRACTICE AND
ONE OF THE METHODOLOGIES FOR
DOING THAT.
IS IS BETTER TRAINING -- SO
THEY'RE ALL THESE IMPERATIVES TO
ENHANCE THE TRAINING AND AND IT
REALLY HAS SORT OF NOT KEPT UP
WITH SORT OF LANGUISHED AND SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR THIS --
AUGMENTATION FOR THE STATE TO
ENHANCE ITS CONTRACTS WITH THE
REGIONAL TRAINING ACADEMIES TO
PROVIDE -- THAT.
MORE TRAINING FOR THE REASONS
THAT I'VE MENTIONED BUT ALSO
SOME OTHER ENHANCEMENTS TRAINING
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM LIKE
WITH PEERS SO THAT THEIR OTHER
MODALITIES OF LEARNING.
TRAINING FOR SUPERVISORS BECAUSE
WE ALL KNOW THAT SUPERVISION IS
AS IMPORTANT. TO OUTCOMES AS AS
THE WORK OF THE LINE -- CASE
WORKER.
TRAINING FOR SPECIALTY
POPULATIONS CHILDREN WHO'VE BEEN
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED --
FOR EXAMPLE AND IS ALSO -- A
PROVISION IN OUR REQUEST TO
ALLOW FOR THE GATHERING ABOUT
COME DATA TO SEE IF THE TRAINING
IS ACTUALLY IMPROVING THE
PRACTICE -- AND SO -- THAT IS
THE BASIS FOR A REQUEST AND WE'D
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IN
THE MORE MORE SPECIFICS TO
OPERATIONALIZE OUR REQUEST.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ON PAIN OF ECHOING MISTER MACKEY
YET AGAIN YOU KNOW HE'S RIGHT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TRYING TO
CHANGES IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM -- UP TO THIS POINT UP TO
THIS POINT THE APPROACH HAS BEEN
RE PRIORITIZING THE EXISTING
TRAINING BUDGETS WHEN WE LOOK AT
UPDATING CURRICULUM AND SO FORTH.
WE HEAR HIM SAY ON ON BEHALF OF
HIS MEMBERS WHO ARE DOING THE
WORK THAT MORE IS NEEDED.
AND HE ALREADY TOUCHED ON OTHER
THINGS I WOULD SAY WE WANT THE
TRAINING TO REFLECT MODERN
PROVEN APPROACHES REUSABLE
CONTENT PROMOTE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES.
FIELD BASED FOLLOW ON TRAININGS
HE MENTIONED SUPERVISOR TRAINING --
SPECIALTY POPULATIONS NEW TOPICS
FOR FOR FOR THOSE -- AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT AS WELL
ABOUT COLLECTING OUTCOME DATA
YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK ALL DAY
TODAY THAT WHEN WE INVEST IN
SOMETHING WE WANT TO KNOW
WHETHER WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WORKING WHETHER WE'RE GETTING
WHAT WE EXPECTED.
YOU KNOW ALL AND MAYBE THE FINAL
COMMENT THERE ARE A COUPLE
THINGS YOU NEVER HEAR AND ONE OF
THEM IS MY RATE IS TOO HIGH.
AND THE OTHER THAT YOU NEVER
HEAR IS I'M OVER TRAINED.
RIGHT ON I MEAN YES [inaudible]
HELLO. FOUR WONDERFUL WHAT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THAT -- AND
NOW I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP.
TO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON ISSUES TO THROUGH.
NINE I ALSO TRIED THEM TO FIGHT
WHAT ISSUE YOU'RE SPEAKING ABOUT.
AND AGAIN WE ASK THAT YOU KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO WONDER ONE
MINUTE.
YES HI -- MY NAME IS TASHA
MATTHEWS I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH SPEAKING ON IN -- IN
SUPPORT OF THE FFA SOCIAL
BECAUSE GETTING AN INCREASE IN --
PAYMENT -- JUST BECAUSE I GREW
UP IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND I WAS
IN FOSTER CARE MY WHOLE LIFE
FROM ONE MONTH OLD TELL TWENTY
ONE YEARS OF AGE.
I WAS WORKING MORE WITH THE
COUNTY EVEN FFA BUT I SAW HOW
THE OVERTURN OF COUNTY SOCIAL
WORKERS AND JUST THAT CONSTANT.
LAKE WANTING TO TELL THEM WHAT'S
WRONG WITH MY FOSTER FAN FAMILY
AND LIKE ISSUES GOING ON WITH
THIS ONE PLACEMENT WHEN
UNFORTUNATELY NOT GETTING TO DO
THAT UNTIL WAS. TOO LATE AND BY
THAT TIME I WAS ALREADY AN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE AND THEY
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF ME
UNFORTUNATELY -- THEIR FRIED AND
SO I'D THEN THEY FOUND OUT WITH
ISSUES AND IN BY THEN IT WAS
THERE'S SO MUCH TIME THAT WENT
BY SO I'M TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF
YOU KNOW SUPPORTING US
SPECIFICALLY FFA SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SEEING THE WORK THAT THEY DO
JUST WORKING IN THAT.
AGENCY AND SO JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE YOU
GONNA BE A SOCIAL WORKER.
TO NO I'M I'M MORE THINKING LAW
LAW SCHOOL RIGHT NOW SO WE'LL.
YEAH.
YEAH I'M AN ATTORNEY AS WELL --
GREET THANK YOU YES THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MELISSA VIA
GOMEZ AND I'M A FORMER FOSTER
THAT AS WELL -- FROM SAN DIEGO
WAS IN FOSTER CARE FOR ELEVEN
YEARS BUT THE FOR THE FIRST
THREE YEARS IN FOSTER CARE WAS
AT THE COUNTY AND MOVED ABOUT
THREE TIMES.
I CAN'T RECALL WHO MY SOCIAL
WORKER WAS BUT WHEN I WAS ABOUT
EIGHT I FINALLY WENT INTO AN FFA
AGENCY AND I WAS ASSIGNED AN FFA
SOCIAL WORKER.
WHO'S STAYED WITH ME FOR SEVEN
YEARS AND ACTUALLY STILL
CONTINUE HAVING A RELATIONSHIP
WITH HER AT THIS TIME I MEET
WITH THEIR ONCE A MONTH -- BUT I
CAN TELL YOU FROM THE MOMENT
THAT I MATTER SHE GOT ME -- ON A
PLAN FOR SUCCESS SHE NOTICED
THAT I WAS THREE GRADES BEHIND
AND I CAN TELL YOU I WOULDN'T BE
HERE STANDING IN FRONT OF YOU
WITH A DOUBLE MAJOR IN SOCIOLOGY
AND CRIMINOLOGY.
AND NOW ADVOCATING FOR FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND I AM THE
YOUNGEST OF FIVE I WAS THE ONLY
ONE THAT WAS ABLE TO GET INTO AN
FHA AGENCY AND UNFORTUNATELY MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
A REPEATING THE CYCLE AND I DO
HAVE -- NEPHEWS AND NIECES THAT
ARE IN FOSTER CARE NOW.
SO I DO ADVOCATE FOR THE
INCREASE FOR FFA SOCIAL WORKERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO IMPORTANT AND
WE NEED MORE OF THEM SO THAT.
MORE FAST YOU'D HAVE
AGENCIES.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON JORDAN SO SO
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION AN
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
KERN A FORMER FOSS YOU'VE TO
IMPROVE THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
TO LEGISLATIVE POLICY AND
PRACTICE CHANGE.
I DO WANT TO GIVE.
A SHOUT OUT TO A G. DETAILS IN
JAKARTA CARSON THE MORE IT'S A
STUDIO -- FOR GIVEN THEIR
EXPERTISE THEIR TESTIMONIES AND
THE USE PERSPECTIVE WITHIN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM -- HERE IN
SUPPORT AND ISSUE TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS AMONG FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH ADVOCACY PROPOSAL -- ISSUE
THREE ON PROMOTING HOUSING
STABILITY FOR TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH ADVOCACY PROPOSAL -- ISSUE
FOR ELIMINATING BARRIERS TO
ENTER AND RE ENTER EXTENT OF
FOSTER CARE ADVOCACY PROPOSAL
AND ISSUE A CONTINUATION OF
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME ADVOCACY
PROPOSAL OUR VISION FOR THE
ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR YOUTH.
COULD GROW UP TO BE HEALTHY AND
VIBRANT ADULTS AND WE BELIEVE
THESE PROPOSALS WILL CONTRIBUTED
THEIR DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AT THE SENATE JOHNSON WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
HERE FOR ISSUE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE NON DISCUSSION ITEMS ISSUE
TEN ON THE OFFICE OF FOSTER
CAMPUS PERSON.
AND THE ISSUE ELEVEN ON THE
STATE TRIBAL -- ED EQUAL
COMPLIANCE ITEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS ON
THE WITH THE ADDRESS I'M I'M A
SOCIAL WORKER AT A SPRINT FOSTER
CARE AGENCY AND FRESNO I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUES TWO FOUR
AND SIX I JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
RECONSIDER -- AS I HAVE FOURTEEN
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN BEING A
FOSTER PARENT AND I'VE SEEN A
LOT OF CHANGES AND REMEMBER THAT
THESE CHILDREN ARE OUR FUTURE OF
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU AGREED THANK YOU.
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE DO SUPPORT
ALL THESE PROPOSALS BUT I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT A FEW -- ISSUE.
THREE THIS ONE IT WAS ONE OF OUR
LOBBY DAYS ISSUES THIS PAST
MONDAY WHEN WE HAD OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS IN THE CAPITAL -- ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF ISSUE FIVE ISSUE
SIX ON THE MINIMUM WAGE -- FOR
FFA AGENCIES I THINK IT WAS
POINTED OUT THAT THAT SOMETHING
WE REALLY MUST DO -- AND THE
ISSUE NINE WHERE A CO SPONSOR OF
THE CW AS TRAINING THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NANCY PRESS
MARTINEZ I'M A SOCIAL WORKER
WITH.
A STERN AND FRESNO AND I'M
SUPPORTING ISSUES TO FOR AN
ESPECIALLY.
SIX ARM FOR WAGES THAN INCREASES
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS A LOT OF US
AS AS WE HEARD EARLIER WE WE
NEED MASTER'S DEGREES TO GET
INTO THESE JOBS AND SOME OF US
GET INTO SIGNIFICANT THAT.
AND THEN WE START WORKING IN THE
FIELD AND GET PAID -- NOT ENOUGH
AND ARE IN THAT FOR A LONG TIME
AND I'VE SEEN MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES LEAVE THAT ARE VERY
QUALIFIED AND VERY PASSIONATELY
FOR OTHER JOBS AND OTHER PLACES
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
STAY IN.
AND SOCIAL SERVICES WITH THESE
PACE OF THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA MICHAEL
GASTON WITH YOU FORWARD.
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
FIVE THE FOSTERING SUCCESS FINE
AND IF I MAY UM OUR YOUTH BOARD
MEMBER DEVOTION ARE MADIGAN'S.
WHO WAS A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
YOU CAN BE HERE TODAY BUT SHE
WANTED ME TO SAY THAT THIS BILL?
GIVES FOSTER YOUTH A SHOT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE REAL WORLD AND
THAT'S WHY SHE URGES YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING JACQUI ONE WITH
GRAYSON -- ENDING ENDING CHILD.
REDDING CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN SO
EAGER TO SUPPORT. TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SEVEN AND YES SEVEN AS A
SOCIAL WORKER I ACTUALLY WANT TO
SUPPORT THE THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE TO RATE SO THAT'S
SEPARATE AND APART FROM GRACE
BUT THANK YOU.
AND SO EVANS HOLDEN FAMILY
SERVICES AND I'M THE CO I WILL
ONE HAVING CONTINUAL DIFFICULTY
RETAINING SOME OF OUR WONDERFUL
FISH WORKERS HAS WITH HEAD
STABILITY AT STUFF MAKES SUCH A
DIFFERENCE TO THE YOUTH WE WORK
WITH.
SO WE SUPPORT THE SUCH WORK
INCREASE ALSO WORKED WITH MANY
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH WE DO
SUPPORT THE BILLS TO AND HANS
ALL SERVICES TRUCK TRANSITION
AGE YOU THOUGHT THAT YOU TWO
THREE AND FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CNN IF AN WITH CHILDREN NOW WE
SUPPORT ALL THE ASKS AGAIN
CHILDREN DON'T HAVE JUST ONE
NEED THAT MANY NEEDS OF THE MORE
OF THESE YOU CAN FIND THE BETTER.
I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TWO AND
THREE RIGHT NOW THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS JUST REALLY HITTING
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE HARD SO
EVERYTHING THAT YOU CAN DO TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE AT LEAST
HOUSED IN SHELTERED IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU.
WESLEY SABER JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ISSUE TWO THREE FOUR
SIX EIGHT NINE STRONG SUPPORT OF
ALL OF US THANK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALEXIS BERRY'S FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND NOW KERN
ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT OF THE BUT
SMITH'S PROPOSAL AND ALSO AS A
FORMER HOMELESS YOUTH IN FULL
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER TWO FOR
THE HOMES PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WOULD BE SANTOS SEIU CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUES THREE SEVEN
EIGHT AND NINE IN REGARDS TO OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE PROPOSAL WE
ARE MOST WELCOMING OF EXPANDING
IT TO INCLUDE ANY OTHER COUNTY
ALTHOUGH WE NEED A LITTLE MORE
MONEY.
NOT LA MONEY BUT A LITTLE MORE
MONEY -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
ME GIVE A HEARTY CAMPBELL
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM.
AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO MISTER
MAC AS COMMENTS ON HOW IMPORTANT
PROGRAM IS WE HAVE -- WE'RE ONE
OF THE TWELVE COUNTIES IN HOUSE --
OVER NINETY FAMILIES AND I
PERSONALLY SEEN THE IMPACT THAT
THIS PROGRAM CAN HAVE SO I URGE
YOU TO CONTINUE ANTHONY THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JERRY JOHNSON THE QUANTITY OF
FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE SIX AND JUSTICE YOUR
PERSONAL.
I WENT FOR NINE YEARS WITHOUT A
RAISE.
IT'S MY GIRLS FROM HIGH SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE I COULD REALLY USE
THE MONEY BUT BECAUSE OF MY AND
MY SALARY WAS LOCKED.
MY VALUE FOR DOLLAR DROP AND
THAT'S THE SITUATION A LOT OF
OUR WORKERS ARE NOW.
THANKS THANKS FOR STICKING WITH
IT BECAUSE THE KIDS THAT YOU
HELPED OBVIOUSLY WORK.
THAT THAT WAS SO IMPORTANT I
MEAN DURING THIRTY ONE YEARS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT.
JULIE MCCORMICK CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUES --
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SEVEN AND
AIDS -- I THINK AS THROUGH THE
END OF AN FROM CHILDREN NOW SAID
CHILDREN.
IN FOSTER YOUTH ARE IN NEED OF
ALL OF THESE ISSUES WHAT YOU CAN
FIND WOULD BE GREAT I DO WANT
ESPECIALLY HIGHLIGHT AND THANK
MADAM CHAIR FOR COMMENTS.
IN REGARDS TO ISSUE -- FOR THESE
ARE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD SEVENTEEN
HAVE YOUR OLD IN DESPERATE
SITUATIONS CHILDREN'S AUTHOR OF
CALIFORNIA'S A PROUD CO SPONSOR
THAT ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CO SPONSORING THE
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- WHEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE THREE ON
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE INITIATE ON
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME --
COUNTIES CONTINUE TO COME BACK
HOMELESSNESS AT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IS NO IMPORTANT MORE
IMPORTANT PLACE TO INVEST THEN --
INSURING THAT CHILDREN YOUTH
HAVE SAFE AND SECURE HOUSING SO
WITH THIS FUNDING.
COUNTIES CAN CONTINUE AND EXPAND
ON EXISTING EFFORTS TO SERVE
THOSE CHILD WELFARE INVOLVE
FAMILY IS AN OLDER YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSICA --
ENZYME A MASTER'S LEVEL SOCIAL
WORKER I'VE BEEN IN FFA SOCIAL
WORKER FOR THE LAST SIX YEARS
THANK YOU DONNA AND I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT 75% OF THE CHILDREN
PLACED IN FOSTER CARE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO ARE NOT
IN RELATIVE.
CARE OUR PLACE THROUGH AT THE
FACE -- AND HAVE A SOCIAL
WORKERS SEE THEIR KIDS IN
FAMILIES USUALLY WEEKLY
SOMETIMES MULTIPLE TIMES A WEEK.
SO WE'RE KIND OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THIS -- SITUATION
IN ADDITION I AM ALSO FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH SO -- FOR ME AS
SOMEONE WHO WAS ABLE TO GET TO
COLLEGE AND OBTAINED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
AND TO FIGHT TO ALSO GET A
MASTER'S DEGREE -- TO ENTER A
FIELD THAT I TRULY AM PASSIONATE
ABOUT AND TO FINALLY GET HERE
AND THEN TO FIND THAT MY WAGES
ARE STAGNANT.
IS IS BEYOND DISAPPOINTING SO
DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE TO
ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHAT A GREAT SUCCESS STORY?
HI MY NAME IS GORDON RICHARDSON
I'M A SOCIAL WORKER WITH
UPLIFTED ON THE SERVICES -- WE
SUPPORT ON ALL THE ISSUES
THROUGH -- THAT WERE DISCUSSED
THIS AFTERNOON A FIVE THREE NINE
SPECIAL ATTENTION TO THE BFA
RATE INCREASE.
AND YOU KNOW TECHNOLOGY MATURES
A COMMENTS THAT THIS IS
COMPLETELY RATIONAL -- PART OF
THE REASON WE'RE HERE IS BECAUSE
FFA RATES ARE ONE OF THE VERY
FEW RATES THAT ARE NOT.
INCREASED WETTON COSTS INCREASE
ACCORDING TO SEE AN AYE INDEX.
AND THAT'S NOT RATIONAL.
AND I THINK THAT -- WE COULD
AVOID THIS IN THE FUTURE IF WE
LOOK AT THAT ISSUE AS WELL --
DEEPLY APPRECIATE YOU
CONSIDERING SUPPORT FOR THIS --
TWENTY SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING AND WHAT THE
PROCESS WITH A PROFOUNDLY
SERVICES WE PROVIDE SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BOTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND FOSTER ON
WERE ALSO FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THE IMPACT OF THE MINIMUM WAGE --
Là ON SOCIAL WORKERS AND FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES WE ALSO SUPPORT
ISSUES TWO THREE FOUR AND FIVE
AND ALL THE OTHERS ON THE LIST
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KRISTIN POWER THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUES THREE FOUR AND SIX AND
ALSO WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE DSS NON
DISCUSSION ITEMS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE OFFICE OF THE
BUT FIRST THEN AND ALSO GREATER
RESOURCES FOR A QUICK COMPLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO AT LEAST MADRID WITH
DESPAIR NET I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF A ISSUES TWO FOUR AND SIX I
WANT TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT
SHOULD NUMBER.
TWO I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO
WORK -- FOR THE TV PLUS PROGRAM
FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS OF MY
LIFE -- HAS.
ABOUT THE YOU KNOW I I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU GUYS REMEMBER IN THE
TIME FOR YOU KNOW WE HAD A
COUNTY MATCHING WE HAD THIS THIS
AND THAT.
I BREAKS MY HEART THAT.
WE HAVE YOUTH AMY MENTIONED
EARLIER FOUR HUNDRED YOU THAT
CAN I GET INTO THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS AN EXISTING PROGRAM YOU
KNOW EARLIER THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED THAT WE WANT TO SEE
RESULTS.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS
PROVEN YEAR AFTER YEAR THAT IT
IS EFFECTIVE THAT IT IS CHANGING
IN LIFE THAT IT IS.
CREATING THE OFFICE COULD CHANGE
THAT HAVE YOU KNOW WHETHER WE
LOOK AT IT FROM A FISCAL OR
HUMANITARIAN POINT OF VIEW IS
HAVING AN IMPACT.
RIGHT NOW I'M I'M ON THE
COACHING CONTRACT ACROSS THE
STATE AND COUNTY KEEPS THINGS
WITH.
WHY CAN'T WE SERVE MORE?
WE HAVE BEEN OPERATING WITH THE
SAME ALLOCATION SOME COUNTIES
FOR EIGHT NINE YEARS THAT.
BREAKS THE HEART TO TELL THE
YOUTH YOU KNOW WE CAN DO THAT I
BROUGHT A LOT OF OUR YOUTH WITH
ME EARLIER TODAY I TOLD THEM
THAT.
I CAN GO UP THERE AND SPEAK ALL
THEY WANT BUT YOUR VOICE TO THE
ONE THAT COUNTS.
BUT BECAUSE THEY WORK AND THEY
GO TO SCHOOL THEY HAD TO GO BACK
OP SO JUST ON BEHALF OF THEM I
INALL OF OUR YOUTH I WHEN I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT -- ISSUE
NUMBER TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALEXIS PETERS I WORK
WITH THE SPELLING OF HIS WHILE
I'M HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
OFFICE -- I HAVE BEEN IN THIS
FIELD FOR OVER SIXTEEN YEARS
I'VE DONE A LOT OF DIRECT WORK
BEFORE HE MOVED INTO MANAGEMENT.
AND I HAVE WATCHED THESE SHOES.
AGE EIGHTEEN GO INTO NOTHING.
AND THEY END UP ON THE STREETS.
ANYWAY I WILL TELL YOU OF YOU
PROBABLY KNOW BUT WE WILL
DEFINITELY SUPPORT ISSUES TWO
FOUR AND SIX AND LET'S HELP ALL
ARGUE PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN LUIS GONNA SPEAK ON ISSUES
TWO FOUR AND SIX A MAP THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOU
THEN THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION ESPECIALLY ON ISSUE.
FOR I'M IN A WHILE WE'RE SITTING
HERE SENT THE LANGUAGE OVER SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE WE CAN
CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION AND
MEETS I'M ACCORDINGLY AND BEFORE
THE IN THE MONTHS THAT THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR TIME INTENTIONS
DETAIL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MERRY FRAME I AM A
CURRENTLY DIRECTOR OF QUALITY
ASSURANCE YEAH I AM A FORMER
SOCIAL WORKER WHO WORKED IN --
AND LIVES IN SAN MARINO COUNTY
THAT HIS SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WORKING WITH CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL HEALTHCARE NEEDS AND
OTHER NEEDY CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE FROM.
ZERO TO TWENTY ONE AND WE ARE
SPENDING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME WE SEE THEM ONCE A WEEK WE
HAVE CONTACT WITH THEM EVERY DAY
THESE ARE EXTREMELY NEEDY KIDS.
AND THE SOCIAL WORKERS NEED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE WHAT THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THESE CHILDREN.
AND I AM ABSOLUTELY ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF TWO THREE AND FOUR I
WORK WITH EMANCIPATED FORCED
FOSTER YOUTH IN A HIGH DESERT
AREA OF SIMMERING DINO.
AND I SEE THE YOUTH WHO COULD
NOT GET INTO THP THE NUMBER OF
KIDS ON A WAIT LIST DOESN'T EVEN
TOUCH BECAUSE THERE ARE A WHOLE
BUNCH OF KIDS THAT NEVER EVEN
MADE IT TO THE WAIT LIST.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO POINT TO GET
ON THE WAIT LIST SO THEY HAVE TO
FIND SOMETHING ELSE IF IF
POSSIBLE.
SO THAT NUMBER IS ACTUALLY
PROBABLY NOT THE MOST ACCURATE.
AND SO WE SUPPORT ALL OF THESE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OPERATORS HAVE GUESTS WITH
SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES ARE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WAS HERE
EARLIER TODAY.
I IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
INCREASE IN WAGES FOR THE FOSTER
FAMILY SOCIAL WORKERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CRISTO NUMBER IT'S CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF JOB AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE AND OF COURSE SIX THE
FOSTER CARE RATES INCREASE.
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE A
CONTINUATION OF THE BRING HOME
FAMILIES.
A PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO A CHAD BELLEROSE C. S.
BERNETT TO BOTH A DIRECTOR OF MY
FRESNO OFFICE AND A RESOURCE
PARENT MYSELF THE LAST TWELVE
YEARS SERVICE SEVENTEEN ALL
RIGHT NOW THAT'S GETTING READY
FOR COLLEGE.
AND IT'S BEEN A A WORLD WHEN
THERE BUT IT'S SHOWS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THOSE THE
STABILITY IN THAT CONTINUUM OF
CARE FROM WORKERS AND SO IN
SUPPORT SPECIFICALLY OF TWO FOUR
AND SIX AND I CAN'T REALLY SAY
ANYTHING MORE THAN THAT WORKERS
AND OTHERS HAVE ALREADY SAID
BEFORE AND THE IMPORTANCE.
IN THE RATIONALE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING DIANNE WARREN A
SPARE NET FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
WE HAVE LOCATIONS IN SACRAMENTO.
SAN JOAQUIN FRESNO TULARE KERN
LOS ANGELES SAM BERNIE DINO --
MONTEREY CONTRA COSTA VENTURA
COUNTIES I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUES TWO FOUR AND SIX AND I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE
CONVERSATION AND CONCERN TODAY
THAT WAS SHOWN. FOR YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE -- WAS VERY HEART
WARMING FOR ME TO HEAR YOUR YOUR
ALL YOUR CONCERN -- FOR FOR OUR
YOUTH AND AND IN PARTICULAR TO
FOR ITEM NUMBER.
SIX OUR COUNTIES ARE LOOKING TO
FF FACE FOR THE FAMILIES FOR
THESE CHILDREN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THESE KIDS ARE COMING OUT
CONGREGATE CARE.
THEY'RE RELYING ON FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES TO HAVE THE FAMILIES
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FOR THESE
YOUTH AND THE FAMILIES.
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE THE RATE
INCREASE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE THERE TO
TO OFFER THAT SO I I FEEL LIKE
IT'S VITAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON PEAK MASS BUT TO
LOW WITH A SPEAR IN IT AND ALL I
OVERSEE THE GREATER BAY AREA
OFFICE.
WE PROVIDE SERVICES TO OF THE
WHOLE BAY AREA COUNTIES.
OF I HAVE BEEN IN AND AROUND.
CHILDREN FAMILY SERVICES.
FOR THE ONE THREE THIS THIRTY
FIVE YEARS ON THE PRIVATE SIDE.
MY WIFE AND I BETWEEN THE SOCIAL
WORKERS WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
RESOURCE FAMILIES SINCE -- TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WE'VE HAD.
ADOPTED GUARDIANSHIP AND
FOSTERED.
OVER. SEVENTEEN CHILDREN.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT. TWO FOUR IN
SIX IN SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE WE
ARE IN THE BAY AREA.
REALLY IS CHALLENGING TO RECRUIT
AND HIRE SOCIAL WORKERS WHO WITH
THE COST OF HOUSING WITHIN THE
BAY AREA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO AGAIN JORDAN WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION WANTING
TO SHOW OUR ORGANIZATION SUPPORT
ON THE NON DISCUSSION ITEM ISSUE
TEN ON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL ON THE OFFICE OF
FOSTER CARE -- BUT IT'S OFFICE --
JUST PERSONAL PER -- PERSPECTIVE
ON IT I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
POSSIBLE RIGHTS UNTIL I WAS
INVOLVED IN CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTION WAS IN THE SYSTEM
SINCE NINE AN AGED OUT.
AND ON FOR EVEN THOUGH I WASN'T
ABLE TO LEARN ABOUT MY RIGHTS
AND I KNOW ABOUT THE FOSTER ON
BUT IT'S OFFICE HOTLINE I WAS
ABLE TO SHARE THIS INFORMATION
WITH MY YOUNGER SIBLINGS WERE
STONE CARE.
AND FOR FUTURE USE WILL BE
ENTERING THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
SO JUST GOT ONE IT SHOWS A POOR
ON ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR THEM
THAT'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
HI AM J. BERLIN I'M CEO OF
ALTERNATIVE FAMILY SERVICES AND
FFA IN ADOPTION AGENCY IN THE
BAY AREA ALSO HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON ITEM SIX
THE MINIMUM WAGE BUT IN A WAY
ALL THE ITEMS THAT YOU'RE OR
MANY OF THE ITEMS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY REALLY INTO RELATED.
YOUR SISTER IS QUITE RIGHT THE
SOCIAL WORKERS DO ALL THE WORK
THE IF IN FACT WE ARE LOOKING AT
CC OR IN A COMPREHENSIVE WAY AND
YOU ARE LOOKING TO TRY AND
RETURN.
THAT CHILDREN TO FAMILY BASED
SETTINGS IT'S THE SOCIAL WORKERS
TO CREATE THIS FAMILY BASS
SETTINGS THE RETENTION OF FOSTER.
FAMILIES IS BASED IN -- ALMOST
DIRECTLY ON THE LEVEL SUPPORT
THEY RECEIVE FROM THE SOCIAL
WORKERS THE APPROVAL OF NEW
FAMILIES IS DONE.
UP A BY SOCIAL WORKERS THE
MINIMUM WAGE IS A MAJOR
WORKFORCE ISSUE FOR US BUT EVEN
WITHIN A LARGER CONTEXT I WOULD
I WOULD -- I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LOOK AT THE ROLE OF THE FAA
WITHIN THE C. C. R. I DON'T
THINK IT IS A HEAD THAT HAS BEEN
PAID A SUFFICIENT.
ATTENTION. TO DATE.
AS WELL YOU KNOW WHAT.
START HERE THIS MORNING IN THE
CONVERSATION ON IT ITEM NUMBER
ONE SO WITHIN THAT CONTEXT
THANKS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS MARYLAND
SEX AN ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA YOUTH AND
FAMILY PROGRAMS WERE BASED OUT
OF BUTTE COUNTY AND SHASTA
COUNTY AS WELL -- DEFINITELY
HERE FOR THE INCREASE IN THE FFA
SOCIAL WORKER SALARIES YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT HOW
IMPORTANT THEY ARE.
AND HOW MUCH THEIR RELEASE
COMPLETELY INVOLVED WITH -- THE
CHILD AND ALSO AS A PREVIOUS
FOSTER CHILD WAY BACK IN THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES -- IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN SUCH A BLESSING
TO HAVE ALL THESE THINGS IN
PLACE FOR ME WHEN I TURNED --
EIGHTEEN BUT I DIDN'T HAVE THAT.
BUT SO ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN
DO TO IMPROVE THE LIVES AND THAT --
OUTCOMES OF THESE FOSTER YOUTH
WE SHOULD BE DOING WHETHER IT'S
THE REUNIFICATION OF THE FAMILY
AND IF WE CAN'T DO THAT THEN
SUPPORTING THOSE KIDS IN
PROVIDING THE BEST OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM FOR THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LEE CSE SO I'D AND I
AM A RESOURCE FOR THEM.
I HAVE TWELVE CHILDREN AND EIGHT
WHICH ARE IN THE HOME RIGHT NOW.
FIVE OF THOSE I AM IN THE
PROCESS OF ADOPTING TO THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AND SADLY MY CHILDREN CONTINUE
TO KEEP HAVING A LOSS OF AND
CARING ADULTS IN THEIR LIFE.
THEY THIS LOSS OF THE CARING
ADULTS ARE LIFE IS SPECIFICALLY
HAPPENING.
BECAUSE OF THE LOSS OF THE
SOCIAL WORKERS THAT HAVE WORKED
WITH THAT.
SINCE MY FIVE CHILDREN HAVE.
BEEN PLACE WITH ME THAT I'M THE
ADOPTING AND WE HAVE LOST.
THE STATE HAD LOST FIVE SOCIAL
WORKERS TO JUST IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN AS THEY HAD TO
LEAVE.
WITH -- TAPE GATE HAVE BETTER
EMPLOYMENT.
AND THE ONE SOCIAL WORKER I DID
FIND HER.
AND WHEN WE CALL TURN OVER
WRITER OUR DRIVER IF HE WAS THE
UBER DRIVER AND IT JUST BROKE MY
HEART TO HEAR LIKE IN TO SEE.
THAT SOMEONE WHO SHOULD BE A
PROVIDERS OF SELF CARE IS UNABLE
TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS GERRY
MCCULLOUGH OF REPRESENT AFS
FAMILY SERVICES ALTERNATIVE
FAMILY SERVICES -- I WOULD LIKE
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF TWO FOUR AND
SIX HEARD A LOT FROM -- PREVIOUS
FOSTER -- FOSTER YOUTH -- I WAS
OUT OF FOSTER YOUTH BUT MY
MOTHERWAS SO I'M MORE
GENERATION REMOVED -- AND I HAVE
RATED AND PROGRESSED TO BE A
SOCIAL WORKER AND DIRECTOR A
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SO.
THE SAYING THAT -- THERE A LOT
OF YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE WHO LOOK.
LIKE ME THERE ARE A LOT OF
MINORITIES A LOT OF MALES AND
FEMALES A LOOK LIKE ME AND IN
ORDER TO MY MOTHER DIDN'T HAVE
THAT.
I'M I'M GOOD WITH A TIME WHERE
THERE WERE NO IF A PHASE SO SHE
TO HAVE SOMEBODY TO COME AND
CHECK ON HER EVERY WEEK -- A. B.
IN THE TRENCHES WITH THEIR SOUL --
I WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT SIX
BECAUSE A LOT OF US.
WITHOUT THAT YOU WON'T SEE A LOT
OF US THEY WILL GET A CHANCE TO
SEE THEMSELVES AND SEE WHAT
SUCCESS LOOKS LIKE.
SO.
IN SAYING THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HECTOR LUIS MIGHT
THE US JUNIOR.
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF FOSTER
CARE FOR AN FFA TLC.
AND COME BEFORE YOU BECAUSE I
HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH SOME OF THE MOST
AMAZING AND MOST SACRIFICIAL
SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE ODDS -- DO IT.
FOR LITTLE TO NOTHING.
AND THEY ALSO LAST THAT LONG
LITTLE TO NOTHING AND SO I'M
HERE SUPPORTING TWO THREE FOUR
AND SIX AND PARKING ON SIX SO
THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN THE
CONTINUITY.
AND THE CHILDREN THAT WE KNOW
LOVE AND CHOOSE TO SURF.
THANK YOU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
EIGHT THE BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
PROGRAMS THEY'VE HAS TO MORE
THAN SIXTY FAMILIES UTILIZING
THE FUNDING.
AS WELL AS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NINE THE CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
TRAINING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS YURI
CAMERA AND I OVERSEE A FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA -- WE'VE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT TURN OVER SOCIAL
WORKERS OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
MANY CITING SALARY AS A REASON
FOR DEPARTURE.
OUR FAMILIES OFTEN STATE THAT
THE STRONG RELATIONSHIPS THAT
THEY HAVE WITH SOCIAL WORKERS AS
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS THAT
THEY ARE SATISFIED.
AND ABLE TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
AND STABILIZE YOUTH IN THEIR
CARE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THEY HAVE
STATED HIGH SOCIAL WORKER
TURNOVER IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CONCERNS.
SOCIAL WORKER STABILITY AS HAS
BEEN STATED ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTS
THE STABILITY OF YOUTH IN OUR
CARE AND THE RETENTION OF
RESOURCE PARENTS THAT WE
CRITICALLY NEED.
AND SO I SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE IMPACT OF
THE MINIMUM WAGE LOSS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA HARRIS
FAMINE FFA SOCIAL WORKER.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE SIX THE
INCREASED WAGES FOR FFA SOCIAL
WORKERS.
AT THE CONSTANT TURNOVER DO LOW
WAGES ARE NEGATIVELY IMPACTS THE
STABILITY OF YOUTH -- AND BIRTH
FAMILIES AS WELL AS BEING ABLE
TO RETAIN RESOURCE FAMILIES --
AND ALSO IMPACTS THE CASELOADS
AND QUALITY OF SERVICE OF THE
REMAINING SOCIAL WORKERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS FOR CARDINAL
AND AND I'M A FFA SOCIAL WORKER
INTERN -- I MEAN IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER SIX I'M A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AS WELL -- WHO WAS
INSPIRED TO PURSUE MY MASTERS OF
SOCIAL WORK UP I'LL BE
GRADUATING IN MAY YEAH -- IN SO
A YOU KNOW I'M I'M JUST HERE TO
REALLY SAY THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I WAS
FILTERING THROUGH SERVICES AT A
TIME FFA SOCIAL WORKERS WERE NOT
A THING -- IN WHICH I'VE TURNED
EIGHTEEN AND DIDN'T HAVE A
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN AND SO IT'S
VERY DETRIMENTAL TO A YOU FLOOR
FILTERING TO SERVICES SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU CONGRATULATIONS.
HELLO -- I'M DOCTOR LAURA
HEIGHTS I AM A CEO OF A FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY WE PROVIDE
SERVICES THROUGH THE SACRAMENTO
REGION.
AND I ACTUALLY AM IN SUPPORT OF
ALL OF THE ISSUES ADDRESSED HERE
ARE FOSTERING YOUTH REALLY NEED
EVERYTHING WE CAN GIVE THEM TO
BE SO -- SUCCESSFUL AND WE IN IN
TURN ARE OBLIGATED TO SERVE
THESE FOSTER YOUTH IN THE BEST
WAY POSSIBLE.
IN PARTICULAR ISSUE NUMBER SIX
IS OF URGENT.
NEED FOR US SO -- I'M REALLY
HOPING THAT YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS OUR
SALARY ISSUES FOR OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WHAT?
ROB GETTY I WORK FOR A LARGE
STATEWIDE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY I
OVERSEE OUR ADOPTION PROGRAM WE
HAVE FIFTEEN OFFICES STATEWIDE.
JUST RAN THE NUMBERS OF TURN
OVER WITH OUR SOCIAL WORKERS --
THE LAST FIVE YEARS IT'S BEEN
DOUBLE DIGIT TURN OVER WITH OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS.
AND OF THOSE OF THAT TURN OVER
DOUBLE DIGIT TURN OVER. 59% HAVE
LEFT. FOR OTHER STATE COUNTY
JOBS HOSPITALS AND WE CAN'T
COMPETE WITH OF SALARIES WITH
WHERE THE RATE IS NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I THINK ISSUE NUMBER SIX IS A
VERY POPULAR.
ONE SO I WOULD ASK THAT IF YOU
IF IF THAT'S THE ONE YOU WANT TO
SPEAK ON WOULD YOU GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND
THE ME [inaudible]
TOO THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I AM LAURA
RICHARDSON I'M WITH QUEEN ANNE
OF FAMILY SERVICES AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE.
SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M JUST GONNA
LEARN WITH QUEEN IF IN A
SERVICES AND SUPPORT A NUMBER
SIX AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M DAVE WESSON I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE FOSTER PARENTS
BECAUSE SO I WAS A FOSTER PARENT --
MANY YEARS AGO WHEN.
I WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE --
CONTRIBUTION A DIFFERENCE IN MY
COMMUNITY AND SO I TOOK IN A OF
OF FOSTER CHILDREN PARTICULARLY
AT TEENAGERS THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE WERE PROBATION CHOOSE THE
TEENAGERS.
AND I WOULD HAVE NEVER MADE IT
IF IT HADN'T BEEN FOR FOSTER
PARENTS OF FOR THE SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT KEPT ME IN THE GAME
SO I WON SAID NUMBER
[inaudible]
SIX THANKS.
GOOD EVENING CARRY OUT I MEAN
THAT'S WITH ONLY PUT FAMILIES
I'M IN SUPPORT OF ALL THE ISSUES
INCLUDING TEN BUT PARTICULARLY --
NUMBER SIX WE ARE CRITICAL TO
THE VISION AND MISSION OF CCAR
AND SERVING OUR CHILDREN FOR
SAFETY PERMANENCY AND WELL BEING
SO APPRECIATED THANK YOU THANK
YOU IT'S CLEAR WITHOUT YOU CAN'T
[inaudible]
CAN'T SUCCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOR MY
THE GAY AND THE FOUNDER OF A
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY BASED IN
LOS ANGELES AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT NUMBER.
SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OFTEN
A MEDINA AND I'M AN
ADMINISTRATOR FOR AN FFA IN THE
CITY OF ORANGE.
I'M ALSO HERE TO SUPPORT ISSUE
NUMBER SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A
SPENT ON SUBTLETY GUESS I'M A
SUPERVISORFOR THE LA OFFICE.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF NUMBER SIX
AND I ALSO HAVE TO TELL YOU THIS
BUT I AGREE WITH YOUR SYSTEM
WILL FUND THE SOCIAL WORKERS DO
ALL THE WORK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF A BIGGER
TOO MUCH CREDIT.
SHE'S GONNA BE WATCHING THE TAPE
LATER.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DAILY NEWS ON
TV AND I AM A MSW SOCIAL WORKER
WITH REALLY PUT FAMILIES I'VE
WORKED -- WITH AGENCY FOR ABOUT
TWELVE YEARS AND I THINK THE
MOST ALARMING THING I'VE SEEN
SPECIFICALLY MOST RECENTLY IS
THE LACK OF ATTENTION WE'VE HAD
OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE KIDS THAT WE SERVE COME FROM
HISTORIES OF TRAUMA AND ABUSE
AND THEY NEED ATTACHMENT AND
CONSISTENCY AND THEY'RE JUST I'M
NOT GETTING THAT.
AND A BIG PART OF THAT IS
BECAUSE OF THE A LACK OF OF
DECENT WAGES I I ACTUALLY LEFT
THE AGENCIES.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO TO GO PURSUE
HEALTH CARE WHERE I COULD HAVE --
INCREASES AND NOW I AM STAGNANT
IN MY SALARY BUT I'VE COME BACK
BECAUSE I LOVE THE WORK AND I
LOVE WHAT WE DO SO THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMY HEILEMAN
FROM CHILDREN'S BUREAU SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY KERN RIVER SIDE.
NUMBER MEDINA AND WE SUPPORT
NUMBER ALL OF THEM BUT NUMBER
SIX PARTICULAR THANK YOU.
HELLO BILL RICHARDSON A CORNEA
FAMILY SERVICES.
OF ME TO ON NUMBER SIX THANK YOU.
UNDER JOHN'S FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LANCER CHILDREN FAMILY SERVICES
WHO WHO BROUGHT YOU ISSUE SIX
TODAY I ALSO WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE EXPRESSED OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
A NON DISCUSSION ITEMS THAT THE
BIGGER THE BCP'S THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ON
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
SUPPORTING THE FORFEITURE OF
WHICH WOULD PROGRAM.
AND ITS EXPANSION IT'S NOT
COMMITTEE ISSUED TEN BECAUSE
IT'S IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR THE
CHILDREN TO KNOW THEY HELP SOME
PLACE TO COOK TO CALL IN
ADDITION TO THEIR THEIR SOCIAL
WORKERS THANK YOU [inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
WELL.
YOU WERE THE LAST.
ONE WELL I I DO WANT TO THANK.
ALL OF YOU -- FOR YOUR CONTINUED.
ADVOCACY AND AND WORK IN THIS
AREA IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT WHEN YOU YOU'VE
GOT A FINITE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO FIGURE OUT
TO YOU KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING
TO BALANCE IT OUT.
WELL I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT SOME
OF THESE OVER LAP.
AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
ALL OF THESE SERVICES JUST
FIGURE OUT HOW THE BUDGET IS
GOING TO BE -- SET UP SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE OVERLAP IN THE
DUPLICATION -- THE ISSUE NUMBER
SIX EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND IT
JUST IT DOES SEEM LIKE AN
OVERSIGHT.
THAT NEEDS TO BE REMEDIED BUT I
AGAIN I THANK YOU ALL AND I
THINK OUR SOCIAL WORKERS BECAUSE
JUST LIKE ROSA SAID.
YOU ARE THE ONES WHO DO ALL THE
WORK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
ALL -- THIS WEEK I DO WANT TO
REITERATE OR I WANT TO SAY
BECAUSE I DID NOT SAY IT BEFORE.
THAT THE ISSUES A WILL BE HELD
OPEN.
I THANK YOU ALL.
THIS CONCLUDES TODAY'S HEARING.
THE TO TAKE EVEN THE USER ESTHER